OKAY. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET OF REVIEW A CONDOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE THE KOBE
NINE EMERGE. PROTECTOR FOR LIKE
AND- WE ARE LIMITING THE NON
GET. AND IT HEARING TOO SO
DISTANCING AND COVERING GUY. SO
THIS HAS MADE NO. JUST TO OUR
NEW PRESS IS TO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN TO ACT TO OUR PRO. WE ARE
HOLDING. OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND FOR
TODAY'S HEARING BYE BYE I
UNDERSTAND ALL OF THE MEMBERS
ARE PARTICIPATING. HERE IN
PERSON NINE WILL BE REMOTE- WE
ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND AS
THEY ARE USED TO WE ASKED THEM
TO PLEASE MUTE THEIR PHONES AND
COMPUTERS TO ELIMINATE ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. A-ANT WHEN. DURING
OUR- DISCRETION IF EITHER
DEPARTMENT FINANCE EARLIER
WANTS TO SPEAK OR BE RECOGNIZED
PLEASE USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE. AND ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING SPEAKING. R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON ME WHEN YOU'RE DONE. AND
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN E
SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU CAN ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. SO TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ALLOWED
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY. ON TODAY BY PHONE.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS PART. POSTED
ON THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT
ONE EIGHT. TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN.
N. FOR INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE THAT TELECONFERENCES TERM
YOU CAN LOOK AT OUR- BUDGET
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IN ORDER
FOR US TO HEAR THOSE OF YOU
CALLING IN CLEARLY. PLEASE
AGAIN- MUTE YOUR THE DEVICE
THAT YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
LISTENING TO THE HEARING AT THE
SAME. YOU KNOW TO MUTE IT WHILE
YOU ARE SPEAKING TO US. AND-
YES I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED
AND WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
IN AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE
SOME LAG TIMES. WITH OUR I. T.
EQUIPMENT OR AS- FOLKS ARE
CALLING IN OR ADJUSTING SO
WE'LL ALL BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. NOW BEFORE WE BEGIN
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MR
STEPPING SURE OR COMMITTEE
CONSULT WITH YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS DINNER FIVE
HERE SKINNER HERE NELSON
CABRERO. CORTESE DOLLY ALI HERE
THE RATHER BROTHER HERE FIGMENT.
I CAME HERE GROW HAIR GROVE
HERE CALM WATER HERE COME OVER
HERE LAYERED HERE LEHRER HERE
ENQUIRE. MELINDA'S HERE LINDA'S
HERE MAN MAN HERE NEWMAN HERE
NO MAN HERE CONTROLLABLE. THE
CHURCH HERE PAN PAN HERE STERN.
STERN HERE BY CAL SKI HERE THE
CAST HERE. CAN WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED RECORDS YES THANK
YOU MR CONSULT. ALL RIGHT.
TODAY'S SENATE. BUDGET DANTE
SKEWS ME MY NOTES JUMPED. TODAY
SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL BE TAKING ACTION
ON THE LEGISLATURE'S VERSION OF
THE STATE BUDGET FOR THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO FISCAL YEAR. OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ALL BEEN
WORKING EXTREMELY HARD HOURS IN
HEARINGS AND READING MATERIALS
TALKING TO STAKEHOLDERS AND I
REALLY WANT TO APPRECIATE AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT. GOOD WORK I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE STAFF.
FOR BOTH PARTIES. FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YOUR EXCELLENT WORK IS ALSO
HIGHLY APPRECIATED AND WE KNOW
YOU'VE SACRIFICED MANY NIGHTS
AND WEEKENDS INCLUDING MEMORIAL
DAY WEEKEND TO GET US READY FOR
TODAY. AND TO ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE WHO
MANY WHO HAVE ADVOCATED FOR
YEARS FOR ITEMS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET. AND
WHO HAVE SHARED THEIR INSIGHTS.
THAT EITHER HEARING SIR CAUCUS
MEETINGS OR TO THE OUR BUDGET
SET CHAIRS. AND TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS WHOSE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS ARE INVALUABLE I JUST
WANT TO EXPRESS MY THANKS AND I
KNOW THAT- THOSE THANKS WHICH
ARE EXPRESSED BY. ALL OF US IN
THE COMMITTEE. I'M. OUR AGENDA
IN ACTION TODAY REPRESENT A
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
AGREEMENT WITH THE ASSEMBLY.
AND WE ARE THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES ALSO MEETING TODAY
AND WE WILL BE ACTING IN FACT
VERY COMPARABLY. THAT WILL
ALLOW US THEN TO HAVE A TWO
PARTY AGREEMENT THAT WE CAN
THEN. IN A CAGE THEN WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO GET TO OUR
POINT OF A FULL THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT AND ADOPTION BY OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE OF
JUNE. JUNE FIFTEENTH. I'M. NOW
LET ME KNOW IF YOU THINKS OUR
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET IS BASED ON
THE REVENUE ESTIMATES BY OUR
FELLOW. AND WE HAVE HAD
CONFIDENCE IN THOSE ESTIMATES
THEN WE'VE LOOKED AT THEM OVER
TIME THEY HAVE BEEN VERY
ACCURATE AND IF ANYTHING THEY
HAVE BEEN UNDER. WHAT THE
REVENUES WE'VE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED. D. LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
CONTINUES. THE DEMOCRATS
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING AND IT
HAS. TWENTY FIVE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN OUR RESERVE FUNDS.
GROWING TO THIRTY FIVE BILLION
BY TWO TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
WE ALSO FULLY PAY OFF SCHOOL
DEFERRALS IN PRE PAY SOME
PENSION AND OTHER DEBTS. THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET THERE WILL
BE ACTING ON TODAY ALSO RETAINS
AND BUILDS ON THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THAT WERE PRESENTED
TO US WITH THE MARY VICE. WE
EMBRACE OF COURSE THE
GOVERNOR'S GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TWO POINT OH THOSE-
THE ACTION THAT WOULD PROVIDE
FUNDS TO OUR FAMILIES OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND INCOME
BELOW. THE SMALL BUSINESS AND
NONPROFIT GRANTS AND MUCH MUCH
MORE. BUT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE ADDED ON. OUR FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION AREA WHERE WE
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF CHILD
CARE SLOTS TO SUPPORT MORE
CHILDREN. AS WELL AS PROVIDING
READING CREASES FOR OUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS. AND WE EMBRACE
THE PROPOSAL FOR UNIVERSAL
TRANSITION- KINDERGARTEN TKT
FOR THE FOUR YEAR OLDS WE
MODIFY IT SOUNDSA LITTLE
DIFFERENT VISION. AND PROVIDING
SOME OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES. NO
THIS BUDGET INCLUDES A RECORD
NINETY SIX POINT ONE BILLION
FOR PROP NINETY EIGHT- WHICH-
OBVIOUSLY IS. A UNPRECEDENTED
AMOUNT IN CALIFORNIA OF PER
PUPIL SPENDING BUT WE ALSO
INCLUDE SUPPORT TO ASSIST AND
RETAIN OUR TEACHERS. AND TO
MOVE TOWARDS A GOAL OF
PROVIDING. UNIVERSAL SCHOOL
MEALS TO ALL OF OUR K. TWELVE
STUDENTS. THIS BUDGET ALSO
PROVIDES UNPRECEDENTED
FINANCIAL AID EXPANSION TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS ACHIEVE DEBT FREE
COLLEGE. IN AN EXPANSE THE
GOVERNOR'S ACTION ON
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING BY
PROVIDING MULTI YEAR INVESTMENT
TO HELP HOUSE OR ON HOUSE
RESIDENTS AND PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. UNDER BUDGET
RECOGNIZES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AGE FIFTY
AND ABOVE THAT MEET MEDICAL
INCOME ELIGIBILITY DESERVE THAT
COVERAGE. I'M WE ALSO CLEARLY
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO
SUPPORT SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN CLIMATE RESILIENCY IN WATER
IN DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION IN.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN ALL
FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION AS WELL
AS SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS AND WE SUPPORT OUR
LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS WITH
INCREASED INVESTMENTS TO
ALLEVIATE HUNGER ELIMINATE MANY
FEES PROVIDE EXPANDED ACCESS TO
LEGAL AID AND OTHER JUSTICE
SERVICES. EACH THE PAYMENT
TOWARD DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
RESIDENTS AND SO MUCH MORE. NOW
I WANT TO NOTE FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO HAVE LOOKED AT OUR DETAILED
AGENDA. THIS AGENDA REFLECTS
THOSE ITEMS THAT ARE SUB
COMMITTEES DID NOT CLOSE OUT IN
OTHER WORDS THAT WERE LEFT
OPEN. FOR THAT MIGHT HAVE HAD
TO BE MODIFIED- IT ALSO
FINALIZES THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET ARCHITECTURE. AND
COMBINED FOR THOSE OF YOU MAY
BE LOOKING OKAY WELL WE'RE YOU
KNOW WE DON'T SEE EVERY SINGLE
ACTION HERE THAT'S BECAUSE
TODAY'S ACTIONS COMBINED WITH
THE BUDGETSUBS PREVIOUS
ACTIONS OR THEN WILL THAT BE
THE BASIS. FOR THE BUDGET BILLS
IN TRAILER BILLS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE. IN FACT THE
REFLECTS THE LEGISLATURE'S
BUDGET. AND THEN ALLOWS US TO
ENGAGE IN THOSE ACTIVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION BETWEEN NOW AND
OUR FINAL BUDGET VOTE ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH. THEN WEALL I'M SURE
AND I PERSONALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO A FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR REFLECTING
OUR SHARED PRIORITIES. NOW TO
START WE HAVE TO DISCUSSION
ITEMS RELATED TO THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT'S FRAMEWORK. AND
AFTER HEARING THOSE ITEMS WERE
HERE BOTH OF THEM. WILL THEN
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH FIFTEEN
MINUTES OF PUBLIC COMMENT.
BEYOND FOLLOWING THAT WE WILL
VOTE ON THOSE ITEMS. WE WILL
THEN HAVE THE VOTE ONLY ISSUES
TAKEN UP BY SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
BEFORE WE VOTE SO IN OTHER
WORDS WILL DO THE FIRST TWO
ITEMS PUBLIC COMMENT VOTE THEN
START SEPT ONE. AND WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT BOX FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES ON SEPT ONE.
AND THEN VOTE. AND THAT THE
SAME PROCESS FOR THE REST OF
THE ITEMS AND GIVEN THAT WE
WOULD REALLY ASK THOSE FOLKS IN
THE PUBLIC WHO WANT TO SHARE
THEIR ACTS YOU KNOW JOIN WITH
US AND EXPRESSING SOMETHING
PUBLICLY WE REALLY HOPE THAT
YOU CAN BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE
AND BASICALLY JUST SAY YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND WHAT
DO YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE AN
ACTION AND IF IT'S REALLY
NECESSARY TO ADD A LITTLE
DETAIL WE'D REALLY APPRECIATE
IF YOU CAN STATE UNDER A
MINUTE. BECAUSE WE ONLY ARE
GIVING FIFTEEN MINUTES TO EACH
OF THOSE SEGMENTS AND ANY ONE
INDIVIDUAL WHO CALLS IN AND
TAKES UP A LOT OF TIME IS
CUTTING OUT THE TIME FOR OTHERS
SO I'LL BE STRICT ABOUTTHAT
TIMING- THE MAJORITY OF ITEMS
ON THE BOAT ONLY WERE DISCUSSED
AND VETTED IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
ITEMS ON TODAY'S AGENDA THE
NOTE THAT DOWN AS WE ARE IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. ALL ACTIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO RECONCILIATION
CORRECTIONS AND POTENTIALLY
TECHNICAL CHANGES SO LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE FIRST TWO
DISCUSSION ITEMS WHICH ARE THE
BUDGET FRAMEWORK AND PROP
NINETY EIGHT SO I MEAN TO BEGIN
WITH ASKING THE LA- TO PRESENT
BUT BEFORE THE LA- DOES PRESENT
I REALLY WANT TO EXPRESS MY
THANKS TO THE LA- IN THE ALLEY-
STAFF THIS YEAR THE LA O'S
OFFICE HAS BEEN PARTICULARLY
HELPFUL TO BOTH HOUSES IN
ADVISING US. IN CRAFTING OUR
BUDGET AND ITS ARCHITECTURE
EXCELLENT WORK REALLY
APPRECIATE IT- ALL RIGHT SIR
ELLIOTT WHICH. YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT MY- OKAY. MISTER WITH YOU
SAY DAY YEAH AND- IT ENDED YOU
CAN. X. AND GET PEDICLE ANALYST
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND SO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE WITH YOU
I WAS TO PROVIDE. AN OVERVIEW.
AS THE- CHAIR SAID OF THE FOR
TO GET ON YOUR AGENDA. BUT
ISSUE- IS LEGISLATIVE PACKAGES
SECTION REGARDING REVENUES AND
PROPOSITION TO THE BUDGET
FRAMEWORK. AND THEN THE SECOND
ISSUE IS- DESCRIPTION OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PACKAGE. SO I'LL
BEGIN WITH THE REVENUES- AS THE
CHAIR SAID THAT LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE USES THE REVENUE
ESTIMATES FROM OUR OFFICE- OVER
IT'S A BUDGET WINDOW FROM
THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO OUR OFFICES MAY
REVENUE ESTIMATES WERE HIGHER
THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
BY ABOUT FOUR BILLION. IN
ADDITION THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE FACTORS IN ABOUT FOUR
BILLION YEAH FINAL TAX PAYMENTS
THAT WERE RECEIVED IN APRIL AND
MAY AFTER WE CLOSE THE BOOKS ON
OUR FORECAST. THIS ADDITIONAL
EIGHT MILLION IN REVENUE WOULD
BE OFFSET IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE BY THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TWO POINT NO PAYMENTS
WHICH TOTAL ABOUT EIGHT BILLION-
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE COUNTS
THE PAYMENT OF THOSE- THE
DISBURSEMENT OF THOSE PAYMENTS
AS A REDUCTION IN REVENUE. SO
ON NET AFTER YOU ACCOUNT FOR
THESE VARIOUS ITEMS OUR REVENUE
ESTIMATES ACROSS THE BUDGET
WINDOW ARE ACTUALLY VERY
SIMILAR TO- THE- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE DIFFERENCE OF LESS
THAN A HUNDRED MILLION. I CAN
OFFER A COUPLE OF BRIEF
COMMENTS ON OUR ON OUR REVENUE
FORECASTS- IN MAY WHEN WE
COMPLETED OUR ESTIMATES WE
DETERMINED THAT THE SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN STATE REVENUES THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST YEAR
WAS MORE LIKELY THAN NOTTO BE
SUSTAINED IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
OUR ASSESSMENT OF THIS IS
CONSISTENT WE THANK WEST- THE
CONSENSUS VIEW OF ECONOMISTS
WHICH GENERALLY ARE EXPECTING
ROBUST ECONOMIC GROWTH OVER THE
NEXT YEAR- THE ECONOMY IS
HELPED ALONG RIGHT NOW BYE
SUBSTANTIAL FEDERAL FISCAL
STIMULUS AND THE CONTINUATION
OF LOW INTEREST RATES THAT
WE'RE SEEING THROUGHOUT THE
ECONOMY. AND- BY STATEMENTS
FROM OUR CENTRAL RESERVES-
CHAIR. AS WE LOOK FURTHER AHEAD
IN OUR MULTI YEAR ESTIMATE OF
REVENUES WE ASSUME THAT GENERAL
FUND REVENUES WILL GROW AT AN
AVERAGE ANNUAL RATE OF ABOUT 4%
NO THAT'S ACTUALLY SOMEWHAT
LOWER THAN THE TWENTY YEAR
HISTORICAL AVERAGE- IN THE
GENERAL FUND REVENUES IN OUR
ESTIMATES AT THE END OF THE-
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
PERIOD. WOULD REACH TWO HUNDRED
AND SIX POINT SEVEN BILLION
WHICH IS ABOUT TWENTY BILLION
HIGHER THAN THE DEPARTMENT OFRIPPED US FINANCES ESTIMATES AT
THE END OF THE MULTI YEAR
PERIOD. A KEY REASON FOR THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. THE
ESTIMATES FROM OUR OFFICE IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS IN
THE AREA THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX. AND IN PARTICULAR- HOW WE
ESTIMATE THE TRENDS
ENCOMPASSING COMPENSATION FOR
THE HIGH. A HIGH INCOME EARNERS
PARTICULAR. OUR FORECAST
ASSUMES THAT HIGH INCOME
EARNERS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE RELATIVELY STRONG WAGE
AND SALARY GROWTH WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THAT YOU KNOW
RECENT HISTORY. AND YOU KNOW IF
WE WERE TO COMPARE IT TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S. IT IT TEARS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S OUR
FORECAST. IS EXPECTING MORE A
GROWING SHARE OF WAGES AND
SALARIES WILL BE GOING TO THE
LOWER AND MIDDLE INCOME WAGE
EARNERS SO THAT'S PROBABLY. THE
KEY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN OUR TWO-
WE'LL TAKE YOUR OUTLOOKS. SO
THEN MOVING ON TO PROP IS TO
AND RESERVES- AS THE CHAIR SAID
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
PROVIDES FOR TWENTY FIVE POINT
TWO BILLION IN TOTAL RESERVES.
THIS INCLUDES FIFTEEN POINT
NINE BILLION IN THE PROPOSITION
TO BUDGET STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
A TWO POINT NINE BILLION IN THE
SPECIAL FUND FOR ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES. THOUGH I WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THIS AMOUNT
COULD CHANGE UPON SCORING BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THEN- AT THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE CLICKSO IT'S SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION BACK
INTO THE SAFETY NET RESERVE
BRINGING THE TOTAL TO ONE POINT
TWO BILLION- IN THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND THEN THE FIGURE CITED
HERE ALSO INCLUDES FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION IN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
RESEARCH. SO IN. WE SOME ALL
THESE UP. IT'S A LITTLE LESS
THAN A DAY MORE THAN WHAT IS IN
MAIL WITH THE- WHICH HAD TWENTY
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION IN
RESEARCH FROM THE SAME SOURCE-
THE LEGISLATIVE PLAN WOULD
MAINTAINS A THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION IN PROPOSITION TWO DEBT
PAYMENTS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THAT WERE IN THE MAY REVISION
BUT GIVEN THE USE OF OUR HIGHER
REVENUE ESTIMATES. IT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR MORE DEBT PAYMENTS
ACROSS THE MULTI YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY RELATIVE TO THE
MAY REVISION. THE LEGISLATIVE
PLAN WOULD PROVIDE FOR AN
ADDITIONAL TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
FOR CALPERS AND CAL STIRS.
THROUGH THE. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. THE HIGHER
REVENUES WOULD ALSO RESULT IN
HIGHER DEPOSITS INTO THE BUDGET
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT DURING
THESE YEARS BRINGING TOTAL
RESERVES TO ABOUT THIRTY SIX
BILLION BY THE END OF THIS
MULTI YEAR PERIOD. OKAY WITH SO
THAT KIND OF SPEAKS TO. THE
REVENUES AND THE PROPOSITION
TWO ASPECTS OF THE- THAT'S-
AHEAD IN THE FIRST ISSUE IN
YOUR AGENDA. SO I'LL JUST
BRIEFLY GO THROUGH THE SECOND
ISSUE NOW WHICH IS- PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT SO AS THE CHAIR
SAID. UNDER THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. WOULD TOTAL.
NINETY SIX POINT ONE BILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR. COMPARING THAT
TO THE MAY REVISION THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE PROVIDES
FOR TWO POINT SIX BILLION IN
ADDITIONAL PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. BOTH IN THE
CURRENT YEAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR
SO FOR THE CURRENT YEAR THAT'S
A THREE HUNDRED NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE AND
THEN IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE IT'S
A TWO POINT THREE BILLION- THE
DAILY INCREASE IN. IT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR- NOW IN ADDITION- I
SHOULD NOTE THAT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AMOUNT
WOULD PROVIDE FOR THE LARGER
THESE ADDITIONAL AMOUNTS FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WOULD
ALSO TRANSLATE TO AN INCREASE
DEPOSIT INTO THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT RESEARCH SO
PRACTICALLY A QUARTER OF THAT
ADDITIONAL PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING FOR SIX HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION WOULD GO
INTO THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
RESERVES. THE REST OF IT ABOUT
TWO BILLION WOULD BE SPENT ON
PROGRAMS. AND WHEN I COME TO
THE PRO- WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT.
HOW THE RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED
BETWEEN ONE TIME AND ONGOING-
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE SIMILAR
TO THE MAY REVISION- PROVIDES A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF. THE
RESOURCES TO ONE TIME PURPOSES
WHICH WE HAVE OVER TIME WE HAVE
SAID IS YOU KNOW ADVANTAGEOUS
BECAUSE IT CREATES A QUESTION
FOR- PROGRAMS IN THE EVENT OF
THE FUTURE PROP NINETY EIGHT
ARE GUARANTEED DROP. SO I CAN
JUST BRIEFLY TELL YOU THAT OF
THE ONE TIME SPENDING THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE DOES MAKE
SOME DIFFERENCES FROM THE MAY
REVISION. SPECIFICALLY IT
REJECTS IT REDUCES ABOUT FIVE
BILLION YEN MAY REVISION ONE
TIME PROPOSALS AND REPLACES
THEM NOTABLY WITH A TWO POINT
SIX BILLION TO PAY OFF ALL OF
THE REMAINING K. THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE- PAYMENT
DEFERRALS. AND THEN- IT ALSO
WOULD FUND SOME LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES THAT ARE ONE TIME
SUCH AS HIGH SCHOOL BLOCK
GRANTS INCLUSIVE EARLY
EDUCATION EXPANSION. AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. AND THEN LASTLY
WHEN IT COMES TO ONGOING
SPENDING. THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE INCLUDES AN ADDITIONAL
ONE POINT NINE BILLION YEAH
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SPENDING. IN K. TWELVE THE
LARGEST AUGMENTATIONS ARE FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION BASE FUNDING
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS IN RATE
INCREASES IN CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. AND THEN- THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE LARGEST
INCREASES ARE FOR FULL AND PART
TIME FACULTY CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS A HIGHER ON BASE THE
PORTION RENTS INCREASED AND-
STUDENT SUPPORT PROGRAMS. SO
THAT THAT. IT IS VICE OF THE
FIRST ISSUES AND HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS. I'M
GONNA SEE IF THE D. O. F. R.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE WANTS TO
MAKE ANYMORE ARE ANY COMMENTS-
BEFORE WE CHECK WITH FOLKS IF
THEY WOULD LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS TO EITHER YOU OR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS THAT YOU WANT
TO ADD. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ERICA LEAVE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND I
WILL BE BRIEF AND KEEP MY
COMMENTS TO A HIGH LEVEL- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY-
AS YOU NOTED THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF SHARED PRIORITIES IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND- SPECIFICALLY
THE SENATE PLAN- WHEN COMPARED
TO THE MAY REVISION. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS FORWARD TO
WORKING TOGETHER WITH BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY TO COME
TO A FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT A
THREE WAY AGREEMENT- THAT IS
STRUCTURALLY BALANCED THAT
MAINTAINS THE BUDGET RESILIENCE
AND OF COURSE IMPORTANTLY
INVESTS IN AND MEETS THE NEEDS
OF- ALL CALIFORNIANS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE MOST
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC- LIKE
THE MAYOR VISION THE SENATE
PLAN. PROJECTS REVENUE GROWTH-
AS MR PADDOCK JUST EXPLAINED-
ALBEIT A HIGHER LEVEL GOING TO
BE ABOUT TWENTY BILLION MORE
THAN THE MAY REVISION IN TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE- AND WE JUST
WANTED TO KNOW IN IN OUR
pREVENUE PROJECTIONS. DOES
INTRODUCE A GREATER DEGREE OF
FISCAL RISK THE BUDGET IN THE
OUT YEARS ESPECIALLY IF THOSE
PROJECTED REVENUES FOR THEIR
ONGOING EXPENDITURES RATHER
THAN ONE TIME SPENDING. AND
THIS IS REALLY DUE TO TWO
REASONS BUT- I'M SURE WILL BE
FAMILIAR TO THIS COMMITTEE THE
FIRST BEING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
REVENUE PROJECTIONS ARE SUBJECT
TO QUITE A BIT OF VOLATILITY-
AND THIS IS BECAUSE THE HIGHEST
INCOME EARNERS IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUE TO PAY- A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF THE STATE'S INCOME
TAX- FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE TOP 1% OF EARNERS
ACCOUNTED FOR. ABOUT. 46% OF
ALL- SO INCOME TAX. AND I WAS
JUST OVER A AND SOME THOUSAND.
TAX RETURNS SO CORRECT IN THE
STOCK MARKET NOT EVEN EVERY-
COULD RESULT IN SERIOUS
NEGATIVE IN. TO COME. REVENUES
AND SECOND I'M OF THE NATURAL.
SOMETHING WE BEEN LEARNING
QUITE A ABOUT THIS PAST YEAR
IS. THERE'S ALSO JUST A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AROUND BUILDING
THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET COMPARED
TO OTHER BUDGETS- AND THAT IS
BECAUSE OF THE INFLUX OF STUFF
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING-
THAT'S COMING INTO THE STATES-
AND THE INCOMING ASSOCIATED
ROLES IN REGARDS TO THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS- RECENTLY. WE'VE
BEEN WE'VE WE'VE WITNESSED AND
EXPERIENCED THIS IN THE PAST
WEEK OR SO- IN REGARDS TO
FEDERAL GUIDELINES BEING
RECENTLY RELEASED. FOR THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN AFTER OUR
PHONE- AND JUST AS AN EXAMPLE-
TO CHILD CARE PROPOSALS THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION THAT- USED OUR
FINDINGS- WE LEARNED WILL. WILL
NO LONGER BE ABLE TO USE OUR
FUNDS- AND REQUIRE A GENERAL
FUND BACK FILLED IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND BEYOND TO MAINTAIN
THESE PROPOSALS SHOULD BE
SHOULD BE MAINTAINED HIS
PROPOSALS. AND THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF- THE UNCERTAINTY
BEHIND THE PROPOSALS IN THIS
BUDGET- FOR WHICH GUIDELINES
WILL BE ISSUED OR HAVE AN ISSUE
THAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH THAT
RIGHT NOW- AND FUTURE YEAH. BY
LINES THEY COULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS EVEN AFTER
A FINAL BUDGET HAS BEEN PASSED
LATER THIS YEAR- SO THE MATE
MARRIAGES REVENUE FORECAST YES
IS MORE CAUTIOUS THAN THE ONLY
OTHERS TO COVER THESE RISKS.
AND THEN BUDGET REVISIONS
BUDGET STRUCTURE LIKEWISE AS
PROMISED- ON ONE TIME SPENDING
OVER I'M GOING SPENDING WE HAVE
A NINETY TEN SPLIT. 90% OF THE
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS ARE BEING
USED FOR ONE TIME BUT- ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES VERSUS TEN
PERCENT- I'M VERY TARGETED- I'M
GOING EXPENDITURES. AND THIS IS
REALLY BECAUSE IT IS MUCH
EASIER TO PULL BACK OR REDUCE
ONE TIME EXPENDITURES AND ON
THE FLIP SIDE IT IS- NOT TOO
EASY OR QUICK TO UNWIND OR CUT
ON GOING EITHER ENTITLEMENT
STATUTORY OR CONSTITUTIONAL.
OBLIGATIONS SHOULD THE STATE
NEED TO RESPOND IMMEDIATELY. TO
A NEGATIVE FISCAL SCENARIO. SO
THAT SAID AGAIN- THERE ARE MANY
SURE PARTIES IN BOTH THE
BUDGETS- AND AS THE GOVERNOR
STATED YESTERDAY- THE
ADMINISTRATION IS OPTIMISTIC.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THE
DETAILS OF THIS EXTRAORDINARY
ONCE IN A GENERATION- BUDGET
THAT WILL SUPPORT MILLIONS. OF
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU MISLI. I HAVE
COUPLE OF. FOR AND FOR. LA- SO
FIRST. I'M MISLEAD YOU X. THAT
THE- ADMINISTRATION- FIVE THIS
CONCERT ABOUT COST PRESSURE IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET- BUT MY
WHAT WILL YOU COULD TELL ME
WHAT IS THE GROWTH FACTOR WHICH
THE WEAPONS USING FOR YOUR OUT
YOUR REVENUE PROJECTIONS. I WAS
SURE I THINK WE ARE BETWEEN ONE
AND 2% COLBY WAIT ON THE LINE
WHO COULD CONFIRM THAT BUT I
BELIEVE IT IS ABOUT HALF OF
WHAT- THE LA O'S BIRTH ACTORS.
COME ON I THINK THAT'S WHAT I
HAD SEEN IN THE DOCUMENT TO SO
WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
HAVE KOBE- YEAH IF ONE IN TWO
PERCENT. 4% GROWTH AND- MR PECK
YOU WANT TO DESCRIBE WHAT THE
LA ROSE- WROTE THE ESTIMATE IS
AND WHETHER THAT WHETHER THAT
IS HIGHER THAN HISTORICAL
AVERAGE OR LOWER. WELL OURS IS-
MORE IN THE RANGE OF AROUND 4%
IN THE OUT YEARS. AND OUR
IMMEDIATE IF YOU LOOK AT IT
OVER A TWENTY YEAR TIME FRAME
OURS IS ACTUALLY STILL A BIT
LOWER THAN THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
GROWTH RATE ALTHOUGH- YOU KNOW
I WOULD SAY INHERENTLY I MEAN
THERE'S A RANGE THERE IS NO WAY
TO PREDICT FOR CERTAIN WHAT THE
REVENUES WILL BE- AND WE TRY TO
DO OUR BEST ESTIMATE THAT COMES
IN AT ABOUT US FIFTIETH
PERCENTILE SO REVENUES COULD
CERTAINLY BE HIGHER OR LOWER
THAN WHAT WE ESTIMATED. AND YOU
KNOW SO I DON'T I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH ANYTHING- REALLY
THAT MY- COLLEAGUES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SAID IT'S
JUST- YOU KNOW THIS BUT THE
FACTS ARE. OURS GROWS AT ABOUT
4% IN THE OUT YEARS WHICH IS A
LITTLE BIT SLOWER OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEAR PERIOD THAN WHAT.
WE ACTUALLY SAW. THIRTY YEAH I
MEAN DO. NOT TO PUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH BUT IT WHEN I.
WHETHER SOMEONE AND CLEARLY
THESE ARE FORECAST TO THEIR
PROJECTIONS BUT WHETHER WE
FULLY AGREE WITH THE 4%
PROJECTION. WOULDN'T YOU
DESCRIBE A ONE BETWEEN 122% SIR
NOT EVEN 2% GROWTH PROJECTION
IS BEING PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
CONSIDERING THE TWENTY YEAR
AVERAGE. YES AND AS I STATED IT
OUR OUR GROWTH RATE IS MORE
CAUTIOUS- AND I WANT TO JUST
KNOWING THAT I SAW THE GROWTH
RATE IN THE IN THE AGENDA AND
IT'S NOT BETWEEN ONE POINT SIX.
AND TWO POINT 7% TO BETWEEN ONE
AND A HALF 23% GROWTH RATE- AND
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S THAT
IMPORTANT. POINT I THINK I'D
LIKE TO MAKE IS NOT SO MUCH
WHO'S RIGHT IN REGARDS TO THE
REVENUE BUT JUST THE INCREASED
RISK- AND I'M BANKING ON HIGHER
REVENUE SHOULD NOT COME AND SO
I THINK THAT IS. PROBABLY THE
MOST IMPORTANT POINT THE
HIGHLIGHT HERE. AND YET WE KNOW
THAT. CERTAIN THINGS IF WE
DON'T BUY NOT FINDING THEM BY
ADOPTING A MORE. A MORE
CAUTIOUS AS THEY SAY THEN THERE
ARE. WELL LET'S PUT IT A
DIFFERENT WAY WE CAN ACTUALLY
IMPROVE LIVES NOW WHEREAS THE
CAUTIOUS APPROACH MIGHT NOT.
AND WHO'S TO SAY WHAT FURTHER
COSTS THAT MAY THEN CAUSE US.
IF BY NOT TAKING THE
INVESTMENTS NOW SO THAT'S MORE
MY COMMENTARY BUT LET ME ASK
YOU A DIFFERENT QUESTION MISLI-
I UNDERSTAND THAT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS SENT A LETTER TO
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
REQUESTING COST ESTIMATES FOR
THE STATEWIDE SPECIAL ELECTION
HAVE YOU ALREADY RECEIVED THE
RESPONSES FROM THE COUNTY'S.
YES I'M SURE WE DID ISSUE A
LETTER- LAST WEEK AND DID THE
DEADLINE FOR COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIALS TO RETURN INFORMATION
IN REGARDS TO- POTENTIAL COSTS
FOR THE RECALL ELECTION WAS DUE
YESTERDAY SO AT THIS POINT
WE'VE RECEIVED FIFTY ONE OUT OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT- STATES THAT
SORRY COUNTIES RESPONSES- SO.
THE VAST MAJORITY HAVE
RESPONDED AND LIKELY OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS WE'LL BE
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT ANALYZING
IT IN REGARDS TO- TOTAL
STATEWIDE COST OKAY. I'M IN A
PART OF MOTIVATION FOR MY- ASK
IS THAT OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE TO
APPROPRIATE THE FUNDING FOR
THAT STATEWIDE SPECIAL ELECTION
AND GIVEN THAT WE ARE SCHEDULED
TO ADOPT A BUDGET ON JUNE
FIFTEENTH IF WE HAD THOSE COST
ESTIMATES. WOULD IT MAKE SENSE
FOR US TO APPROPRIATE WHEN WE
TAKE OUR ACTION ON THE BUDGET-
I AGREE I THINK THAT DOES MAKE
SENSE AND WE SHOULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION- AGAIN IN A MATTER
OF- SEVERAL DAYS. OKAY GREAT
WELL I'M SURE WE WOULD
APPRECIATE RECEIVING IT AS SOON
AS IT'S- RECEIVED AND COMPILED.
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL ALL
RIGHT LET ME LOOK NOW THROUGH
MY- COLLEAGUES AND SEE IF THEY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS EITHER FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
THE OHIO. ALL RIGHT SEEING
NINE. THEN WE WILL NOW. MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS REGARDING THESE
TWO DISCUSSION ITEMS WHICH
WERE. THE FRAMEWORK. OF THE-
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET AND THE
PROP NINETY EIGHT AMOUNT. SO
I'M GONNA I'M LOOKING NOW IN
OUR GALLERY AND I SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. AND I
CAN GIVE THE PHONE NUMBER
BEFORE I LOOK AT OUR OTHER
ROOM. THE PARTICIPANT NUMBER
AGAIN IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO.
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT ONE
EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN. AND
GIVEN THE- LENGTH OF HEARINGS
ARE TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
ANOTHER PROTOCOLS. WE ARE
ALLOWED TO INSTITUTO I'M LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY AS I INDICATED
EARLIER WE ARE PROVIDING A
TOTAL OF FIFTEEN MINUTES. FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON HIS FIRST TWO
ITEMS AND THEN FIFTEEN MINUTES
EACH ON- THE SUB. ITEMS SO
PLEASE IF YOU CAN THOSE OF YOU
CALLING IN TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION AND IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT. AND AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE IF IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY TO GIVE US MORE
EXPLANATION KEEP THAT UNDER A
MINUTE SO THAT MORE PEOPLE CAN.
PARTICIPATE SO- LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE OUTFLOW
ROOMS- OVERFLOW. OF FLOW
OVERFLOW OVERFLOW ROOM THERE IS
NOT SO WE'RE GOING. TO GO TO
OUR I. T. FOLKS AND SEE WHO-
TELECONFERENCE THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE SERVICE SO
PLEASE PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
NOW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT. BUDGET FRAME.
AND PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS. AND
THEN COLLEAGUES- AS SOON AS
THEY BEGAN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
APPRECIATE IF WE COULD HAVE A
LITTLE QUIET IN THE- IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. ALL RIGHT
MODERATOR PLEASE BEGIN. NINE
EIGHTY NINE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHTY
NINE. MODERATOR MAYBE GO TO THE
NEXT AND WE CAN SEE IF THAT
PERSON KNOWS A- CAN CALL BACK
IN OR MAYBE THEY FIND NINETY TO
YOUR- PHONE. I'M SURE A NUMBER
OF PARTS FOR. THAT IS PRETTY
QUICKLY I'M GONNA HAPPEN BUT
NOT. JUST TRYING TO BE PLAYED A
THANK YOU FOR THE WEEKEND OF
THE VENUE. FIND OTHER BY. FOR
PEOPLE WITHOUT. AT WAS PUT OUT
IT- BULLDOZER- LET ME INTERRUPT
JUST FOR CIRCUIT OUR MODERATOR
IS THAT A PROBLEM WITH THE
SYSTEM WORTH THAT PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUALS PHONE LINE WE
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT. IT APPEARS THAT WE ARE
HAVING AN ECHO AGAIN. OKAY HOLD
ON. OKAY. YEAH YEAH. R. I. T.
STAFFORD JUST GONNA SEE IF THEY
CAN FIX THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HEAR THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT SO HOLD ON THOSE OF YOU
WHO'VE CALLED IN HOLD ON. AND-
NINE MEMBERS WHEN. THE PUBLIC
COMMENT STARTS I WOULD PREACH
IF YOU STOP.
FOR START. OKAY
YEAH ON. ALL RIGHT YEAH OKAY.
ALL RIGHT MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
TEST AND SEE IF THIS- A PROBLEM
IS BEEN FIXED O MODERATOR IF
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO ME
PLEASE. CANADA THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OKAY GO AHEAD JUST TO
ACCOUNT. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE. ALL RIGHT I THINK WE'RE
RESOLVED TO SUMMON A BANG THE
GAVEL. MEMBERS IF YOU COULD
START YOUR CONVERSATION. WILL
NOW GO TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT
MODERATOR GO AHEAD- LETTERS Q.
THOSE PEOPLE OUT. MODERATOR GO
AHEAD. MY NINETY TWO YEAR LINE
HAS BEEN REOPENED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MANCHURIANNUMBER
DOLLARS TOWARDS A STRATEGY
THROUGH SIX PM AFTER THE ACTUAL
INDEPENDENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COULD BE AN
ACKNOWLEDGED BIG. ARE GOING TO
FILE- BUT WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE HARD WORKING
COMMITTEE STAFF AND MEMBERS OF
ALL TIME- TO PROVIDE AID FOR
SHUTTERED INDEPENDENT VENUES
AND PROMOTERS ALSO HERE TO
REGISTER. SUPPORT ORDERED
SOMEONE LIKE GROUND FLOORS
BELOW THEMSELVES ALL LA AREA
VENUES- THAT WANTED TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE BOTTLE ON
WORKING GET YOU ALL FURTHER ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
MAX MODERATOR MY- MY. NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS DALTON OFTEN
LARGER THAN AND- AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY YOU FOR SUPPORT OF
AND IT THEN YOU. FOR A ONE OFF
THEN YOU LA AND ITS SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITY OF MUSICIANS AND
EMPLOYEES AND CREATE YOUR
ARTWORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE ONE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BEN REBEL IRAN GRAND
OLE ECHO NEW JERSEY MUSIC
PROMOTION- HELD AT THE EKO AND-
JUST WANTED BASICALLY SAY THE
SAME THING THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR HARD WORKING IN THIS
BEHALF. AND HOPEFULLY WILL BE-
PLAYING MUSIC FOR THE- THE
AUDIENCE DIDN'T CATCH. THANK
YOU. NINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MARK TAYLOR WITH
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M A
LIFE COACH WITH THE HOPE OF
REDEMPTION TEAM AND ARE GOING
TO PROPERLY CONVEY STATE PRISON
I SUPPORT SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
REHABILITATION REDEMPTION
REENTRY. AND UNIPER
REUNIFICATION PACKAGE
SPECIFICALLY HI GIRL
CONSERVATION CAMP RESOURCES
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE EVERY ABILITY
TO PROGRAM IN PART BECAUSE MANY
PEOPLE BOUGHT. TWO TWO FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE ONE
ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS BELIEVED TO BE A
PRESIDENT ABOUT VOICE WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED EDUCATION
ACTION DEMOCRATIC BUDGET TO BUY
DOWN ALL OF THE K. TWELVE FOR
ALL. YOU TOO QUICKLY CREATE
CONCUR TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
WE BELIEVE DAILY- REVENUE
ESTIMATES AND REPEATABLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FIND ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NOT INSURING
MEMBERS SO HE HAD TO LEAVE THE
SHOP ONLY HALF OF THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE UNIVERSAL
WORLD RENOWNED. COMPOSE ALL
THANK YOU TO SENATOR SKINNER
HER HER WORK ON THIS ISSUE. THE
MEDICALLY TAILORED MEALS
FINDING AND THEN THAT'S THE
THING ABOUT OUR PACKAGE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S OPEN FOR
FUNDING IN THE CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION INCENTIVE PROGRAM ON
THE HEALTHY STORES
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. IT IS VERY MUCH ON
IT WITHIN THE ARC JEWISH ACTION
I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE PRE TRIAL
PILOT ENDED IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO. WITH WHAT WE VOTED FOR SB
TEN WAS WITHDRAWN AND I'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS NEED TO PUT
INTO COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
AND ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION. THANK YOU. NINE
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DOWN
ATTENTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONGREGATION AT. RESEARCH
CENTERS AND I WANTED TO SAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT- LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
OR THE CHICKEN RESOURCE CENTERS
FUNDING TO STABILIZE THEIR
FUNDING AND- TO HELP. FORTY
THREE MILLION CAREGIVERS WANT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI AARON APPY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE COMMENTING ON THE
PROPERTY EDUCATION BUDGET WE
URGE YOU TO MAINTAIN THE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOL AND THE TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SCHOOL CLIMATE
SURVEYS THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISE. EITHER
ESSENTIAL INVESTMENTS FOR
TRANSFORMING SCHOOL CULTURE AND
CREATING RELATIONSHIPS THAT
AREN'TCOOL WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
REVISED PROPOSALS AN EDUCATOR
TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AMBER OPPOSE THE
LEGISLATURE'S SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION OF THE U. TEACHER
QUALITY INVESTMENT. FURTHER WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR EXPANDED LEARNING AND
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE TO MIDDLE AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AS WELL AND
WITH THE PART THAT MAY REVISE
ITS INCREASE OF ONE POINT ONE
BILLION. YEAH CONCENTRATION
GRANT BY RAISING THE RATE OF
65% AND URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADOPT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RATHER THAN THE PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL GREAT INCREASE.
HIGH QUALITY ALTERNATIVE IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION AS NECESSARY
IN THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
SCHOOL YEAR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON A. PROJECT ARE
CONSIDERING A RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBERS CRITTERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION REPORT THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. BECAUSE THE
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCY SECONDLY CAL FOURTH
REQUESTED THE FINAL PACKAGE
COULD SEND IT TO BRING YOUR
TOTAL TO IN BACK TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH THE GRANT
PROGRAM FOR VERY MUCH NEEDED
AND- AND WOULD REMOVE ALL.
MANAGEMENT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR.
A CLIENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ALSO SORE WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M A LIFE%
COACH WITH THE WHOLE PRODUCTION
TEAM AND GOING TO COLLECTING
BASICALLY PRISON I STRONGLY
SUPPORT. SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN
REHABILITATION REDEMPTION
REENTRY AND REUNIFICATION
PACKAGE SPECIFICALLY PONGAL
CONSERVATION CAMP RESOURCES.
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE AND WE HAVE
BEEN A BETTER PROGRAM REPORT
CARDS FOR THE PEOPLE FIVE TWO
TWO FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. NINE
ONE OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EACH CHARACTER
AND MEMBERS SELECTED WILD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MUSEUM THANK YOU FOR POSTING
SUCH SIGNIFICANT NEW
INVESTMENTS IN ARTS AND CULTURE
ESPECIALLY THE PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE MUSEUM GRANT
PROGRAM. AS YOU KNOW A STRONG
COALITION WITH OVER FIVE
HUNDRED LEADING ORGANISATIONS
MAYORS AND BUSINESSES AND
SEEKING A ONE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT THE LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL WHILE PREGNANT THEY
CAN'T AND GREATLY APPRECIATED
TOTALS LESS THAN 40% OF THAT
EVEN INCLUDING EARLIER RELEASE
FOR HOW. WE CONTINUE TO URGE
YOU TO PUT THEM CLOSER TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THE
FINAL BUDGET FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL HISTORICALLY DOWN
MEANT TO LIFT UP UNDER
REPRESENTED STORY FROM
CALIFORNIA HALF. FULL CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS RECOVER FROM THE
PANDEMIC AND JUMPSTART TOURISM
AND OTHER ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR FIND OUT ABOUT ON.
TOP OF THE LEADERSHIP FORUM THE
BOTTOM LINE TWENTY TWO THANKS
ON THE NEEDY FOR IT COULD BE A
BRIDGE LOAN PROGRAM. IN.
BEIJING EXACTLY AFTER HE- WE
CAME IN BY THE FIND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI HILLARY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT ACCORDING ITEM
NOT YET INCLUDED IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PLAN REGARDING
FUNDING FOR STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT PHYSICIANS WHO COMMIT
SERVING MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
UNDERSERVED AREA. DIDN'T WANNA
WORK PAYMENT PROGRAM INCREASED
ACCESS TO CARE FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS. INVESTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING INTO STUDENT LOAN
REPAYMENT IN FACT INCENTIVES
FOR NEW POSITION WITH INCREASED
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS TO TAKE
ON A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES HE
SHOULD NOT. START PRACTICES IN
UNDERSERVED AREAS OR CHOOSE TO
PURSUE YOUR SPECIALTIES THAT
ARE IN ALL OF WHICH WOULD HELP
TO DECREASE THE HEALTH CARE
INEQUITIES HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
COPA NINETY CAN THEM. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. THE NINE
SEVENTY YOUR LINE OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU THE
LADY PANTHERS ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEDICATION AND YOUR COLD AND
HISTORIC INVOLVEMENT AND
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THE
PUBLIC SOCIAL SAFETY NET AND-
THE SUN ARE ADEQUATELY FUNDED
TO ENSURE THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG NOT. THEY'LL FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU TO
ENSURE THAT OUR ROIC WORKERS TO
CARRY THEM THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
GET HERE OKAY BUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS TO BUILDING PUBLIC SECTOR
WORKFORCE IS STRENGTHENED AND
THAT WITH CONSTABLE CONTRACTING
BACK TO PRACTICES. ARE
IMPLEMENTED IN THE FINAL.
PROJECT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR. MEMBERS I WOULD GET ON
THE WHITTLING HANSON JIRO
QEDANI REPRESENTING THE AMITY
FOUNDATION I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF. THAT WORK ON THE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SPECIFICALLY THE
REENTRY- SERVICES GRANT OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS- WE
STAND READY TO WORK WITH THIS
BODY AND THE ASSEMBLY ON FOR
THE WORK SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND- REPORTER WORKING
WITH YOU BYE BYE. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWELVE YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI IT'S A
MAILING YES YOU'RE OKAY. HELLO
MY NAME THE TWO IRAQI I'M A
POLICY ASSOCIATE AT AND HE JUST
A LOVING AND POWERFUL COMMUNITY
OF FAMILY INCARCERATED WOMEN
AND GENDER NONCONFORMING FOLK
NO PUEDEN INCARCERATED. AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY DID NOT ON
BEHALF OF OUR ENTIRE STATEWIDE
MEMBERSHIP I THANK YOU TO BE
EXACT THE GOVERNOR IS ONE FORTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROBATION MY-
CHILD PILOT. BUT THE ISSUE ONE
ITEM. YOU FIND YOUR OWN TRIAL
pMEMBERSHIP PAID OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO BAIL OUT
THE PEOPLE ACROSS THE STREET
FROM OTHER THINGS. OUR MEMBERS
ARE NOT ONLY THE KIND OF
COMMUNITY LET YOUR CHILD
SUPPORT WE ARE DEMANDING THAT
YOU COULD PUT THAT. UP WITHOUT
A PILOT. I DON'T LET MY
PROBATION. WHAT NEED ART ARE.
HAVING GATORS. TRANSPORTATION
SERVICES HI TANYA COURT WITH
MINORS. HOW CAN OTHERS
SUPPORTED SERVICES TO HELP.
OKAY I HAVE HOW CAN BELIEVE
THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS NEED TO BE AT THE
HOME OF THE WORKING PEOPLE
THROUGH THAT PICKUP INTO THE
KITCHEN NOT ONLY DID NOT
MENTION OFFICERS WHO ARE
ACTIVELY FIND OTHER NAMES BUT
THEY ARE RENDERED IS THAT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR S ASKING WILL
EXPAND THE REACH OF THE
PROBATION PILOT. OF THE
PROBATION DEPARTMENT THAT'S
THEIR PART RIGHT AFTER YOU HIRE
ONE FORTY MILLION DOLLAR.
PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEP GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU SHARE OF MEMBERS THAT THE
THING A LOT OF CAR WELL WHAT
THEY ARE CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE PACKAGE OF
THE BUDGET PACKAGE I BELIEVE
YESTERDAY THERE IS MUCH TO
CELEBRATE IN THE PACKAGE. I HAD
SOME OF THE HIGHLIGHTS. THAT WE
SEE ARE AMONG THEM INVESTORS IN
PROGRAMS SERVING OLDER
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING NUTRITION
PROGRAM. TERMINATION OF THE I.
INSURANCE ON OCTOBER TENTH OUR
CURRENT AND THE MANY HOUSING
PROPOSAL. WE DO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT A. R. P.
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL
TO FUNDERS ON THE CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS FOR TEN
MILLION I'M GOING. WE WERE
DELIGHTED TO SEE THAT IT NOW.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE BUDGET
FRAMEWORK CALL TO CREATE A
SIMPLER SHORTER APPLICATION
FOR.JUNIORS ANDPERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES UNDER CALFRESH.
AND ENSURE THAT REQUIRED PHONED
HIM UP ONE CAN BE COMPLETED
OVER THE PHONE. LAST BUT NOT
LEAST OUR RESTORATIVE FUNDING
FOR THE MULTIPURPOSE SENIOR
SERVICES PROGRAM WHICH WAS
ALMOST ELIMINATED LAST YEAR. I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
BUDGET FRAMEWORK AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
MY FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MIGUEL GARCIA WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND A
FORMER YOUTH WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDATION
TO PROVIDE THIRTY MILLION OF
ONGOING GENERAL FUND FOR THE
NEW OFFER COULD MEET AND
COMMUNITY RESTORATION UNDER THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY.
CRITICAL IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS THE SUPPORT OF
CONTINUAL ARE YOU TESTING IN
THE STATE. OF UTAH
CONSERVATIVES AND ELIMINATE
RACIAL ETHNIC DISPARITIES. AND
ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JUST VERY
SENIOR POLICY COUNSEL AT ACLU
SOCAL AND REPRESENTING A SO YOU
CAN ACTION TODAY- WE APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S URGENCY TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S
UNCONSCIONABLE PRE TRIAL WITH
THEM BUT THE PRE TRIAL BECAUSE
ON DIRECTING FUNDS INTO
PROBATION IF MISGUIDED. MODEL
PRE TRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEM MUST
INCLUDE INDEPENDENT COMMUNITY
BASED. SERVICES AGENCIES
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED AS A BEST
PRACTICE THAT FOCUS ON MEETING
THURSDAY CREATING RELATIONSHIPS
AND TRACKED AND HELPING PEOPLE
RETURN TO COURT. NOT THE LAN
ORDER MINDSET AND CULTURE OF
MISTRUST AND FEAR THAT
PROBATION BRINGS. NO WAY FOR
EXAMPLE MULTIPLE COUNTY
COMMISSION REPORT SURE
PROBATION HAD NEGATIVE
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE CULTURE
AND THAT'S FOR THE MENTALITY
THANK YOU THE CARD. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. AND
MODERATOR WE HAVE TWO MINUTES
LEFT NOW. TO OUR FIFTEEN MINUTE
PUBLIC COMMENT TIME. THANK YOU
BUT WE DO HAVE TWENTY THREE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME. ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS SHERIN
REPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND A CLEAN CALIFORNIA
HOME COALITION COALITION WE ARE
TRYING TO PORT OF- FUNDING TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS AND ITEM
FIFTY ONE WE ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE THE
PROVISIONS OF BRING CALIFORNIA
HOME PROPOSAL TO STRENGTHEN THE
HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE AND
PREVENTION ARE HAPPY GRAHAM THE
FUND ALLOCATIONS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY'S PROPOSAL
TO REQUIRE THE STATE TO DO
CAPTAIN NEEDS AN HOUR. AND FOR
LOCAL FUNDING RECIPIENTS TO
CONTRACT CAPS NEEDS ANALYSIS
AND DIRECT SPENDING IN A DATA
DRIVEN WAY. DEFINITELY NOT THE
BUDGET WE SUPPORT FUNDING FOR
HOMELESS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
RECEIVE GRANT BECOME MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS WHICH WILL HELP THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS. IN OUR TEAM. THAT
YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU HI N.
OF MINE ONE THIRTIES NO I JUST
WANTED TO STAY FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WHEN WE CUT THIS WHEN WE
CLOSE THIS PART OF THE PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU ARE WELCOME TO CALL
IN AFTER THE SUB ITEM AT EACH
SUB ITEM THAT WE'RE GOING TO
DEAL WITH WITH WILL BE FIVE WE
WILL ALLOW FOR SOME PUBLIC
COMMENT SO WE WOULD TAKE TWO
MORE NOW IN THE NORTH FIFTEEN
MINUTES WILL BE UP. GO AHEAD
MODERATOR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. NINE ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TOM LAWRENCE MATEJ
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION- ONLY ONE I THINK
SOUTH WIND AND P. COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK
ON IT- E. EDUCATION BUDGET
DEFICIT PER COLON- FIVE POINT
007% AWESOME BUT- WE DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION IT'S NOT
RECEIVING A CALL LEFT. AND HAD
NOT RECEIVED A CALL THAT SINCE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE SO WE ASK
THAT YOU ALSO PROVIDE A FIVE
POINT 007% COLAS FOR.
TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THIS IS OUR LAST POINT.
THIRTY SIX OR SECTION GO AHEAD.
MY THIRD SIX REMINDERS OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI NEWMAN
ABOUT THE LEGAL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. ALCORN ACCESS TO
JUSTICE COMMISSION COMMENTING
IN SUPPORT OF TWO ITEMS FIRST
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ISSUE FIVE.
OR THE FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANNING OR
HUNTING THREE YEARS- ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL PER LEGALLY AND FOR
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS. SECOND
ISSUE SIR CREEK COURT AFTER
JUSTICE PACKAGES. FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE CLOCK ON ALONG WITH
FUNDING FOR A COURT REPORTERS
AND THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT ON AND GOT THE
MESSAGE. MORE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR WE WILL NOW
RETURN BACK TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SEE IF ANYONE HAS
ANY QUESTIONS BEFORE WE TAKE A
MOTION ON OUR FIRST ITEM IN THE
BUDGET FRAMEWORK ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS. SORRY SEEING NONE
THEN- I SEE MISTER ROGERS MADE
A MOTION SHE'S MOVED THE BUDGET
FRAMEWORK- MR STOP AND SHOW YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. IF YOU
WANT A BUDGET FRAMEWORK
SENATORS SKINNER HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. ZERO HI CAREER HI
CORTESE HI CORTESE I. DALI.
TORONTO RUSSELL HI AIKMAN HI
CAITLYN HI BRO. SOME WATER ACT
CALM WATER I LAYERED HI THERE
HI THERE HI CHOIR HI MELINDA.
MELINDA'S NO MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
HI THE MAN I FEEL TERRIBLE NO
THE TROUBLE NO PAN. PNI STERN
STERN HI WHAT COUNTS HI THE
KOSPI HI. GROWTH NOW- MR
CERTAIN TRY BELIEVE WE DIDN'T
CAPTURE MS GROUPS- VOTE NO
GROGAN GROVE NOW AND THEN
MISTER DALI. DOLLY NO. OKAY IS
THAT IS THAT THE FULL COMMITTEE.
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF VOTING
MISTER STEP YES OKAY SO CAN YOU
PLEASE TELL ME HIGHS THIRTEEN
KNOWS FOR. ALL RIGHT THAT BILL
IS ABOUT FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS
FOR. AND NOW. WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE SECOND ITEM WHICH IS THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE. RIGHT THE SENATOR
LAYERED MOVES PROP NINETY EIGHT
PACKAGE MR STOP AND SHOP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ISSUE TWO
PROPOSITION NINETY PACKAGE
SENATORS OKAY- HI SKINNER HI NO
SIN COPYRIGHT HI. HI CORTESE
ALL RIGHT WITH THE HIGH DOLLY.
ALI NOT LOADING THE RUSSELL.
I'D RATHER HI OKAY MAN HI HEY
MAN HI BRO. HI HI FROM AUGUST
SECOND COMMA- HI LEHRER HI
THERE HI. THE WIRE HI BUYER HI
MELINDA. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE HI
DURABLE HI PM HI. AND HI STERN
STERN HI MY CASKEY HI MY CASKEY
HI. THE NET VOTE. FIFTEEN HIGHS
FIFTEEN NICE. RIGHT THAT BILL
IS OUTWITH FIFTEEN ICE. AND NOW.
WE'LL MOVE TO OUR VOTE ONLY
ISSUES WE'RE GONNA START WITH
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE. AND ONE
MOMENT. THE AGENDA THAT'S
BEFORE US AND ALSO AVAILABLE TO
THE PUBLIC PROVIDES THE DETAILS
ON EACH OF THESE VOTE ONLY
ITEMS. AND SO WE'D LIKE TO TAKE
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. SOLELY
AND ONLY ON THE ITEMS RELATED
TO SUBCOMMITTEE ONE. SHIPLEY'S
RESTRICTED COMMENTS TO THOSE
ONLY AND BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT THE TIME BUT YOU CAN BE
BRIEF THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
BECAUSE THEN IF OTHERS WANT TO
SPEAK THEY WILL HAVE THE CHANCE
TO OUR PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 ACCESS CODE. EIGHT
ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN
ALL RIGHT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
GALLERY FOR COMMENT ON SEPT
ONE. SEEING NINE LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN OUR- OVERFLOW
ROOM AND I DON'T SEE ANY SO
MODERATOR GO AHEAD AND QUEUE UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EXCUSE ME-
MANY STEPHEN MYERS I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF- THE CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION PLANNING
COALITION- WE APPLAUDED THE
MANY INVESTMENTS IN THE IN THE
BUDGET. FOR NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS. I PARTICULARLY THE
SENATE'S PROPOSAL FOR- FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD. I'M GOING
TO CUT YOU OFF BECAUSE THAT'S
UP TO WE ARE TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT RIGHT NOW ON SUB ONE
ONLY. AND FOR ANY OF YOU
CALLERS YOU CAN RIP RIGHT ON
THE WEBSITE AND YOU SEE THE
AGENDA. AND THE ITEM THAT THE
GENTLEMAN WAS JUST SPEAKING
ABOUT IS UP TO. SO LET US
CONTINUE OUR SUB ONE. AND-
MODERATOR GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
NINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BETWEEN ELEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY TO DIG ON
BUDGET INVESTMENT THAT WILL
SUPPORT. US IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE SHOULD THE LEGISLATURE OF
INVESTMENT IN V. P. N. YES YOU
PAY FUNDING AND ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AND EXECUTION FAILED TO
NOMINATE SHOOK THEM. I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO BEST BE TIED
TO CLOSING RACIAL. GAPS WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL RELIGIOUS
SPEECHES FOCUS ON MOVING
BARRIERS TO CAL GRANTED
TENEMENT ACT. ACTUALLY HONORED
ME COLLEGE. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
TECHNICIAN THAT AND IT JUST
MADE. BY HOW CONCERNED ABOUT
INEQUITIES THAT WOULD REMAIN IF
WE DO MATCH YOU MIGHT HOW GRANT
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
WORKING WITH MOSTLY NATURALLY.
WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARD A REQUIREMENT BY
CALIFORNIA FULLY MODERNIZED THE
FINANCIAL AID. TO ENSURE
IMPORTANT ARE TARGETED TO MORE
CONVENTIONALLY GLOBAL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN TIME
TODAY THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LAURA
BARBECUE THAT BUT THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN
REMOVING AGE AND TIME OUT OF
HIS VEHICLE BARRIERS TO
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT.
INCREASING FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR NON TUITION COSTS COMPRISE
THE MAJORITY OF MOST CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE COSTS. WHICH ARE
CRITICAL IN SUPPORTING LOW
INCOME STUDENTS TODAY WE ALSO
URGE YOU TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
STEPS TO ACHIEVE A STATE WIDE
PORTABILITY GUARANTEE THAT
PRIORITIZES THE MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS AND FULLY REFORM CAL
GRANTS. INCLUDING SIMPLIFYING
PROGRAM THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. AND YOUR INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE FIFTY SIX YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUILDING
ON PLANET EARTH. AN APPLICATION
ON BEHALF OF MOSQUITO AND
VECTOR CONTROL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON PAGE TWENTY
THREE YOU COULD EITHER GET A
REPLACEMENT BUT THE MILLION
DOLLARS TRYING TO CALCULATE
GATEWAY INCLUDING PUBLIC
HEALTH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS JUST IN
ROWS ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA AND THE STATEWIDE
COLLEGE FOR ALL COALITION. WE
APPRECIATE THE VEGETARIAN AND
THE SENATE SUPPORT FOR THAT
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT EIGHT TWO G.
COMPLETION AND COLLEGE ACT THAT
SUPPORTS STUDENTS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARKET THERE A GIRL'S
DANCE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION IN
CALIFORNIA TOGETHER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED COMMITMENT
TO PROVIDING ALL STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME BILINGUAL
OR MULTI LINGUAL BY PROVIDING
THE INVESTMENT TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. INVESTING IN THE DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION GRANT GLOBAL
MARKETS ARE BECOMING MORE
INTEGRATED WHICH INCREASES THE
NEED FOR OUR STUDENTS TO
POSSESS THE SKILLS NECESSARY TO
CONDUCT BUSINESS AND TO WORK IN
GLOBAL MARKETS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THERE NANCY
AGAIN A PUBLIC ADVOCATE
COMMENTING ON ISSUE NUMBER SIX
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE THE PROPOSED
EXPANSION OF THE REQUIREMENT
THAT 25% OF WILLIAM SETTLEMENTS
THEY INSPECTION BY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT BE ON ACCOUNT.
GIVEN THAT SCHOOL WILL BE
REOPENED AGAIN THIS YEAR AND
INSIGHT AS IT CAN BE SAFELY
CONNECTED IN PERSON IT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO WAIVE THIS
REQUIREMENT. IN FACT EVEN
ANNOUNCES IT WILL BE MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER TO ENSURE
THAT ALL THE PROVIDING ALL
STUDENTS WITH INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS. FACILITIES IN GOOD
REPAIR- AND AS SUCH WE ASK YOU
NOT TO WRITE THE REQUIREMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND ONE
MOMENT FOR LESS COMMON. NINE
ONE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
SIXTY NINE ONE SIXTY NINE IT'S
NO LONGER IN THE QUEUE. OF MINE.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE OKAY IF YOU
PEOPLE THAT HAVE- POPPED IN AND
REMOVE THEMSELVES FROM THE
QUESTION QUEUE OKAY. E HAVE NO
COMMENTS LEFT AT THIS TIME.
GREAT. ALL RIGHT SO THAT WAS
OUR- COMMENTARY OR RATHER OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON SEPT ONE LET
ME SEE IF THERE'S ANY- FLOOR-
SKEWS ME ANY MEMBERS WHO WOULD
LIKE TO- ASK ANY QUESTIONS OR
MAKE ANY COMMENTS. RIGHT- FIVE
S. SENATOR LARRY GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WAS.
GOING TO MAKE SUMMARY COMMENTS
BUT SHE DID A GREAT JOB AND I
THINK WHAT THIS BUDGET DOES IS
PEOPLE SEE THE MONEY THAT'S
AVAILABLE BUT THEY DON'T
UNDERSTAND- CLEARLY THAT THERE
WAS MONEY THAT WENT INTO THE
EDUCATION RAINY DAY FUND TO
MAKE IT OVER FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT THERE'S A PAY DOWN
OF OVER THREE BILLION. ON ON
THE OUR PENSION OBLIGATIONS
THAT THERE IS PAY OFF OF THE
DEFERRALS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AT BOTH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THE R. K. THROUGH
TWELVE LEVEL THAT WE RESTORED
FUNDING AT EVERY BRANCH LEVEL
AND THEN HAVE A COST OF LIVING
INCREASE ABOVE IT THAT'S IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF FIVE PERCENT.
AND SO THIS IS REALLY IN
ADDITION TO REFORMING STUDENT
AID AND DOING THE FAMILY
OPTIONS IN PRE K. THIS IS
REALLY A BUDGET THAT MOVES AWAY
AHEAD OF ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN
DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL IN
EDUCATION FOR KIDS OR FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION IN A
GENERATION AND SO. I THINK WE
SHOULD BE PROUD OF THIS BUDGET
IT SAVES MONEY FOR THE FUTURE
IT DOES SOME OF THE BEST
IMPROVEMENTS IT MOVES TO ADAPT
THREE COLLEGE IT HELPS KIDS
BEFORE THEY GET TO
KINDERGARTEN. THIS IS A GOOD
PROJECT AND I WILL BE PLEASED
TO VOTE FOR IT AND I'LL BE
READY TO MOVE IT WHENEVER WE
ARE COMPLETE- QUESTIONS IN THE
COMMONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND HAVE LEARNED I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR CARING THAT
SUBCOMMITTEE IN OVERSEEING IT
ALL AND I. YOU KNOW WE HAD I
ASKED SOME QUESTIONS TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA-
ABOUT THESE GROWTH PROJECTIONS
BECAUSE WE HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOME
CONCERN. THAT PERHAPS OURS
MIGHT BE TOO AMBITIOUS BUT I
THINK THE EXACT THING THAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED THE FACT THAT IN
OUR BUDGET STRUCTURE WE ARE
PAYING DOWN ALL OF THE
DEFERRALS. AS WELL AS SOME OF
THE PENSION DEBT IN FACT OR
INVESTMENTS IN THE FUTURE SO
THAT IN IN THE CASE WHICH ONE
COULD HAPPEN. THAT THE GROWTH
IS NOT WHAT WE EXPECT WE'VE AT
LEAST CREATED CUSHION. AND LESS
DEBT FOR OUR SCHOOLS AND WE
KNOW THAT DEBT OBVIOUSLY
INCREASES OUR COSTS OVER TIME
SO. I REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
WORK AND I THINK IT'S VERY
PRUDENT- THE ACTIONS THAT ARE
BEING RECOMMENDED BY YOURSELF.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO JUST HOLD
OFF ONE MINUTE BEFORE I TAKE
EMOTION BECAUSE WE MAY NEED TO
SPLIT THE MOTIONS A COUPLE OF
TIMES SO JUST HOLD ON. GOOD ALL
RIGHT SO WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
OFF TAKING A VOTE ON SOMEONE
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD OFF ON THE
ROADS. BECAUSE WE ARE STILL
WORKING OUT WHETHER WE'RE GOING
TO BE. BREAKING THE PACKAGE UP
AND TAKING MULTIPLE VOTES WERE
SINGLE BOATS SO WHILE THAT'S
BEING WORKED OUT. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE- PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON SEPT TWO. AND I NOTE THAT
THERE WAS A CALLER WHO HAD
CALLED IN FOR SUB TWO AND THIS
IS THE TIME WHERE THAT CALLER
COULD NOW AND AGAIN I WILL
ALERT THE PUBLIC TO THE FACT
THAT YOU CAN SEE THE AGENDA. ON
OUR SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WEBSITES THAT YOU CAN SEE THE
DETAILS. SO WHEN I SAY THE SUB
THAT IS YOUR- HAS THE ITEM THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
YOU CAN CALL IN AT THE RIGHT
TIME. BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE A PERSON A PUBLIC MEMBER
IN THE GALLERY. WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK TO SEP TWO SO I'M GOING
TO RECOGNIZE THEM NOW. GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF
HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO REDWOOD
COMPANIES. AND WE WANTED TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE WORK OF
SUBCOMMITTEE TO. END THE SENATE
WORKGROUP ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO COMBAT
WILDFIRES. AND DEAL WITH
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU NOW LET
ME SEE IN THE OTHER WHO WILL
OVERFLOW ROOM IF THERE'S ANYONE
ANY PUBLIC THERE WERE NIGHTS
MAKE COMMENT THERE'S NOT SO
MODERATOR WE CAN QUEUE UP NOW
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
OR MAKE A COMMENT ON THE ITEMS
IN THE SUB TO PACKAGE. GO AHEAD
MOTOR THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT AND SUB TO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOHN CLAY
CALLING IN TO SUPPORT ISSUE
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
REPORTS ON BEHALF OF THE PORT
OF SAN DIEGO AND THEN ALSO-
SUPPORT ISSUE THIRTEEN AND THE
PRESERVATION OF THE BEACH SAND
REPLENISHMENT PROGRAM ON BEHALF.
OF THE CITY THAT THEY NEED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BRING INTO A GUN BATTLE
THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
WE'RE DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ACTION TO REJECT
THE EPA CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS
FUNDING TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
WHICH INCLUDES THE CARL MOYER
AND LOCALLY B. NINE TWENTY
THREE INCENTIVE PROGRAMS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
RECONSIDER UPS THAT YOU THINK
THAT SHE SHOULD CONTINUE
APPROVING EXPANSION THIS YEAR
WILL ALLOW FOR PROGRAMS
CONTINUE SEAMLESSLY HELP INFORM
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN
DEVELOPMENT AND PROVIDE
BUSINESS AND MARKET CERTAINTY.
ALSO IN LIGHT OF THE BUDGET
SURPLUS WE ASKED YOU TO FURTHER
PRIORITIZE INCENTIVE FUNDING
FOR THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
AND FARMER PROGRAMS AND LAST
BUT WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR AIR DISTRICT EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION.
IT DOES NOT COVER CURRENT COSTS
ARE ACCOUNTS FOR NEW
COMMUNITIES ADDED TO THIS
IMPORTANT STATE. MANDATED
PROGRAMS THANK YOU. THANK. NINE
ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHECHNYA
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BROADBAND PROPOSAL
WHICH IS A FULLY FLESHED OUT
PROPOSAL THAT IT EVERY.
NECESSARY PIECE OF THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE AT THE CALIFORNIA HAS. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S PLAN- BUT I'M
WORRIED THAT IF WE WAIT FOR
MONTHS. TO EVEN PASS QUICKLY
PASSED THE BUDGET DEADLINE TO
PASS SOME OF THESE CHANGES
THAT'LL BE FOUR MONTHS WE WON'T
HAVE TO DO THE PLANNING THE
STAFF IN THE DRAFTING OF
GUIDELINES AND EVERYTHING THEY
COULD ACTUALLY BE DONE BY
SEPTEMBER IF WE PASSED IT-
EARLY- BIRD RATE SUBSIDIES ARE
GREAT PART OF THE PLAN THEY
PROVIDE SHORT TERM BENEFITS
DON'T LASTING IMPACT- AND THAT
THE STATE WIDE OPEN ACCESS
MIDDLE MILE NETWORK IS THE ONLY
LONG TERM SOLUTION. TO
AFFORDABILITY AND JUST A QUICK
REMINDER LAST THING EACH PIECE
OF IT IS ACTIVATED AS SOON AS
THE TENT SO IT STARTS PROVIDING
BENEFITS AS SOON AS.
CONSTRUCTION BEGINS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
NINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXACTLY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION ABOUT HALF OR MORE
THAN EIGHTY FIVE TRENDS RELATED
TO MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO APPLAUD
THE LEGISLATION THE
ADMINISTRATION PORTER STRONG
SUPPORT PUBLIC TRANSIT AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITY. YOUR MISSION BOXING
REELED APPOINTMENT TODAY
INVOICING OUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE CAP AND TRADE EXPANSION
PLAN AND THAT PACKAGE INCLUDED
IN ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN. THE
BUDGET DISCUSSION CONTINUE WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE CLEAN
TRUCK. AND BUS PROGRAM AT
LEVELS PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND TO MAINTAIN
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION OCTOBER
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
TRANSPORT TO THE NAVISTAR-
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
AND FINALLY ON BEHALF OF B.
CALIFORNIA GREEN BUSINESS
NETWORK I LIKE TO THINK THE
LEGISLATURE COURTS CONTINUED
INVESTMENT. A. N. D. CALIFORNIA
GREEN BUSINESS PROGRAM IS
PRESENTED. IN ISSUE THREE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. NINE SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DO AND MILLER WITH
UCLA. SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CLIMATE SCIENTISTS FROM THE
STATE AT THE NINE KE. CONCERN
ISSUE TO SEVEN THE WILD HARBOR
AND PROPOSAL AS YOU WORK
THROUGH THE DETAIL OF THE WHILE
PACKAGE WITH THE MINISTRY. WE
RESPECTFULLY CAN MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING HELP THE
CLIMATE AND WILDFIRE INSTITUTE
A BOLD NEW AND INNOVATIVE
COLLABORATION THAT WILL PROVIDE
LONG TERM SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT. INTERDISCIPLINARY
ENGAGEMENT SYSTEMATICALLY
ADDRESSING BOTH RESEARCH AS
WELL AS POLICY GAPS WITH REGARD
TO CLIMATE IN WILDFIRE THIS
INSTITUTE WILL HELP THE STATE
ENGAGE AND COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THE LATEST
SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY DATA AND TOOLS ARE
UNDERSTOOD IN THE BILL POLICY
MAKERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE ONE SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CURRENT MEMBERS JERRY DOES MEN
ON BEHALF OF RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA ON ISSUE
THIRTEEN IN STATE PARKS WITH
FISCAL STABILITY PROMOTING
PROGRAMS. WE SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION NOT TO INCREASE
THE BOAT REGISTRATION FEES NOW
UNTIL THE TAKEOVER PROCESS
DEVELOPED THE PLAN FOR ONGOING
STABILITY OF OUR PERSONAL
WATERCRAFT OF ALL THE FUN. AND
WE URGE THAT THE TRAILER
BILLING WHICH SETS FORTH A
TRANSPARENT INCLUSIVE AND
MEANINGFUL. STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON- WILL BEAR IT
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION I WANT TO THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ALL ITS WORK-
TO GET US TO THIS POINT AND FOR
THE FULL COMMITTEE FOR DURING
MY COMMENTS TODAY. BUT WE
DEFINITELY PREFER TO FOCUS ON
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCES WE VIEW THE
INVESTMENT- PUT FORWARD IS
CRITICAL TO PROTECTING AND
IMPROVING LUNG HEALTH FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. FOR ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN GIVEN THAT THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR LEADING
SOURCE OF OUR AIR AND CLIMATE
BURDENS WE SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE THREE POINT
NINE BILLION INVESTMENTS
TARGETED TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE. WE
CURRENTLY DISTRICT WHAT IS
LATER ON THE GOVERNOR TO MAKE
RAPID DISTRIBUTION OF THESE
FUNDS FOR LIGHT MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES REALLY A
HIGH PRIORITY TO REDUCE HARMFUL
POLLUTION ACROSS THE BOARD WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EQUITABLE
DEPLOYMENT ON THE BENEFITS OF
THEIR EMISSION VEHICLES MUST
ALSO BE A HIGH PRIORITY. AND
ALL ECHO THE CAPCO COMMENTS-
ARE DISAPPOINTED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DECLINED TO RE
AUTHORIZE OR INCLUDE THE RE
AUTHORIZATION OF NDA KARL MOORE
ANOTHER CRITICAL CLEANER
PROGRAM THIS YEAR WE BELIEVE
THAT SHOULD BE REVISITED AND
BELIEVE THAT RE AUTHORIZATION
SHOULD HAPPEN. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NINE ONE NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS FULL OF CRAP WITH THE SOUTH
COAST AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT THE FALCONS BECAUSE OF
NORMA'S CHALLENGES AND REDUCING
AIR POLLUTION TOXICS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH SPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
NOTHING INTERESTING ABOUT
INCENTIVE FUNDING IS CRITICAL
FOR MANY HEALTH BASED AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS TO CELEBRATE
CRITICAL. NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. WHAT FUNDING TO
REPLACE DEALS WILL BE ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS BETTER LOWER
COST AND PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. THIS WORKS
IN TANDEM WITH YOUR MISSION
OPTIONS BEING DEVELOPED FOR
MASTER PLAN IN THE FUTURE. WE
ASK THAT YOU RECONSIDER
REJECTED IMMEDIATELY
AUTHORIZATION AND INSTEAD
SUPPORT THIS YEAR ESPECIALLY AS
IT RELATES TO THE CAR WHERE
PROGRAM. NEXT ACTION NOW
PROVIDES PROGRAM STABILITY
HELPS INFORM STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN DEVELOPMENT
ENSURES PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN TECHNOLOGY. THE FUNDING
FOR AIR JUST FOR EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVES HOWEVER
ASKED YOU INCREASES FUNDING TO
PRIORITIZE NEAR TERM EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. AND APPRECIATING
THE SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR AIR
DISTRICTS BUT AFTER YOU
INCREASE THE FUNDING TO COVER
ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MANAGER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JUST IN ROWS ON BEHALF
OF- TO CHANGE A PROGRAM OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE WERE IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
SPECIFICALLY THE AGRICULTURE
BUDGET PLAN ESPECIALLY FUNDING
FOR SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE AND
THE HELP THE STORE FOR TUITION
GRANT PROGRAM AND CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION CENTER PROGRAM. THE
LATTER TWO OF WHICH HELP
SUPPORT- INCREASING HEALTHY
FOOD ACCESS FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS STATEWIDE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE ONE SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BARRINGER NUMBERS
FIFTEEN BLOCK ON THE HALF OF
THE CENTER FOR FOOD SAFETY I
WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE FOR
SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF FUNDING FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
UNDERSERVED FARMERS FARM TO
SCHOOL HEALTHY SOILS STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION. AND
INVESTMENTS AND POLLINATOR
HABITAT. IN THE BUDGET LANGUAGE
TO ENSURE ENHANCED PRESENT SIDE
AIR MONITORING WILL BE GOING TO
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. C. S. CONTINUED TO
POSE ANY UNDING TO TERRY DIED
OF THIRST THAT POLLUTE ALL
DOING NOTHING TO REDUCE AIR AND
WATER POLLUTION AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHILE
THEY ARE WHERE THEY ARE OFTEN
LOCATED FINALLY. WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT A TIERED PEASANT SIGN
MILTIE TO FIND FOR INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT RESOURCES I'M
ALSO CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS. CAPPING THE
LEGISLATURE FOR SUPPORTING
TRANSITION TO SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE AS WELL INCLUDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FARM TO
SCHOOL. CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE PROGRAMS URBAN
AGRICULTURE BEGINNING FARMERS
TRAINING AND A STATEWIDE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION. THANK
YOU URGES. THE FINAL. THANK YOU.
MY ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR IS UP
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLE RICE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLE COALITION
FIRST I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND
STAFF FOR THEIR EXCEPTIONAL
WORK AS USUAL DURING YET
ANOTHER UNPRECEDENTED BUDGET
HERE. AT THE DISCUSSIONS
CONTINUE WE URGE THE SENATE TO
INCLUDE IN THE FINAL PACKAGE
AND YOU'RE TURNING MISSION
REDUCTION STRATEGY AS LAID OUT
BY FAMILY MEMBERS FREEDMAN
INTERCOOLED TRIED SUCH A
REQUEST. THIS WOULD INVEST
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO REMOVE DIRTY HEAVY
DUTY DIESEL TRUCK OFF OF
CALIFORNIA ROAD AND REPLACE
THEM WITH LOW KNOCKS TRACK. AND
COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE TODAY
THIS STRATEGY COMPLEMENTS THE
STATE'S LONGER TERM GOAL TO
ACHIEVE ZERO EMISSION BY MAKING
GOOD ON THE POLICY PROMISE TO
PROVIDE DISADVANTAGED AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BUT THEY'RE
BETTER AIR QUALITY. INSTEAD OF
MAKING THEM WAIT ANOTHER FIVE
TO TEN YEARS WHEN HEAVY DUTY
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY IS
WIDELY AVAILABLE IN THIS
VEHICLE CLASS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE NUMBERS
MENTIONED WHAT MODULE WILL
DECLINE CENTER. WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER ADDRESSING A WIDE RANGE
OF ISSUES BUT ONCE YOU PLUG ONE
ITEM IN PARTICULAR THAT HAS NOT
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL RELEASED HUNDREDS OF
PACKAGE GIVEN THE NUMEROUS
CLIMATE DRIVEN GREAT I'LL USE
THAT WE- HAVE HERE WHICH WILL
CONTINUE OUR STUDENT REC NOT.
PUTTING COURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT WE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF THE-
PACKAGE GO TOWARD COMMUNITY
ENERGY RESILIENCE I THANK THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE FLASH
FOCUS ON USING CLEAN
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
HELP COMMUNITIES WEATHER
CLIMATE DISASTERS AS WELL AS
OTHERS WE GOT. REVENGE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. ONE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MY NAME IS THAT OF THE S.
WITH CHARGEPOINT CURSED POINT
SUPPORTS THE SENATE'S LEAD
PACKAGE PROVIDING THREE POINT
EIGHT BILLION OVER THREE YEARS
INCLUDING TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR TO MAKE SURE THE
PROGRAM MAKE APPLICATION THESE
FUNDS SO AGAIN WE APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS AND SUPPORT THIS BUDGET
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AVAILABLE ENERGY I'M CALLING
ABOUT THE PACKAGE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR SONNY PROPOSAL FOR
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EATING AT THE STRUCTURE.
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE MULTI
YEAR FUNDING PROPOSALS FOR THE
CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE PROJECT-
SPEEDIER P. HOWEVER WE BELIEVE
THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE PROPOSAL TO MAKE
CD R. T. LOW INCOME ONLY MAKE
IT INTO QUESTION TO ENSURE THAT
THEY TRULY TRANSFORM QUICKLY
TRANSPORTATION MARKET.
ADDITIONALLY DECISIONS AND BOTH
OF THESE ITEMS. SHOULD NOT BE
DEFERRED THANK YOU. THE WHICH
CURRENTLY THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE. LET'S THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHILE
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED
TELL TWENTY AFTER HE TO THE
COMMITTEE AND- FOR ALL OTHER
INCREDIBLE WORK- MY COMMENTS
ARE RELATED TO THE DROUGHT
PACKAGE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THE FINAL PACKAGE OF DOCUMENTS.
IN THE AMOUNT OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS CONSUMMATION MATCHING
TICKETS AND ALSO FUNDING FOR
THE CALL BACK FEATURE BETWEEN A
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ALL THESE ARE- CREDIBLE
UNICORN BLACK AREAS THAT NEED
TO BE. INVESTED IN IT AND WE
WOULD. LIKE TO SEE THOSE.
FACTORS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MA'AM SURE MEMBERS THIS
IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SPECTRUM MERIT DALE STAMBERG IN
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE SENATE FOR
PROVING MONEY SUSPECT MARLBORO
ERIC'S LAST WEEK DIDN'T ****
PROPER- AND WE BEGIN TO EARN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE NINETY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR- MRS
CHAIR MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
RECALL MASTRODONATO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION CLIMATE PACKAGE
WHICH INCLUDES. THREE HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE MILLION FOR URBAN
CLIMATE RESILIENCE WE HOPE THAT
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE TWO
HUNDRED AND MILLION FOR THE
URBAN GREENING PROGRAM.
SCIENCES WARNING US OF THE
IMMEDIATE DANGER OF EXTREME
HEAT WE APPRECIATE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE INCLUDE THAT IN
THE JUNE FIFTEENTH- FINAL
BUDGET NOT DELAY THAT LATER IN
THE SUMMER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND MODERATOR WE HAVE TWO
MINUTES REMAINING FOR THE
COMMENT PERIOD ON SEPT TWO SO
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
CALLING IN OU CAN. TRY TO BE
BRIEF SO WE CAN FIT WHOEVER'S
REMAINING IN GO AHEAD MOTOR.
NINE ONE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE NINETY NINETY MAYBE ON MUTE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS APOLOGIES FOR SPEAKING
OUT OF ORDER EARLIER TRYING TO
TAKE MYSELF OUT OF THE WRONG
QUEUE STEPHEN MYERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN COALITION ON
A TWO TWENTY SEVEN. WE
APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS ARE NOT FULLY INTO
THE BUDGETPARTICULARLY THE
SENATE CLIMATE PACKAGE THAT
CORRECT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD FOR
PROTECTING FISH AND WILDLIFE IN
RESPONSE TO DROUGHT WILDFIRE
AND CHANGING CLIMATE
CONDITIONS. WE URGE THE
ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT THAT AMOUNT
IN THE FINAL AGREEMENT AND IN
ADDITION WE URGE YOU TO RECEIVE
RESERVE A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF THOSE FUNDS FOR
NATURAL COMMUNITY CONSERVATION
PLANTS AND HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANS WHICH ARE ATTEMPTING TO
IMPLEMENT SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT PRINCIPLES BY
PERMITTING A PERMITTING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AT THE
SAME TIME. THE PROTECT WILDLIFE
HABITAT AND BIODIVERSITY AS
WELL AS THE QUESTER CARBON.
LOCAL LANDSCAPE SCALE PLANS ARE
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S THIRTY
BY THIRTY PARTICLES AS WELL I
THE CARMICHAELS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. THE NOW
MODERATOR. WILL HAVE ONE
REMAINING OKAY. PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU NINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS JULIE JORDAN
WITHIN OUR CHICAGO FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES AND ASK FOR FUNDING
AT ONE FORTY A YEAR- WE'RE ALSO
ASKING FOR FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
FOR COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
INCLUDING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE CENTERS. TO
COMPLEMENT THE ALLOCATION FOR
CV AT THE FAIRGROUNDS- I ALSO
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR MULTI BENEFIT
PROJECTS. FOR COMMUNITIES NEAR
THE SALTON SEA- CLIENT
INVESTMENTS WE'RE- URGING YOU
TO INCORPORATE OUR THE LIVE
WITH PROGRAM- LOW INCOME
WEATHERIZATION AT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION A YEAR- AND WE ALSO
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO ELIMINATE
ALL FUNDING FOR GERRY THAT
GESTURES WHICH EXACERBATE.
POLLUTION IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES- IN. ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND WASTEWATER
WE URGE YOU TO INCLUDE THE TWO
BILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAMS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. IN ADDITION TO
CONTINUE FULLY FUNDING TAKEN
APART OF A DRINKING WATER AT A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION- WE
ALSO SUPPORT- SIGMA AND
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
ANNOUNCED THAT 30% OF THE
OPENING DIRECTLY BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
30% TOWARDS PROJECTS THAT
PROTECTING CLEAN WATER. ON THE
PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION OR
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
NOTIFICATION SYSTEM AND THE
FUNDING TO TRANSITION TO
SUSTAINABLE PEST MANAGEMENT IN
ADDITION TO A MILKY- BUT WE
URGE YOU TO ALSO INCLUDE A
COMMUNITY SUPPORT PROTECTION
FUND TO PROVIDE DIRECT
PROTECTIONS FOR THE- COMMUNITY
THAT WORKERS MOST EXPOSED TO
CHEMICAL PESTICIDES. THANK YOU
WE ALSO HAVE. YOUR WE DON'T
LIMIT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- ALL
RIGHT NOW MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO SUB. THREE THEN AGAIN
FOR THE PUBLIC YOU QUEUE UP NOW
IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
ITEMS UNDER STEP THREE AND YOU
CAN LOOK AT THE AGENDA THAT IS
ON THE BUDGET COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY MEMBER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE SUB
THREE PACKAGE YES SENATOR
CAREER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
HAVE A COUPLE OF- NOTATIONS-
YEP I II SUPPORT BOTH OF THE-
THE ITEMS I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE I JUST WANNA MAKE A
STATEMENT ON ONE AND THEN ASKS
FOR SOME. LANGUAGE IN THE
OTHER- ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY
FIVE THE ONE CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE IMMIGRATION
SERVICES- ALL OVER THE STATE
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT THE
PROGRAM AND I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS FOR THE PAST COUPLE
OF YEARS- PAST FOUR YEARS TO BE
EXACT. IS THAT THE ONE
CALIFORNIA WAS SET UP. TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
GRANT. TWO COMMUNITIES ARE TWO
AGENCIES THAT HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR A PERIOD OF TIME WHICH
IS GREAT BECAUSE I HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE THE PROBLEM IS IT
BETWEEN VENTURA. AND SAN JOSE
THERE ARE NO SERVICES AT ALL
AND WHEN YOU GO INTO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OTHER THAN
FRESNO THE NEXT SERVICE I
BELIEVE IS IN STOCKTON SO DO WE
HAVE HUGE PARTS OF THE STATE.
MOSTLY IN RURAL RURAL
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAD NO
IMMIGRATE WE HAVE NO
IMMIGRATION SERVICES. OTHER
THAN- ORGANIZATIONS COMING IN
AND DOING WORKSHOPS AND THE
CHALLENGE IS THAT THESE ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE LEGAL SERVICES
THAT PROVIDE REAL- LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. ON CASES AND WE
JUST DON'T HAVE A NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIA SO I MEAN I SUPPORT
IT I THINK IT'S A GREAT THING
THE TWEETS GOT SOME SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS WITH WITH THE PROGRAM-
AND SO. THAT'S THAT'S MY KEPT
MY IN MY DISTRICT THERE ARE
ALMOST NO SERVICES AT ALL OTHER
THAN. THAN PERIODICALLY COMING
IN AND DOING AT A WORKSHOP- THE
NEXT ONE IS ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY ONE WHICH IS THE
ENHANCED SERVICES PROGRAM FOR
THE ASYLUM HE'S- THERE'S EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS IN. CASE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH A MAYOR. THE
MAYOR OF MENDOTA THEY- TEND TO
GET A NUMBER OF ASSIGNED THE
SIXTH OF FAMILIES THAT ARE-
THAT ARE. RELOCATED TO THEIR
COMMUNITY AND HE ASKED THAT WE
CONSIDER SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
SO THAT THEY CAN INTEGRATE. THE
ASYLUM SEEKERS INTO THE
COMMUNITY INTO THE FABRIC OF
THE COMMUNITY AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE CHILDREN THAT
ARE PART OF THE FAMILY AND SO
BOTH OF THOSE WERE REQUESTED.
THAT I HAVE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MANAGER. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR RECOMMEND YOU WANTED
TO- CENTERING MENU OUT A
QUESTION OR COMMENT. GO AHEAD.
YOU'RE WELCOME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WOULD JUST TO ADD JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT I AM VERY
PLEASED WITH THIS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE IT WHEN THE TIME
COMES I JUST I JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A NOTE THAT WE HAVE JUST
MADE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
THINGS LIKE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH-
CALLIE M. EVERY YEAR RE DOING
OUR PART MEDI CAL SYSTEM-
EXPANDING BENEFITS TO THOSE
FIFTY AND OLDER- REALLY
INVESTING IN R. I. D. D. D. D.
COMMUNITIES- AS WELL AS LOOKING
AT THE CHILDCARE AND RATES FOR
THAT. MAKING SURE WE HAVE
ENOUGH SOCIAL WORKERS AND THEY
REIMBURSED AT THE RIGHT LEVELS
BY MAKING SURE OUR FOOD BANKS
ARE FUNDED SO THERE IS JUST-
THERE IS SO MUCH IN HERE THAT
IS GOOD I JUST. WE'RE GOING TO
GO THROUGH THIS BUT I JUST WANT
TO REALLY HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING PUBLIC
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THE POOREST OF OUR
POOR THOSE ON SSI S. S. P. DOES
THAT- THIS BILL BACK PROBABLY I
THINK REALLY GOES A LONG WAY TO
TAKE CARE SO THE BASIC NEEDS.
OF CALIFORNIANS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THIS ITEM WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ECKMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR CHEERING AD DOING THAT
EXCELLENT WORK IN YOUR WITH
YOUR- COLLEAGUES ON HE
COMMITTEE. AND I THINK WE'VE
ALL. BEEN ACUTELY AWARE OF WE-
DEAR WE HAVE NEVER HAD ADEQUATE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES BUT WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES
THAT SO MANY CALIFORNIANS FACED
AS A RESULT OF THIS PANDEMIC.
THE WORK BOTH THE GOVERNORS-
MAY REVISE WORK ON BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND THEN THE
AUGMENTATIONS AND MODIFICATIONS
THAT YOU'RE SUBCOMMITTEE MADE.
AN ADDITIONALLY THE- WHAT HOW
WHAT UNFORTUNATELY WE SAW AS
THE- UNDER RESOURCE ASPECT OF
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
OR IF NOT JUST UNDER RESOURCE
PERHAPS ON UNDER PREPARED. FOR
THIS PANDEMIC THAT OUR
INVESTMENTS. IN REALLY
STRENGTHENING THOSE LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IS-
GOING TO BE I THINK REALLY
VALUABLE AND I'M REALLY GLAD
THE BELTS AND SUSPENDERS ARE ON
IT SO THAT WE ALSO CAN ENSURE
THAT IT'S- THAT THE INVESTMENT
USE WIDELY WISELY WISELY-
CENTER PAN DID YOU EVER COME IN
YOU WANT TO MAKE. IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
APPRECIATE INTELLIGENCE FIRST
OF ALL I- I JUST ALSO WANT A
SECOND- THE REMARKS OF
SETTINGS- SIR EDMUND HAS SAID
THAT THE POSITION IN THE PAST
CHAIR OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE I
REALLY WANNA THANK CENTER ADMIN
FOR HER LEADERSHIP- AND HELPING
CRAFT- THE SUB THREE- BUDGET-
BUT ALSO I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT- I KNOW MADAM CHAIR YOU
AND I. CAME IN YOU YOU CAME IN
WITH A COUPLE YEARS EARLIER
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION AND
IN MANY WAYS- IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
UNTIL THIS PARTICULAR BUDGET TO
NOTHING WE TAKING CARE OF ALL
OF ITS WE'RE WE'RE WE ACTUALLY
ARE FINALLY UNWINDING THE
CUSTOMER MADE. ALMOST TEN YEARS
AGO. TO HEALTHY HUMANS. AND
EVEN THOSE WERE FACING YOU KNOW
EVEN AS WE'RE COMING. BACK OUT
OF TELEVISION. AND WE KNOW THE
NEEDS ARE SO GREAT- FROM- FOR
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. THAT
WE HAD THIS OPPORTUNITY TO STEP
UP AND ADDRESSES SO WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT EXPANDING
COVERAGE HEALTHCARE YES WE
STILL HAVEMORE PROGRESS TO BE
MADE BUT WE'RE MAKING A
SUBSTANTIAL. INCREASE IN THIS-
WE TALK ABOUT THE DD COMMUNITY
AND THE RATE STUDY THAT WAS
DONE AND WE'RE STARTING THAT
PROGRESSION ARE WE THERE YET NO
BUT WE'RE MAKING THOSE FIRST
STEPS RIGHT- THE OTHER CUTS
THAT WERE MADE. AND THEN OF
COURSE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
PACKAGE WITH THE REALLY A
STRONG FOCUS ON EQUITY. I THINK
THAT SAYS SOMETHING WE NEED TO
REINFORCE AS WELL SO THE
REBUILDING OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH WAS AGAIN
CUT BACK IN THE GREAT
RECESSION. AND REALLY NEVER
RESTORED NOW WE'RE SORRY MAKES
OF IT BUT ALSO WITH A STRONG
FOCUS ON EQUITY. STRONG FOCUS
ON TRYING TO BE SURE THAT- WE
ADDRESS- THIS THIS THIS
VERITIES THAT WE SEE AND A LOT
OF DIFFERENT AREAS SO I. FEEL
COMPELLED TO HAVE TO RECOGNIZE
THIS- THAT- AFTER A DECADE OF
BEING A LEGISLATURE I ACTUALLY
FEEL LIKE WE'VE NOW STRAIN TO
MAKE SOME REAL PROGRESS ON
WINDING THE CUTS THAT WE STILL
PAINFULLY MADE. OVER A DECADE
AGO AND YET EVEN IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS DID NOT
ACTUALLY SEE THEM. TRULY GETS
FULLY GET ROLLED BACK TO HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES. AND AGAIN I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND ALSO-
CENTER ADMIN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN IT HI I THINK IT
DOES ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE OF US
WHO HAD TO MAKE THIS CATCH IT
DOES FEEL VERY GOOD AND WE KNOW
HOW VULNERABLE. OR HOW OUR
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. REALLY
SUFFERED FROM IT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NOW LET US DO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. ON SEPT THREE I
WILL LOOK FIRST TO OUR- PUBLIC
IN THE GALLERY TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY COMMENTS SINCE SEPT
THREE NO. AND I WILL LOOK IN
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM WHICH I
BELIEVE IS STILL EMPTY IT IS.
AND SO MODERATOR. YOU NOW CAN
QUEUE UP. THOSE FOLKS WHO WANT
TO MAKE A COMMENT TO US ABOUT
SEPT THREE. AND REMEMBER WILL
ONLY WILL LIMIT THAT TO FIFTEEN
MINUTES TOTAL. SO THOSE OF YOU
WHO MAKE A COMMENT I WILL CUT
FIVE ASKED TO STATE UNDER A
MINUTE SO I WILL CUT YOU OFF IF
YOU START GOING OVER THAT. AND
YOU COULD ALSO JUST SAY HEY YOU
SUPPORT. THE ACTIONS THAT WE'RE
TAKING. SO GO AHEAD MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT. ON
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE TWO HUNDRED TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT SHARED CALL WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND EXPRESS
OUR STRONG CORPORATE ISSUE ONE
SIXTY UNDER FOOD BANK. ISSUE
ONE SEVENTEEN THAT THE BOOK BY
CALFRESH APPLICATION PROCESS
FOR SENIORS ISSUE ONE TWENTY
FOR ALL TO EXPAND ACCESS TO THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM PROGRAM ISSUE
ONE TWENTY TWO ONE TIME AND
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE CHILD.
CARE FOOD PROGRAM THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE HISTORIC AND
EQUITY FOCUSED INVESTMENTS IN
THE FACE. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU FOR
TAKING ON BEHALF OF THE NURSE
FAMILY PARTNERSHIP AND DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE
AUGMENTATION OF THE CALIBER
COME VISITING BUDGET AND IF YOU
ALTER EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE
LEGISLATORS PLAN TO PROVIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING FOR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. AND THEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION PAID
TO THE OXFORD RECAP AND HOPE
THAT OUR POINTS REGARDING THE
PRIORITIZATION OF PRIMARY CARE
IS REFLECTED IN PLAIN LANGUAGE
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO STACEY ARMATO
DIRECTOR OF RAM COAL OTHER
RACIAL AND ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION UNDER
ISSUE THIRTY THREE WE SUPPORT
THE SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT. UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS WELL AS THE
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MILLION
FOR HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE INTERVENTIONS WE WOULD
LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PARTICULARLY YOU AND SENATOR
ECKMAN AND SENATOR PANTS. FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO ALL THESE
MATTERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CRAIG CROMBIE HALFWAY KELLY
HELP THANK AND THE EPIDEMIC. A
STATEWIDE COALITION OF OVER ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WEARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTMENT UNDER ISSUE THIRTY
THREE AND ESPECIALLY THE ANY OF
THE DEMOCRATS REQUEST TO
ADDRESS EACH I. B. S. T. I.
APPETITE IT'S AN OVERDOSE. ALSO
JUST WANT TO SEND OUR THANKS TO
THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS CAITLYN DEAN
WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION
CALLING IN REGARDS TO ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. SHE'S SUBBED
REACH RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVE
FUNDING AND ADOPT MODIFIED
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOCATE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION FOR MOBILE
CRISIS SUPPORT G. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
PRIORITIZE SUPPORT THE CRAZIEST
ACTS BY ALLOCATING. THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IS
STILL LOCKED AND SUPPORT
COMMUNITY BASED MOBILE CRISIS
SUPPORT TEAM RESPONSIBLE
CONVERGENCES LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
CRISES PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE
HOMELESSNESS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
NATURAL DISASTERS AS
ALTERNATIVES TO POLICE OR
SOMETHING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. PACKAGES OTHER
THING IS ONE ONE SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TIM LYNCH FROM PLATINUM
ADVISORS ON BEHALF OF LIBERTY
DENTAL CALLING ON ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ELIMINATE DENTAL
MANAGED CARE AND RECOGNIZING
THAT THE SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTION
THE PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE CAUSE.
TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN THANK YOU. NINE TWO OH
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION IN CALIFORNIA I
JUST WANT TO QUICKLY EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR ALL OF THESE
INCREASED INVESTMENT. IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR YOU- WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE CHEROKEE AQUIFERS
FOCUSED ON OR NOT HEALTHEQUITY
AND REDUCING RACIAL
DISPARITIES. IN PARTICULAR WE
WANT TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
FOR FULL. MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR
ADULTS FIFTY AND OVER
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. FIND TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS KELLY QU'IL
REPRESENTING THE COALITION FOR
COMPASSIONATE CARE CALIFORNIA
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ON THE
AGENDA. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR TWO BUDGET
ALLOCATION A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO ESTABLISH A
STATEWIDE ELECTRONIC REGISTRY
FOR POSITION ORDERS FOR LIFE
SUSTAINING TREATMENT ALSO KNOWN
AS POST. AN ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION OF SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
SUPPORT PAPERBACKS POSTING
GARMENT THE STATEWIDE POLLS
REGISTRY KEY TO ENSURING THAT
PATIENTS TREATMENT WHICH IS OUR
CREDIBILITY READILY AVAILABLE
TO MEDICAL PROVIDERS WHENEVER
AND WHEREVER THEY ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT. PATIENT CENTERED CARE
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERMARKET
URINE MEMBERS ANASTASIA CULTURE
COULD CALIFORNIAN FIGHTERS FROM
THE CAPITAL PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
MULTIPLE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS
INCLUDING TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TO SUPPORT ALL CHILDREN TRIED-
A STATEWIDE INITIATIVE THAT
SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO MITIGATE
THAT DISTRICT. AFFECTED ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES ON
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN TWO HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY IN PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION TO SUPPORT HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
YOU FOCUS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TEN MILLION
TO FIND THE OFFICE OF RACIAL
EQUITY IS COMPLETED AND BE
SEVENTEEN HE TAKES EXPRESSES
OUR DEEP GRATITUDE TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND RECOGNIZING.
THE IMPORTANCE IN FUNDING THESE
CRITICAL IMPORTANT. PUBLIC
HEALTH INITIATIVES THANK YOU SO
MUCH. NINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BRITISH
OTHER THAN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE THE DEPLETION
OF CALIFORNIA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE COMPANY CAN'T WE
COLLECTION. WE'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACT AND
COULDN'T FIND IT AND IN
PARTICULAR THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR A LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH REQUIRED BY AN ACTING IN
PUBLIC HOW THE LEGISLATURE IS
INVESTING IN PROTECTING THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS AND
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENGAGE WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON TRAILER BILLING WHICH-
INSURE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
AN EQUITY EFFORTS FUNDED
THROUGH THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
COORDINATED. LOCALLY AND I
MIGHT THINK YOU. NINE ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS DOUG
BIGGS I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
ALAMEDA POINT COLLABORATIVE AND
LIFELONG MEDICAL WE WANT TO
THANK SENATOR SKINNER THE
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
VOTE ON SOME THREE LINE TWENTY
EIGHT TO PROVIDE FUNDS FOR THE
ALAMEDA LONG. STANDING GET JUST
ONE STEP CLOSER TO MAKING OUR
VERSION OF THE STORE THAT
CAPTURES BOTH FORMERLY HOMELESS
JUNIORS OBTAIN PERMANENT
HOUSING AND ACCESS TO QUALITY
HEALTH SERVICES A MEDICAL GROUP
BUT. A REALITY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. FOUR NINE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS KAYLA ROBINSON ON
BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER BRENT
PREVENTION PARTNERS AND CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
THINKING THE LEGISLATURE AND
STRONGLY SUPPORTING ISSUE FORTY
ONE ON VACATION OF FUNDING FOR
THE FIRE MONITORING CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY ONE THE
W. CALIFORNIA I WANT TO BEGIN
BY THINKING THAT YOU'RE IN THE
COMMITTEE PROPOSED ACTIONS
RELATED TO THE AGENT THAT-
PROGRAM AND IT COMMUNITY MANY
OF THESE CHANGES ARE LONG
OVERDUE AND WE COMMEND BROKEN
AND YOU'RE PRETENDING UPDATE
MOBILE MEDICAL AND DOES NOT
CARE FOR THEM CRITICALLY
SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING ITEMS. A
NATION IS TWENTY FOUR I. I. T.
EXPEDIA THE NATION OF THE GREAT
THREE FIFTY THREE THE
PERFORMANCE INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FIFTY FOUR D. AT THE WORKFORCE
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT FIFTY NINE
ATTRACTING BUT EACH FOR MORE TO
THE COORDINATOR THE REGIONAL
DANNER CONTINUALLY THINKING
BACK ABOUT MY- NUMBER SIXTY TWO
THE PAGE NUMBER TO BE AT THREE
THIRTY. AND THAT WOULD BE TOO.
I. THINK YOU GOT MUCH. NINE
ONE. YOUR LINE IS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR
AND- I'M TAKING A BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE FOR
REJECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITALS PROPOSAL TO.
HOLD L. P. S. AT THE HOSPITAL
THIS ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE
AND THEN EXPRESS OUR- GRATITUDE
TO THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE FOR MAKING
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUE ON THE PRESCRIPTION.
IN PUBLIC HEALTH LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH ACTIVITIES AND PUBLIC
HOSPITAL ACTIVITY THANK YOU.
NINE TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS BARBARA GLASER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
I'M CALLING IN TODAY SUPPORTED
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE THE PROPOSAL
TO FUND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PILOT PROJECT I WANT TO THANK
THE SENATE PRECLUDING THIS
REQUEST IN THE LEGISLATURE'S
JOINT BUDGET AND CULPRITS
CONTINUED INCLUSION IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BUT REALLY YOU
WANT TO HAPPEN YOU W. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
TREMENDOUS ON THE BUDGET FOR
ITEM FIFTY ONE EIGHTY WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ADOPTION OF
THE FOLLOWING. PROPOSALS ISSUED
SEVENTY TO SEVENTY SIX BUT ALSO
HIGHLY ISSUE THIRTY FIVE MINS
AGO SHE SUPPORT FOR FRONTLINE
SPECIAL WORKERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE TWO THIRTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE NUMBERS
INTERCHANGEABLY CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS THANK
YOU YOUR SCANNER WELL AS A
JUROR I MEAN REALLY APPRECIATE
THOSE COMMENTS BUT HI THE
BANKS- JUST BRIEFLY SUPPORTING
THAT A PACKAGE OF INVESTMENTS
THERE WE HOPE THAT THE US IS
THAT CORRECT CAN BE FULLY
RESTORED THIS IS AN AMAZING
STAFF- AND DEEPLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK BEING DONE TO SUPPORT.
EMERGENCY FOOD HEALTH
QUESTIONS- FOR ALL MEDICAL CAL
WORKS I'M SORRY I MISSED-
SOMEONE EARLIER. WHAT'S GOING
ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE TO
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
ON A BUTCHER MY NAME IS ERIC
MORSE CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL
WEEK AND THE ONLINE SUPPORT
ABOUT COLOR REGARDING ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE. ALL GOING TO BE
A LINE BOOK THE BOOKING OF
COLOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED ALLOCATION OF FUNDING
FROM MOBILE CRISIS SUPPORT. WE
BELIEVETHAT THESE RESOURCES TO
SCORE AND REINFORCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CRISIS
ACT EIGHTY EIGHT ONE EIGHTY. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR PEOPLE DISABILITY
TRANSGENDER DONKOR PEOPLE AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER HOUSE OR
HOME WITH COMPLETELY ACTIVE
QUALITY EMERGENCY SERVICES THAT
ARE CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE AND
UNTRAINED PRACTITIONERS WITHIN
ESTABLISHED AND TRACK RECORDS
OF SERVICE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. RIGHT THANK YOU TO
BOTH OF THESE PRINCIPLES AND
PRACTICES AND IMPROVE PUBLIC.
SAFETY FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU. LINE ONE. YOUR LINE
IS A PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MANAGER REMEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
COALITION PERSISTED IN RECAP
TECHNOLOGY WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE- SENATE FOR ISSUE TWENTY
NINE RESTORING THE 10% CUT FOR
COMPLEX REHAB TECHNOLOGY WHICH
IS ONE OF THE- DEVASTATING CUTS
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION THAT
SENATOR PAN REFERENCE IN. IT-LONG OVERDUE AND WE APPRECIATE.
THE SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE TWO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JAMES BURKE- THE POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE ANTI POLICE
TERROR PROJECT REPRESENTING THE
LET US LIVE COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES THE BLACK BLACK LUG
NOT A LOS ANGELES COURAGE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA YOU W. POLICY
LINK BERKELEY FREE CLINIC. BBC
OCD OBSESSIVE COLLECTION INTO A
CONDO YOU DEDUCT- DISCUSSING
ITEM TWELVE WE APPRECIATE THAT
THREE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
PRIORITIZE MOBILE CRISIS THE
COURT WILL GRAB THE STATE IS
PRIORITIZING WITH MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR
EIGHTY ONE EIGHTEEN THE CRISIS
ACT THE CRISIS ACT. WHICH IS
SEEN OVERWHELMING SUPPORT BY
THE LEGISLATURE FOR TWO YEARS
NOW EXCELLENT VEHICLE FOR
MOBILE CRISIS BUDGET ALLOCATION
AND SO WE HOPE- AND PRAY THAT
WE CAN ALL WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT VEHICLE BUT
ALSO SUPPORTED- I FIND THAT
WAY- INTO. THE BUDGET PROCESS
THANK YOU. NINE TO NINETEEN
YOUR LINE OPEN TO GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOHN
PRATT I AM. GOING TO CALIFORNIA
I'M OPTIMISTIC I MEAN. COME
ATTACK APPEARED TO BE TALKING
TO ME. I'M GONNA DATE AS A
PERMANENT DISABILITY I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE LOCAL SUPPORT.
WE ARE CREATING ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WE ISSUED
ONE ISSUE SIXTY ONE SIXTY FOUR
THANK YOU FOR HEARING US.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME
MODERATOR WE NOW HAVE TWO
MINUTES REMAINING TO R. FIFTEEN
SO- SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES LEFT
GO AHEAD MOTOR. THANK YOU LINE
TWO OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIKE CARROLL WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WHICH YOU WANT I THANK
THE CHAIR NUMBER SUB SUB THREE
FOR ABOUT OUTSTANDING WORK
TODAY YOU GET THIS YEAR ON THIS
BUDGET WOULD PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THEIR LEADERSHIP AND
FUNDING A NUMBER OF HEALTH
EQUITY PROPOSALS INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICAL
ASSET LIMIT. AND EXPANDING MEDI
CAL ALL INCOME ADULTS AGE FIFTY
PLUS YEARS OLD. WE ALL DROPS
THE STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
BATHROOM SINK OUR SCRANTON
REMOVING BARRIERS TO ENROLLING-
FAMILY DENTAL CARE TO- WAITING
POSSIBLE CAL WORKS OVER
PAYMENTS DUE TO THE PANDEMIC
AND FULLY FUNDING CAL WORKS ON
THIS CITY. AND LASTLY WE
SUPPORT THE FOOD FOR ALL
PROPOSAL ENTER THANKFUL FOR THE
MID FIRST MAJOR RESTORATION
INVESTMENT BY GRANT AND LOOK
FOR THE FULL RESTORATION OF
TEACHER AND REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR ADMIN CALLING THAT OUT IN
BOTH THE COMMITTEE AND IN OUR
COMMON. TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ONE MIGHT. ONE
LAST. SIX POINT TWO- OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS REBECCA
GONZALES WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR ALL THE AMAZING ABOUT
INVESTMENTS I'LL JUST MENTION A
FEW. SIXTY THREE POINT ONE
MILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REFUSING TO FERRY PROJECT A
WONDERFUL PROJECT THAT MIGHT
CONTINUE- ALSO THAT HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE
INTERVENTION- THE ELIMINATION
THE MEDIC HOW ASSETS HAS.
INVESTMENTS FOR A FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCY SOCIAL WORKERS AND ALSO
THE INCREASE IN Q. EFFORT BY IT
THAT HE GRANT SO APPRECIATED I
HOPE WE CAN GET PEOPLE-
RESTORATION. AND THAT THIS IS A
GREAT START THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND- WE WILL
NOW. GO TO THE- SUBCOMMITTEE
FOR. AND AGAIN FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO CALL IN PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU CAN SEE THAT AGENDA ON THE
SENATE BUDGET WEBSITE SO YOU'LL
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT ITEMS ARE
THERE IF YOU WANT TO COMMENT TO
THOSE BUT LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY FLOOR QUESTIONS ABOUT- THE
ITEMS WE HAVE BEFORE US AND SUB
FOUR. OR ANY COMMENTS. MEMBERS.
I THINK GOES SENATOR NEWMAN GO
AHEAD. I THINK I THINK ABOUT
YOUR DAD MORE OF A COMMENT OR
ANYTHING SO IT'S SPECIFICALLY.
ABOUT THE DECISION IN THIS
BUDGET NOT TO RESTORE THE
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT TAX
CREDIT THE NET OPERATION
OPERATING LOSS PROVISIONS FOR
LIFE SCIENCES COMPANIES- IN THE
COMING TAX HERE. BUT THOSE
CREDITS WERE. DROPPED IN AUGUST
TWO BUDGET YEARS AGO IN THE
FACE WHAT WE EXPECT TO BE A
VERY LARGE RECESSION- AND SO- I
AM CONCERNED THAT THEY'RE NOT
BEING RESTORED MANY OF THE
DECISIONS BEING MADE. BY THESE
COMPANIES WERE BASED
SPECIFICALLY ON. ACCESS TO
THESE CREDITS AND SO IT IS
LITTLE BIT CONCERNING SEARCH
FOR. BUSINESSES IN NOW IN MY
DISTRICT IT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE- SO JUST WANT TO GET THAT
ON THE RECORD. AND I KNOW THAT
SENTIMENT PROBABLY HAS A
SIMILAR COMMENT THANK YOU.
CERTAINLY SENATOR MITCH. YES
SENATOR MEN GO AHEAD I JUST
WANTED TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
COMMENTS AND VOICE MY SUPPORT
FOR HIS- FOR HIS COMMENTS OKAY
OKAY GREAT- SEEING NO OTHER.
MARKS UP BY MEMBERS WILL DO OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE WILL SEE
FIRST IF THERE'S ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WHO WANTS TO MAKE A
COMMENT. ON ITEMS IN SUB FOR I
SEE SOMEONE GO AHEAD. YES MADAM
CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF THE- FILM AND TV
CREDIT AS WELL AS YOUR PROPOSAL
ON CREDITS DEALING WITH THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
AND- A MASSIVE A LIABILITY THAT
PARTICULARLY SMALL BUSINESSES
WILL HAVE TO ENTER OVER THE
NEXT DECADE OR MORE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- LET'S SEE WE WILL
NOW LOOK IN THE ROOM IS STILL
EMPTY THE OVERFLOW SO WE WILL
MODERATOR YOU CAN QUEUE PEOPLE
UP FOR THOSE COMMENTS ON SUB
FOR. AND WE CAN BEGIN AGAIN
WITH FIFTEEN MINUTES LEFT LIMIT
ALL RIGHT GO HEAD MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
JUSTIN ROWS- ON BEHALF OF PORK
ON RECOVERY CALIFORNIA
COALITION- WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND IT'S UP FOR HEARD OUR ISSUE
AND REQUEST THAT WAS SUBMITTED
BY SENATOR PACKARD AND NOTICED
THAT WOULD INCLUDED IN THE
VOTING CALENDAR HAVE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE TO. HOPEFULLY
REVISIT THIS REQUEST I WOULD
SUPPORT CAPITAL AND GRANTS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO CONVERT
SMALL BUSINESSES TO WORKER
OWNERSHIP WE THINK THIS WILL
ALIGN WITH THE LEGISLATURE'S
GOALS OF AN EQUITABLE AND
INCLUSIVE ECONOMIC RECOVERY FOR
EXAMPLE WORKER COOPERATIVES-
OVER 60% OWNED BY WOMEN AND
ALMOST 60% ARE OWNED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA GROUP POLICY CENTERS
WE WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE
THAT THE GOLDEN EGG THING YOU
KNOW IT'S TWO POINT NO WOULD
ALSO SUPPORT NON I. TEN HI
THERE- UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I WENT TO THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ANYONE WITH THAT YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA AND PUT IT INTO
A MEDICAL EXAMINATION OF THE
POTENTIAL EQUITY AS OUTLINED BY
DR. ONE ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE THIRTY NINE YOU MAY BE
ON MUTE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE TO TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING A SUB FOR MY MPC
COMISKEY REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL DISTRICTS
COALITION. AS AGENCIES WITH
UNPARALLELED SPEED AND
EXTENSIVE COLLABORATION IS THE
CORE TENET OF THEIR EXISTENCE
HE- CULTURAL DISTRICT STRIVE
NONPROFIT MUNICIPAL OFFICE AND
BUSINESS ENGAGEMENT. INVESTMENT
AND CULTURAL DISTRICTS IS
IMPERATIVE AND CAN BEST BE
ACHIEVED BY YOUR SUPPORT AND
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THE OPS BUDGET
PROPOSAL IS CHAMPIONED BY
SENATORS ALAN RUBIO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AS ARIANNA AND
COOK SO. THIS IS NOT CURRENTLY
REFLECTED IN THE BUDGET. IN
ADDITION TO A CAREFULLY
DEVELOPED PLANS TO INCREASE THE
RATE OF RECOVERY FOR THE CULT
CREATION SECTOR TO BRING BACK
JOBS AND REBUILD OUR
COMMUNITIES AND DRIVE ECONOMIC
IMPACT. THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
AN INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA
CULTURAL DISTRICTS. THE
INCREASE OF THE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS TO AN ESTIMATED SIXTY
COOLING REPRESENTING
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THANK YOU FOR YOUR FUTURE
SUPPORT FOR CULTURAL DISTRICTS.
ONE ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
FOR TAKING ON THE HOP BACK IN
OUR AREA COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
PLEASED TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE'S AUGMENTATION ON
ITEM THIRTY NINE INCREASING THE
AMOUNT OF SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION ON PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT. BEEN A
MAJOR PRIORITY FOR THE
SACRAMENTO AREA SIX COUNTY
REGION AND OUR REGIONAL
DELEGATION IN THE LEGISLATURE.
YOU NEED A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS I DO AND SURE THAT THE
CLEANING WORK. ALREADY DONE
INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY AND
REDUCE VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED
PER CAR MANDATE IS MET THANK
YOU AND WOULD. LIKE TO SEE THAT
REFLECTED IN THAT LANGUAGE. ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS IN
BREAKING THE EXECUTION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
THE PART OF THE ISSUE THIRTY
FOUR FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN KOBE NINETY REALLY
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL DISTRICTS.
INCLUDING HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
THAT HAVE BEEN AND CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO THE ONGOING CORBIN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND PUBLIC.
HEALTH NEEDS OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
NUMBERS SO IT'S A NOT A NOT-
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA AREN'T
IN SUPPORT OF THE-
LEGISLATURE'S FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- ON THE
WHOLE PRACTICE APPOINTED WITH A
LACK OF FUNDING FOR AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROJECTS.
PARTICULARLY ISSUE FORTY FIVE
WE WOULD HOPE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL- FUNDING FOR
OWNERSHIP- BACKLOG ARE THEY
JUST THREE CALHOUN PROGRAM AS
WELL AS ISSUES. AND WE WERE
HOPING FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
FOR ALL PROGRAMS TO HELP
SUPPORT DEVELOPMENT OF.
AFFORDABLE HOMEOWNERSHIP WHICH-
WHO IS ALREADY AND- AND HOW.
CLOSE THE RACIAL WEALTH BACK
FAMILY CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOMEOWNERSHIP. PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA THE JUDGE. ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR AND NUMBERS MY NAME IS
BEATRICE KATHY GRANT I'M THE
ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF AFFILIATE
JUMP A FIFTY FEET NONPROFIT
THEATER FOUNDED AND RUN BY
LGBTQ AND LATINO WOMEN WE ARE
ONE OF THE 70% OF NONPROFIT-
PETER COMMUNITY. COMMUNITY
BASED HERE IN CALIFORNIA WITH
ANNUAL REVENUES UNDER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND WELL I'M
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
FUNDS HAT YOU HAVE ALLOCATED
ON DEC TWENTY EIGHT I'M HERE TO
SAY THAT NON TINY NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS COMPANIES NEED
MORE THAN ONE TIME GRANT TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY
FIVE. WE NEED YOU TO ALLOCATE
FUNDING FOR S. B. EIGHT OH FIVE
WHICH PROVIDE BOTH PAYROLL
COMPLIANCE SUPPORT AND
EQUITABLE PAYROLL FUNDING SO
TINY CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
NONPROFIT COMPANIES CAN CREATE
JOBS AND PAY MINIMUM WAGE. AT
B. EIGHT OH FIVE FORTY LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION WILL FUND THIS PROGRAM
FOR TWO TO THREE YEARS AND
CREATE OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND JOBS FOR ARTISTS WHO
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE
FIFTEEN MONTH PANDEMIC SHUT
DOWN. PLEASE A SMALL FEE
DESPITE ALLOCATED TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. FOR SB EIGHT OH FIVE
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH. MY TWO
OH EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NICKELODEON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF OAKLAND ONE EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT AND THANKS FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE HOMELESS PACKAGE-
VERYGRACIOUS AND APPRECIATIVE
OF THE LARGE DOLLAR AMOUNT. I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE DESIRE
AND THE NEED FOR FLEXIBLE
SPENDING AND OF COURSE DIRECTOR
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING TO
CITIES- AND THEN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ROBUST PERFORMANCE MEASURES
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
NEGOTIATIONS WILL BEGIN WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND US ONE
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE AND THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. ONE TWO FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE TO FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON THE
WHIM HERE ON BEHALF OF
TRANSPUTER ANAHEIM. CALLING
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ITEM TWENTY
EIGHT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. WE
ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOCATING FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING TO
HELP SMALL NONPROFIT PERFORMING
ARTS COMPANIES COMPLY WITH AB
FIVE. STILL WE CAN'T STRESS
ENOUGH THE NEED FOR THE LEVEL
OF FUNDING THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED BY S. P. ETAL FIVE.
CODED IN EIGHTY FIVE HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
INCLUDE PETERS AND EMERGING AND
PORTABLE ARTISTS WHICH INCLUDES
SO MUCH ROBIN SO MANY LEVELS
AND TYPES OF REPRESENTATION IN
THE ARTS. THE FULLY CHAMPION
WHICH WERE POSING AS FAR TO SET
UP AN EQUITY FUND ANDA
PAYMASTER TO PROVIDE A LONG
TERM SUPPORT SYSTEM. THAT WILL
BUILD SUSTAINABILITY AND ENSURE
THEIR SURVIVAL COMMUNITY BASED
PERFORMING ARTS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
INVESTMENT IN THE LOCAL ARTS
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MARKET
THAT WELLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION CALLING ON BEHALF
OF ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOR THE
SPECIAL DISTRICT BACK BILL. THE
FDA APPRECIATE THE STATE
LEGISLATURES RECOGNITION OF
COVERT NINETEEN IMPACT ON
SPECIAL DISTRICT AND THE
COMMUNITY THEY SERVE INCLUDING
A LETTER SIGNED BY FORTY SIX
STATE LEGISLATORS STRONGLY
URGING THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION TO EXTEND ACCESS
THE FEDERAL CODE NINETEEN
RELIEF FUNDING. SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AS AUTHORIZED BY THE
US TREASURY. GIVEN ADDITIONAL
STATE BUDGET PROPOSALS TO
ADDRESS UTILITY RIORDAN'S CORKS
HARBORS AND TRANSIT AGENCY. BUT
LEGISLATORS PROPOSE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION SPECIAL DISTRICTS
COLBERT NINETEEN RELIEF FUND
ADDRESSES JUST OVER 20% OF THE
REMAINING PROJECTED NEED
INCLUDING LOCAL FIRE PROTECTION
HEALTHCARE AND PARK SERVICES.
THE FDA LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THAT RESPOND
TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. DURING THE
PANDEMIC ARE PROVIDED THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO MEET THE
NEXT CHALLENGES WE KNOW OUR
HEADS. THANK YOU. NINE TO FORTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS OSCAR
SANDOVAL NUMBER GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS SENIOR MANAGER FOR THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA I WASN'T GIVEN A
CHANCE TO COMMON ITEM THIRTY
THREE PERCEPTIVE YOU ARE JUST
LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
SUPPORTING HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE. AT THE
INNOVATION FUND AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH THE
LEGISLATOR TO ENSURE
HEALTHEQUITY IS INCLUDED. IN
THE NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND WE URGE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO FUND MORE
EQUITABLE HEALTH OUTCOMES I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR INVESTORS
INVESTING IN AN EXPANSION OF
MEDICAID OR MEDICARE FOR ALL.
INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS
AGE FIFTY PLUS WE ENCOURAGE
BOTH HOUSES TO PASS ABFOR
WHICH INSURANCE HEALTH FOR ALL
BY TWENTY TWENTY SIX. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH DUGGAR'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE
WITH URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR ISSUE FIFTY ONE
IN THE LOCAL STATE HOMELESSNESS
INVESTMENTS ACROSS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND SUB COMMITTEES
INCLUDING PROJECT HOME KEY AND
THE FLEXIBLE LOCAL HOMELESSNESS
AID. BILLBOARD TO CONVERSATIONS
ON THE ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILLS
THANK YOU. NINE TO FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
VANESSA GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
LOCATION OF GOVERNMENT
INSTRUCTED AT. ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY NINE ITEM TWO TWO POINT
ZERO THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL IN THE MAIN
REVISED FOR THE ALTERNATE
TALKING PRODUCTION APPROACHES
AND WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THEIR PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
THE FUNDING WITH AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION.
FOR A TOTAL OF. SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION THANK YOU. MY
NINETY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CAN MONITOR PRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
EXPECTING OUR SUPPORT FOR ITEM
NUMBER FIFTY ONE BATH HOME OF
THE PACKAGE AND REALLY
APPRECIATE. THE CONVENIENCE OF
A SIDE BAR YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS LEVEL
THREE COURSES CHANGE THAT WE
CAN ACQUIRE ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOUSING FOR
THEM AND THE COURT THAT WORKING
WITH YOU ON THE STREET LEVEL
THANK YOU. NINE ONE FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS NOT YOUR MAMA SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RECREATIONAL
PARK DISTRICT THE FIVE
CALIFORNIA FIRE DISTRICT
ASSOCIATION AND THE MID PENN
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT. EACH OF
THE COURT OF ISSUE THIRTY FOUR
THE LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL OF A
HUNDRED MILLION ARTIKEL RELIEF
TO SPECIAL DISTRICTS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ESPECIALLY STEPPED UP
TO SERVE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE COVER
NINETEEN RESPONSE I NEEDED
FUNDING TO HELP OFFSET THE
IMPACT OF THIS CAR. THANK YOU.
NINE TO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MA'AM CARE MEMBERS BROUGHT UP
IN BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO AND MAYOR DARRELL
STEINBERG LIKE THE THINK THE
CENTER INCLUDING FLEXIBLE
CORRECT MONEY TO CEASE TO
TACKLE THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU. NINE
TO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS- JOHN LAWRENCE RIVERA I
AM THE ARTISTIC DIRECTOR OF THE
PLAYWRIGHTS ARENA HERE IN LOS
ANGELES. I AM. VERY GRATEFUL
FOR THE LEGISLATURE FOR
ALLOWING FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING TO HELP SMALL
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
COMPANY. TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY
FIVE HOWEVER I WOULD LOVE TO
SUPPORT. SB EIGHT OH FIVE- THAT
IS NECESSARY FOR LONG TERM
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT WILL BUILD
SUSTAINABILITY FOR OUR SMALL
THEATERS THANK YOU. ONE TWO
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS KRISTEN
THEM BACK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIPS AND DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ONE OF THE REALLY
APPRECIATE BE- SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING FOR HOMELESSNESS YOU
ARE A MEMBER OF THE BRING
CALIFORNIA HOME COALITION AND-
IT DID IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT
STRUCTURE. ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL TO MAKE
SURE THAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTERS WHICH ARE HOUSING
HOMELESS FAMILIES THE HOMELESS
SURVIVORS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE FUNDING AS THE GROUP IS
IMPLEMENTED THANK YOU. NINE TWO
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
AMY HINES CYCLIC WILDCAT
CONSULTING I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE FUNDING ON ITEMS FORTY
EIGHT PAGE NINETY THREE UNDER
THE BUDGET THE REPORT FOR THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
THAT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR ITEM WILL GREATLY ASSIST
CALIFORNIA AFTER THE MORATORIUM
IS LIFTED WE ALSO STILL SUPPORT
THE SECOND ITEM IN THE ANTI
DISPLACEMENT HOUSING
PRESERVATION PACKAGE FOR FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
COMMUNITY ACQUISITION PROGRAM
THAT WAS BROUGHT FORTH BY
ASSEMBLY. BLOOM AND JEFF THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN. NINE TWO
THREE LOTTERY- WE NOW WILL HAVE
TO WE HAVE TWO MINUTES
REMAINING SO. WHATEVER METHOD
NUMBER PUBLIC SPEAKERS IT CAN
DO IN THE TWO MINUTES AGO IT.
THANK YOU NINE TO THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING KRISTEN
YOUNG GOING TO CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING ISSUE
NUMBER SIXTY ADDITIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS INITIATIVE WHEN
HE WON THE ELECTRONICS FOR PASS
THROUGH ENTITIES IN CREDIT FOR
NPR'S THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARES INTERNAL SENATORS
MICHAEL BACK WITH A BRAND
MCKINLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION THE FORTY FIVE
LOCAL BOARDS THEY REPRESENT A
CROSS CALIFORNIA. WE SUPPORT
THE THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSAL MUST HIRING TAX CREDIT
APPROVED IN SOME POOR
PREVIOUSLY WE ALSO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR PROVISIONS OF THE
BREAKING BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
ACT TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT A LEVEL
OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. LASTLY THE LANGUAGE
USED FOR A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
WORKFORCE BOARD TO PROVIDE
GRANTS ARE REGIONALLY ORGANIZED
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARDS.
FOR REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS IN
THE REAGAN UNDEFINED. TERMS ARE
GOING TO R. MAY TWENTY FIRST
LETTER TO YOUR COMMITTEE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
I'VE COME TO AN AGREEMENT ON-CLARIFYING LANGUAGE ENERGY
LEGISLATURE TO FIND A WAY TO
INCLUDE THIS LANGUAGE IN THE
FINAL ADOPTED BUDGET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ONE LAST COMMON WE'RE
DONE. ONE NINE TWO TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES HI MY NAME IS
EMMANUEL DELI- SH I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COUNSELING DOING THEATER IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS LOS ANGELES AND-
LIKE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES YOU
SEEM CALLING ON- THE COMMITTEE
FOR ID TWENTY EIGHT HELLO WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR A ONE TIME
FIFTY TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
BUDGET LINE ITEM TO COMPLY WITH
THE B. FIVE THAT THAT FUNDING
IS NOT ENOUGH WE DO MORE THAN-
YOU DON'T JUST CREATE PLEASE WE
WORK WITH COMMUNITY PARTNERS-
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY WORK WITH
CRITICAL INDUSTRIES. LIKE THAT
CAN GET A LITTLE. HEALTH
WORKERS WHO WORK WITH YOU TO.
ENSURE SMALL. DO MORE THAN IN
TWO BIG STORIES THE- DID THEY
REALLY ARE THE FABRIC OF
COMMUNITY AND- I URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT SB UNIFIED
FRONT. WHEEL DRIVE A TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SIR.
THANKS FOR YOUR CALLS IN ON
THAT ITEM SEPT THREE. WE WILL
NOW. GO TO THE ITEMS UNDER SUB
FOR. AND I WILL FIRST LOOK TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO ASK QUESTIONS OR
MAKE A COMMENT. REGARDING THE
ITEMS THAT ARE UNDER. WELL I'M
SORRY THOUGHT SPACED OUT SORRY
SEPT FIVE YOU'RE RIGHT- I HOPE.
MIXING MY NUMBERS OKAY SO I SEE
MR ASO'S MIKE UP AS THE CHAIR
OF SURVIVE YOU GO HEAD MISS
SENATOR BROWSER. FOR THE MIKE
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I TOO AM VERY PROUD OF ALL THE
WORK THAT THE STAFF AND
EVERYONE HAS DONE UNDER YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND SO I CAN'T HELP
BUT- IDENTIFIER A FEW THINGS
ARE THAT ARE IN THE- PROPOSED
BUDGET. REDUCING DEBT ON LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. THROUGH
THE LAMINATION OF CRIMINAL-
FEES AND ASSESSMENTS THE CIVIL
ASSESSMENTS. UP WILL GO A LONG
WAY RESTORING TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. TO PROCESS
BACKLOGS IN OUR COURTS- TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ACCESS
TO JUSTICE PACKAGE. FOR LEGAL
AID COLLABORATIVE CHORDS COUNTY
LAW LIBRARIES DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL COURT INTERPRETERS AND
COURT REPORTERS. IT WITH
SOMETHING THAT DUMB MANY MANY
PEOPLE. BUT TESTIFIED TO IT IN
OUR PANELS- WE HAVE THE LEGAL
AID SERVICES FOR RENTERS AND
HOMEOWNERS I SAW THAT THERE
WAS- CALLERS ABOUT HOMEOWNERS.
TO AVOID EVICTION AND
FORECLOSURE. WE HAVE A NEW
REHABILITATION REDEMPTION RE
ENTRY AND READING UNIFICATION
PACKAGE BECAUSE WE WANT
EVERYBODY TO WHO COMES OUT OF
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
STAY OUT. THROUGH CAREER
DEVELOPMENT REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING AND LOCAL SUPPORT
AND REMOVE THOSE BARRIERS TO
THE SUCCESSFUL ENTRY- AND LAST
ON THAT SUBJECT IS THE NEW
OFFICE OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY.
RESTORATION. OF COMBAT IN HATE
CRIMES- BY SUPPORTING THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE RACIAL
EQUITY OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY
THAT SENATOR PAN- HAS
CHAMPIONED- INVESTING IN
VARIOUS PROGRAMS TO. SUPPORT
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SEXUAL VIOLENCE HUMAN TRACK.
MANY
FUNDING FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE ACROSS THE
STATE. THAT'S THAT'LL CREATE
SOME REALLY GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
WELL PAID JOBS AND CAREERS- IN
SEVERAL INDUSTRIES IN
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE-
JOBS AS WELL- AND THEN FINALLY
UNDER THE LABOR. WE ARE
INVESTING A LOT TO REFOCUS THE
ET DES- ENERGY WHERE IT SHOULD
BE OF FUNDING TO ADDRESS THE
WORKLOADS FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE- BUSINESS SYSTEM THE
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM. APPS
THIS IS OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
ALL EMPLOYERS TO PAY WELL WHO
HAVE APPRENTICESHIP AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND- RECRUIT
FROM- HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
COMMUNITIES SO THERE'S MUCH
MUCH MORE BUT- THOSE ARE JUST
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WORK
OUT WE SHOULD ALL THIS ENTIRE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAFF SHOULD
BE VERY PROUD OF THANK YOU
MANAGER. AND BEFORE I CALL ON
SENATOR NEWMAN I WANT TO THANK
OUR CHAIR SENATOR DRAW SO- SEPT
FIVE IS OBVIOUSLY DEAR TO MY
HEART CAT BEING- CHAIRED IT FOR
THE FOUR YEARS PREVIOUS OR
PRIOR. AND I KNOW. HOW MUCH- SO
MANY CALIFORNIANS WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE ACTIONS THAT YOU
DESCRIBED  MEAN JUST FOR
EXAMPLE WELL WE HAVE. A BOTH AN
EVICTION ANTI FORECLOSURE
MORATORIUM. THE AND WHEN WE SEE
NEWS REPORTS THERE SEEMS TO BE
REAL ALARMING- PREDICTIONS OF A
HUGE WAVE OF BOTH THE FICTIONS
AND FORECLOSURES. BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN THE DATA THAT THOSE
TENANTS AND THOSE OWNERS WHO
HAVE ACCESS TO LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. CAN OFTEN. AVOID
AND WHEN I SAY VOID I DON'T
MEAN THAT THEY IN ANY WAY WOULD
BE- BREAKING THE LAW BUT RATHER
THAT THEY DON'T ALWAYS
UNDERSTAND EITHER WHAT THE
RIGHTS OR THE TERMS OF
CONTRACTS ARE VERY THINGS LIKE
THAT. AND THE LEGAL ASSISTANCE
CAN ASSIST THEM SO THAT THEN
THEY ARE ABLE TO RETAIN EITHER
THEIR HOME OR THE PLACE THAT
THEY LIVE AND OBVIOUSLY WE DO
NOT WELL WE HAVE FUNDS NOW WHEN
WE'RE INVESTING TO HELP PREVENT
AVOID HOMELESSNESS WE DO NOT
KNOW A LOT OF BIG WAVE OF NEW
HOMELESSNESS SO I THINK. MANY
OF THESE INVESTMENTS ARE SO
WISE AND OBVIOUSLY THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENTS BECAUSE
WE KNOW. THAT MANY PEOPLE WHO
EITHER WERE LAID OFF OR LEFT
THE WORK FORCE DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEIR JOBS MAY NOT
RETURN SO WE NEED TO HELP.
PROVIDE THE TECH PART OF
PROCREATING DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
THEY CAN GET BACK TO THE WORK
FORCE IN JOBS THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO BE RETAINED SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS AND THE STAFF
DID. AND. NOW I WILL CALL ON
SENATOR NEWMAN. AND IN THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SO- BEEF I
S. MY QUESTION LET ME. FIRST
BECAUSE- YOU- AND THE STAFF OF
THE LARGER BUDGET COMMITTEE-
FOR ALL THE WORK BUT BUT I JUST
POORLY THANK. AND COMMEND THE
CHAIR OF MY SUB SUB FIVE
SENATOR ROGER WHO'S DOING
WONDERFUL JOB- AND ALSO THE
STAFF OF SOME FIVE. SO WE'RE
VERY LUCKY TO HAVE ALL THREE OF
I GUESS FOR PEOPLE SO ALL OF
THEM- I HAVE A QUESTION KIND OF
A TWEENER I THINK BETWEEN SO
FOUR TO FIVE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT. THE U. I. DEATH IN THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT TRENDS TAX CREDIT-
ELEMENT AND SO IT'S MY QUESTION
IS PROBABLY FOR SOME COMMISSION
THE LA- AND DEPARTMENT FINANCE-
IF THEY ARE AVAILABLE FROM THAT
RUINING THEIR- DINNER IN SOME
WAY. CERTAINLY AND- I WILL TURN
TO BOTH L. A. O. AND U. F. BUT
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUDGET OUR
APPROACH. FOR THAT-
UNEMPLOYMENT DEBT AND THE
CREDIT IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WAS PROVIDED-
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISE. BUT
LET'S SEE WHO WANTS TO START. I
HAD A NAME IN THIS IS ERICA LAY
WITH HER. FINANCE ENGINE. I
WOULD JUST NOT EXACTLY SURE THE
QUESTION BUT- PROPOSAL THAT-
THE MAIN REVISION INCLUDE WAS
PAGAN. OF THE U. I TRUST FUND.
OF ONE. ONE BILLION DOLLARS-
USE OF OUR FINDS A LOT- ALONG
WITH LANGUAGE THAT ANY. USED
OUR FUNDS AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WOULD ALSO APPLY IF
YOU APPLIED TO PAY DOWN THAT
TRUST FUND- BALANCE. THAT WAS
THE MAY REVISION- PROPOSAL. IN
YET A MANAGER I MINUS ANY SAID
OUR- SOLUTION ARE BARB IS
DIFFERENT DID DID DID APPLY
SAID BY WAY OF TWO AND- TAX
CREDIT- AND SO MY GUESS IT'S
APPLIES TO AN MILLION IN TAX
FOR THE- BUT IT'S- HARD. MORE
AT THE SMALL BUSINESS YES AS A
ARE THE- IT'S OUR SYSTEM. THAT
THEY ARE THE ONE WHO WOULD BE
MOST HARD BY SUCH DEBT. AND
IT'LL THEM TO MORE QUICKLY.
RECEIVE SOME RELIEF. AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THE STRUCTURE OF
WHAT WAS IN THE MAY REVISE MAY
NOT. THE BUSINESSES THAT WOULD
BENEFIT. WOULD MAY NOT-
EXPERIENCE OR RECEIVE THAT
BENEFIT TILL TWENTY TWENTY NINE
TWENTY THIRTY. SO NOW I
APPRECIATE THAT SO MUCH OF THE
QUESTION REALLY. THEY CAN IT'S
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN I GUESS I
COULD START WITH INITIALLY- THE
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
COMPANY'S CURRENT YOU ARE THERE
TO SOME OF THE ORDER OF TWENTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS PROJECT TO
GO MUCH HIGHER- AND THAT. THE
TAX CREDITS. ALTHOUGH THEY MAY
PROVIDE RELIEF WON'T. OFFSET
ANY OF THE INTEREST THAT
ACCRUES AGAINST. THE DEBTORS IS
THAT CORRECT. ALL RIGHT YEAH I
CAN REALLY SPEAK TO THAT TYPE
CREDIT BUT IN. TO THE TEAM OF
THE YOU ARE BY- THE- IT IT
APPLIES TO ALL OF. IN STATE
THAT PAID. THE TRUST SO. IF
THERE IS A- IN THE U. TRUST
FUND FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IS- OVER TWO
CONSECUTIVE YEARS THERE THERE
WOULD BE AN IMPACT ON THE
EMPLOYER TAX RATE. AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WELL THIS. AT THE
BETTER LEVEL IN REGARDS TO A
TAX CREDIT- ALL EMPLOYERS WHO
DO RECEIVE A 6% TAX CREDIT- AS
PART OF THE FEDERAL IT'S CALLED
THE FOOD OFF. AND HOWEVER IF
THE STATE HAS A NEGATIVE
BALANCE- THAT CREDIT IS
REDUCED- ANNUALLY- FROM A FIVE
POINT 4% AND I THINK IT'S POINT
3% ANNUALLY. SO IT. IT AND
ENCOURAGE YOUR QUESTION JUST
THAT'S SORT OF HOW THE PROPOSAL
WOULD WORK IS WE WOULD PAY DOWN
THE TRUST FUND THERE WOULD BE A
BALANCE STILL REMAINING. BUT IN
REGARDS TO INTEREST THE STATE
IS ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING THE
INTEREST IN REGARDS TO- THEY
FEDERAL TRUST FUND ITSELF
SHOULD ENSURE ISSUE HAD WE HAD
WE MADE A DOWN PAYMENT AGAINST
THE DEAD IT WOULD HAVE SAVED US
SOME AMOUNT. OF INTEREST OVER
TIME RIGHT SO GOOD COULD DID
DID YOU LOOK AT HOW MUCH THAT
MIGHT HAVE. SAVED THE STATE
PROSPECTIVELY OVER. IT WAIT
WAIT WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK SEE
IF E. D. D. ROUTE UP IN ORDER
TO THE BUT YOU THE SOONER WE
CAN DOWN THAT DEBT THE LESS YOU
WOULD HAVE TO PAY OVER THAT'S
TRUE AND THEN THEN I GUESS THE
REMAIN MICROCHIP FOR THE LA- OR
FOR OUR SIDE- AND INSISTS I
MEAN IT DID THIS TECH CREDIT IS
DESIGNED TAKE PLACE OF TEN
YEARS- WHAT'S YOUR SUREN STAY
THAT HE WILL REMAIN IN PLACE
FOR ALL TWENTY. AND WHAT WOULD
HAVE IF IT DOES NOT. THIS
PADDOCK YOU WANNA RISK TO THAT.
GIVE HEADACHES. LET'S ANALYST-
YOU KNOW I MIGHT ASK MY CO
BRIAN YOU'LL FROM OUR AND LABOR
UNIT TO SEE IF HE HAS ANY
INSIGHT AND NOT ON ON WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO THE- CREDIT IF
IT'S NOT MAINTAINED OVER THE
TEN YEAR PERIOD. YES THANK YOU
GAME OF GRANULAR WITH THE OHIO-
THERE YOU KNOW THE ASSURANCE
FOR THE CREDIT- CONTINUING TO
EXIST WOULD BE THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD- YOU KNOW AS THEY DO WITH
ALL OUR TAX CHANGES HAS A
TRAILER BILL THAT PLACES IT
INTO STATUTE- THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING YOU KNOW- THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO BIND THE
HANDS OF FUTURE LEGISLATURES SO
IT WILL REMAIN IN LAW- THERE'S
NOTHING. THE CAN STOP A FUTURE
LEGISLATURE FROM APPEALING THAT
BUT- YOU KNOW THE FUNDING FOR
THOSE TAX CREDITS. ARE BUILT
INTO THE LEGISLATURE'S PACKAGE
IN THE OUT YEARS- IT IT SEEMS
CLEAR THAT IT'S- THE INTENT OF
THE PACKAGES IS SIGNALING TO
PROVIDE THIS ACTUALLY IT'S OVER
TEN YEARS- SO. I DON'T KNOW
THAT ANSWER YOUR QUESTION NO I
THINK THAT'S THAT'S FAIR- AND
IS IT IS IT FAIR TO SAY THAT
ONE OF THE BASELINE ASSUMPTIONS
IS THAT AT SOME POINT- THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL GIVE US
SOME LEVEL OF RELIEF FROM OUR
CURRENT YOU ARE DEAD. THE
CRYSTAL BALL GO HEAD YEAH I
DON'T I DON'T I DON'T I DON'T
THINK. I DON'T THINK WE HAVE A
CLEAR ANSWER FOR YOU ON THAT I
THINK WE WOULD ALL- GRATEFULLY
ACCEPT THAT TYPE OF RELIEF FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- BUT- WE
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS TRUE-
RESEARCHERS ARE THEN IN THE END
WE YOU KNOW WE AS A STATE OR-
AND ALL THE BUSINESSES
ATTENDED. THE YOU WHY- ARE
GOING TOO FAST DID DID TO HAVE
TO PAY DOWN THE DEBT THE
INTEREST. OVER TIME- AND SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT. THIS PROGRAM
TO LIVE REALLY TARGET SMALL
BUSINESSES. WHAT WAS THE
THINKING WITH RESPECT TO OTHER
BUSINESSES PARTICULAR MEDIUM TO
LARGE SIZED BUSINESSES- THAT
THEY TEND TO SHOULDER A LOT OF
THE BIRD PAYING. THESE U. I.
TAXES. I WOULD THAT. TO THAT
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OR MAYBE THE CHAIR
OUR OUR OFFICE WAS NOT-
NECESSARILY INVOLVED WITH THE
CRAFTING OF THIS ELEMENT OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. FAIR
ENOUGH. FIVE JUST A COUPLE
THOUGHT SENATOR NEWMAN FIRST
OFF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
WAIVED INTEREST RATES FOR THE
U. Y. DE THREE SEPTEMBER. WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT MOVING
FORWARD. ADDITIONALLY ON YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION ONCE THE
LEGISLATURE PUTS THE TAX CREDIT
IN PLACE IT WOULD TAKE A TWO
THIRDS VOTE. TO ELIMINATE THAT
TAX CUT FROM SMALL BUSINESSES
SO. THE LEGISLATURE WOULD HAVE
TO VOTE BY TWO THIRDS TO
ELIMINATE IT- THE LOGIC FOR
THIS. IN THIS MOMENT IN TIME IS
THAT IF WE LOOK AT THE- STOCK
MARKET IN OTHER INDICATORS MANY
OF OUR LARGER BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN DOING. VERY WELL AND SOME
PROFITING. YOU KNOW DOING THEM
FAR BETTER IN FACT UNDER THIS
PANDEMIC WERE AS OR SMALL
BUSINESSES. HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY HURT NOW OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S ALWAYS EXCEPTIONS THERE
SOME LARGE BUSINESSES WHO WERE
HURT ALSO BUT IN GENERAL THE
SMALL BUSINESSES HAD A FAR
WORSE ECONOMIC IMPACT THEN THE
LARGER. BUSINESSES SO THE
MOTIVATION WAS TO HELP THOSE
WHO ARE MOST WHO'VE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED NIGHT I DO APPRECIATE
THAT SO IT'S SO I WOULD ASK IT
BY WAY OF FINISHING MY COLLEGE-
IF DO YOU EVER COULD PROVIDE
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
WHICH IS WHAT WOULD. PAYING OFF
DID YOU KNOW SOME. AMOUNT I
THINK IT BETTER ONE POINT ONE
BILLION IT MAKE A COMMENT WHAT
WOULD THAT HAVE SAVED- INTEREST
RATE JUST FOR THE STATE OF THE
COURSE OF THE SAME TEN YEAR
PERIOD IF THEY COULD GET BACK%
TO US I'D. BE GRATEFUL- BUT
THANK YOU. SENATOR ALL RIGHT
ANY COMMENTS- BY- COLLEAGUES OR
COURSE YES SENATOR PARRY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE CHAIR OF
THE LET'S CAR I DID WANT TO
JUST CALL OUT AND THANK- THIS
FOR. LOOTING THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION- IN GENERAL FUND TO
COMBAT. THE INCIDENTS- THE API-
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY HE HAS
BEEN RISING- ACTUALLY FORTY
NINE- AMONGST MANY GROUPS-
TALKING AS MANY GROUPS- AND-
MORE SPECIFICALLY AGAINST THE
API COMMUNITY AT THE TECH
THERE'S BEEN A SPIKE- RELATED.
TO BOTH COVE IT BUT ALSO TO THE
RHETORIC THAT'S. AROUND THAT
AND- IN AS WE TRY TO PROVIDE TO
CALIFORNIA THE CAN- THE- NEEDS
THAT RELIEF SO THIS STUFF THE
JOB THAT VICTIM- ALSO.
INTERESTING ENOUGH THE DATA
THAT WE GOT CAME FROM NOT FOR
PROFIT SO WE NEED TO HAVE- A-
DATA COLLECTION AS WELL BUT
ALSO TO ADDRESS SOME HISTORIC
INEQUITIES IN TERMS OF ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS FOR THE API
COMMUNITIES SO HERE IN THIS
BUDGET WE'RE- PROPOSING- MANY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PROGRAM TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES TO HELP
INDIVIDUALS WHO FOUGHT
SUFFERED. BECAUSE OF COVE IT
AND ITS IMPACTS- BUT FOR THE P.
I. COMMUNITY WE NEED
INTERPRETATION AND- INTERPRET
CORE AND BE SURE WEPEOPLE
HAVE. IT IN LANGUAGE HEALTH- WE
NEED TO BE SURE WE UPDATE
EQUITY BECAUSE TOO OFTEN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND VISIBLE AND THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR COMMUNITY. AND
THOSE ARE ALL REALLY IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS IN THERE AND THEN WE
ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT. WE
HAVE ARE I THINK ENCLAVES WHO
ACTUALLY SUFFERED EVEN PRIOR TO
THE PUBLIC HEALTH LOCKDOWNS.
WERE ALREADY SUFFERING IS A
**** PREJUDICE AND
DISCRIMINATION SO AGAIN I WANT
TO EXPRESS MY GRATITUDE THAT
THAT'S IN THIS PACKAGE I HOPE
THAT THE GOVERNOR WILL SEE FIT
TO SUPPORT- THE STATE SENATE.
AND ASSEMBLY AND SUPPORTING
THIS PACKAGE SO WE CAN PROVIDE
RELIEF TO THE API COMMITTEE BUT
ALSO MORE BROADLY I THINK
ELEMENTS OF THIS ARE MORE
BROADLY FOR ALL THE- DIFFERENT
RACIAL AND ETHNIC CAUCUSES AS
WELL- TO HELP THOSE COMMUNITIES
AS WELL BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY
HE HAS BEEN HAPPENING ACROSS.
APPRECIATE THE SOLIDARITY AND
HOPE THAT THAT WE CAN GET THIS
THROUGH. IN- THIS BUDGET THANK
YOU. THANK SENATOR PAT. ALL
RIGHT. LOOK SEND CAREER. THANK
YOU VERY- MA'AM I AM I NUMBER
ONE ON THE- LET'S AS A PRIEST
TRIAL- WITH THE PROPOSAL WAS
EVERY CHECK AND I WANNA GO
RECORD SAYING THAT I'M HOPING
WE CAN HAVE MORE COME ON THE
SET. TO LOOK AT ECHO AND SAFETY
IN THE PRE TRIAL SYSTEM
MAINTENANCE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT- THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A
REASON WE REJECTED THE PROPOSAL
BUT IT WE SHOULD HAVE SOME MORE
CONVERSATIONS ON IT. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME JUST ONE LITTLE
NOTE THERE IS A PRE TART TRIAL-
PILOT THAT IS CONTINUING. SO
AND THAT WILL CONTINUE
INDEPENDENT OF THE ACTION THAT
WE TAKE IN THIS BUDGET- ALL
RIGHT THE. OKAY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO DO OUR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
SEPT FIVE AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
CORRECTING ME SO I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN OUR GALLERY I'M
LOOKING NOW IN THE OVERFLOW
ROOM THAT'S EMPTY SO MODERATOR
YOU CAN- I. QUEUE UP FOR FOLKS
THAT WANT TO COMMENT. ON THE
PROVISIONS- THE ACTIONS THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKING. ONE
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE. AND AND WE
WILL STICK TO FIFTEEN MINUTES
SO PUBLIC COMMENT APPRECIATE
YOUR BEING. A RESPECTFUL OF THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO MAY BE CALLING
IN SO WE CAN HEAR FROM AS MANY
AS POSSIBLE GO AHEAD MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NINE TO FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TINA REGARDLESS OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. FOUR THIRTY SHE SHOULD
NOT BE ACTIVE PRODUCTIVE
INVESTMENT TO HELP PROTECT
TENANTS FROM ADDICTION AND
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE END OF THE
CIVIL ASSESSMENTS IN CRIMINAL
AND TRAFFIC COURT. LIKELY WE
ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE FINAL
BUDGET WILL INCLUDE AN
EXTENSION OF THE EVICTION
MORATORIUM OTHER TENANT
PROTECTIONS AND MEDIC HOW
HOUSING SUPPORT CAPACITY
BUILDING GRANTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ONE ONE OF. MY
PARDON ME MY MANTRA YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS MICHELLE PEREZ A
PROGRAM DIRECTOR AT THE- OFTEN
LEADER CALIFORNIA WHERE AND I'M
NOT ANGELES. HELLO I'M DOWN IF
WE NEED BETTER OUT THE- COURAGE
IN THE- TO ADOPT COMMITTEE'S.
THAT REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
FUNDING FOR YOURSELF HOW FREE
TRIAL. ZERO THE FIRST REACH OUT
PAGE IN THE- AND SIXTY ONE AND
HAS SIXTY OF X. ON THAT. THE
BEST RESULTS OR HIS AGENCY IS
SURE TO ORDER THEIR PRINT ONE
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT AND NOT
BEHOLDEN TO PRE EXISTING
ENFORCEMENT PARKER. BODIES AND
TO. REDUCE OF THE COURT. FOR
EXAMPLE ARE PUTTING A COPY.
WHAT ABOUT CITY ROCK BUT NOT
FOR THE FROM TRIAL THE DRIVER
MORTON SAID FIVE. PEOPLE
COULDN'T GET TARGET FELONIES.
87% MAKE THEIR APPEARANCE. 90%
OF NEW PHONE ARRESTS ARE THEIR
CASE. SEEMS LIKE NEW JERSEY
KENTUCKY HAS TO GRAPPLE. PRE
SHOT AND BE IN. OF CO. I BOUGHT
LOOKING TRY TO. FROM THE PANDA
OFTEN MY THAT HAVE BUY CARS.
CALLUM SHOULD BE GOOD WRAP UP
CHARLIE NOT. AND THE
PARTNERSHIP. ENSURING HUMAN
RIGHTS DON'T DECREASE AND
REQUEST A COMPLIMENTARY
INVESTMENT IN THE FACILITY
INSURANCE FUND TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS WORKERS TAXES ARE
NOT INCREASED TO FUND THE
EXPANSION THANK YOU. NINE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
TECHNICALITY HOW CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES ASSOCIATION OR
CALCUTTA IT'S THE KIND OF ISSUE
SIXTY ARE SUBJECTED PACKAGE
PARTICULARLY THE FORTY MILLION
FOR DEPENDENCY COUNCIL THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING THAT IN
BALANCE THE BUDGET. SH. NINE
TWO FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING. MADAM CHAIR
DISTINGUISHED SUBCOMMITTEE MY
NAME IS SAM LEWIS ON THE BACK
OF THE RECTOR BUT THEY ARE
STUDENT I WAS COALITION I
SUPPORT SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN A
REHABILITATION REDEMPTION
REENTRY AND REUNIFICATION
PACKAGE SPECIFICALLY PINE GROVE
CONSERVATION CAP RESOURCES. IN
TWO FIVE TWO TWO FIVE AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE BY TWO TO
FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HIS
CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR BEING
ABLE O. HELP PEOPLE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED AND CHANGE THE WAY
OUR SYSTEM WORKS I'M A LIVING.
EXAMPLE OF WHAT REHABILITATION
DOES. NINE TWO FIFTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS JOHN RIFLING
ONE WITH HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH ARM
AND HOLD ALONG I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT I OPPOSE FUNDING THE ARM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PRE TRIAL
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT PROMOTE THE
USE OF RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS IN
FRONT PROBATION APARTMENTS. TO
MONITOR. PRESUMPTIVELY INNOCENT
PEOPLE RELEASED PRE TRIAL THANK
YOU. NINE TWO SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD EVENING- CHAIR AND
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JANELLE CARTER I'M
WITH THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION I'M A LIFE COACH WITH
THE HOMECOMING DANCE ROUTINE
AND I'M GOING TO IRON WOOD AND
TELEPATHS THE PRISONS ARE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN. THE
ABILITY VISION. THANKS RE ENTRY
AND RE YOU YOU RE GOING TO
CATION PACKAGE SPECIFICALLY
PINE GROVE CONSERVATIVE
CONSERVATION CAMP AND
RESOURCES. NUMBER FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE NUMBER FIVE TWO TWO FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE TWO SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOIN
BACK TO STORY TO YOU INDEX
PROJECTED CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORTED SENATE ISSUES TWO TO
FOUR ISSUES TO INJURY REJECTED
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND EARLY COMPARED HIGHLAND
AVENUE YOUR CREDIT PROPOSALS
FOR DEBT FORGIVENESS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ISSUES FOR.
WHICH ARE SUPPOSED TO PROVIDE A
MORE DIRECT SUPPORT TO LOW
INCOME FAMILIES BY REDUCING THE
BURDEN OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE SEES
DOCTOR SPECTACLE IN
RETROACTIVELY. MAKERS ARE LIKE
DISH SUPPORT CONDITION NINETEEN
REGARDING ADDITIONAL OUR LEGAL
COUNSEL TO PER PERSON'S.
REPAIRING THE VEHICLE MARKET
THANK YOU. MINE TOO SO FOUR
YOUR LIFE IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS LET
THAT THING I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND CAMPAIGNS WITH
DIGNITY AND POWER NOW HERE IN
LOS ANGELES. CALLING TO
STRONGLY URGE THAT THE HUNDRED
FORTY MILLION DOLLAR PRE TRIAL
PILOT FUNDING THROUGH JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BE REJECTED REJECTED
QUICKLY YEAH WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY STAY IN TUNE
WITH THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
VOTERS. AND PEOPLE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE VERY VALID IN
LONGSTANDING CONCERNS WITH
RACIAL BIAS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
ADMINISTERED SYSTEM THE
SPECIALTY AT THE MANIFEST IN
THE PRE TRIAL SYSTEM THE JAILED
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
LEGALLY INNOCENT PEOPLE THESE
PILOTS WILL ONLY MAKE THE
PROBLEM WORSE. THE SHORT AMOUNT
OF DATA THAT WE HAVE COMPILED
PROVEN TO MAKE THAT EVEN WORSE
THAN WE THOUGHT. SO WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE STAYING CLEAN STOP
THIS AND LOOK TOWARD THE BETTER
EXAMPLES THAT ARE POPPING UP
ALL OVER THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND INFORMED BY
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. ONE TWO
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
COULD SEND THEM BACK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REALLY WANT
TO APPRECIATE ALL OF THE-
COMMITTEEMEMBERS AND ALSO
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THE BUDGET- AND DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR ITEMS THIRTEEN
AND FOURTEEN ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR VICTIMS OF
THE PHONE. AND ESPECIALLY THE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT AND LEFT THE
CONFESSIONAL VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND WE BELIEVE
STRONGLY THAT WE CAN TRULY
PREVENT VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. ALTHOUGH ONE
APPRECIATE THE LEGAL SERVICES
FUNDING INCLUDED HERE AND ITEM
THIRTY TWO AND THE RECOGNITION
OF THE NEED TO CONTINUE THE
HIGH WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE FOR
PAID. LEAVE AND STI THANK YOU.
NINE THIRTY THREE YOR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS JENNIFER MILEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
WANTS TO EXPRESS OUR-
APPRECIATION FOR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND I'LL BET YOU DO-
ALSO WANTED TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT- ISSUES.
IN PARTICULAR ISSUE FORTY.
THIRTEEN THAT THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING AND FUTURE HIRING
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
STATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE
TO SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WOULD
BE TANTAMOUNT ON BEHALF OF THE
ATHLETES ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
WANTING TO EXPRESS DEEP
APPRECIATION FOR THE PROPOSAL
TO AUGMENT EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE PARTICULARLY AS IT
RELATES TO ENSURING QUICK
REPORTERS WILL BE IN THE COURT
TO COMPLY WITH JAMESON BE DEATH
THAT TO ENSURE. THAT INDIGENT
LITIGANTS DON'T LOSE THEIR
RIGHT ON APPEAL WE ALSO WANT TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THE
COMMENTS MADE BY SENATOR TABLET
EURO REGARDING HAVING AN ON
GOING AND YOU WANT A
CONVERSATION REGARDING PRETRIAL
RELEASE IN THE IMPORTANT ROLE.
BY OPERATION AND THE- ENSURE
THAT GEOGRAPHY DOESN'T DICTATE.
ON ACCESS TO JUSTICE. FINALLY
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
OF THE COMMENTS MADE BY BILL
QUESTIONS CAROLINE POVERTY AND
THE ACLU I THINK MEANS ENSURING
THAT THE FINAL BUDGET DEAL
INCLUDES AN EXTENSION TO THE
VICTIM MORATORIUM AND BAD-
CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES ARE
BETTER ADDRESSED I'M NOT. THE
FUNDING FOR THE COURT. ON THE
BACK AND THE PEOPLE THANKS. ONE
TWO THREE SIX YOUR LINE OF THE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS DOMINIQUE NAM AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF
OF OVER THIRTY FIVE MEMBER
ORGANIZATION FOR THE STATEWIDE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR YOUTH
AND COMMUNITY. JUSTICE WE
APPRECIATE BETTER GET OFF WHILE
HIGHLIGHTING A COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION TO ALLOCATE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO THE
OFFICE THAT YOU CAN COMMUNITY
RESTORATION AND ASKED THE
COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THAT
RECOMMENDATION THIS LEVEL OF
FUNDING INCLUDED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE VISION FOR HOW WE
TREAT THE POOR YOUNG PEOPLE. WE
WANT TO GET SPECIAL THANKS TO
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S LEADERSHIP
ON THIS ISSUE AND PARTICULARLY.
CARE DIRECTOR AND HER STAFF
THANK YOU. NINE TO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING AND HAPPY
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT OF ISSUE FIVE AND SIX
LEGAL AID FOR RENTERS AND THE
ACTORS. ACTORS YOU WANT TO
THINK OF WHAT COULD BE THE LAST
MONTH TOOK BAND ESSENTIAL LEGAL
SERVICES FREE PRACTICE THE
FRESHLY APPRECIATE THAT THREE
YEAR ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT ARE.
PROVIDE LEGAL AID SERVICES FOR
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS TO AVOID
EVICTIONS AND FORECLOSURES YEAH
I WANT TO THANK YOU AND WITH
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE FIFTY
MILLION INVESTMENT IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET AND THE TWENTY
MILLION I'M GOING TO FIND BY
THE LEGAL AID LEGAL AID
SERVICES THE DETOXIFYING. THE
PRESEASON BACK ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS FOR THE LOW INCOME AND
OTHER VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY HAVE CONTINUED ****
REACTOR. WITH A LEGALLY THANK
YOU. NINE ONE. SO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
BUT I THINK I CANNOT HALF
MARATHON ADULT EDUCATION
INSTITUTION WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM
SPECTRUM DISORDER IN REGARDS
ISSUE FORTY. WE SUPPORT THE
ADMINISTRATION FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR ALLOCATION TO TRAINING
PROGRAMS FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER WHICH
WILL HELP TRAIN EMPLOYERS
RECRUIT HIRE TRAIN AND RETAIN
PEOPLE WITH ASD AND CONNECT
THEM TO A LIVING WAGE JOBS WE
THANK SENATOR ALSO FOR HER WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING. THE SAME
DOCTORS IN THE FINAL BUDGET
THANK YOU. NINE NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND IF WE CAN LOWER THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
EXCEPT HERE SUPPORT FOR ISSUES
THAT IN THE HOME WITH YOU TO
MAKE THE SERVICE OF THE HOUSING
PROGRAM REALLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. FIFTY NINE DOLLAR ONE
TIME INVESTMENT FOR A PROGRAM
THAT IS REALLY DOING GREAT WORK
AND SERVE OUR NONPROFIT CEOS
AND SERVING YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ALSO THE PART OF
THE ISSUE THIRTEEN AND THAT. IS
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT FUNDING
AND THE PART OF THE ACT WILL
CONDUCT THE PACKAGE ESPECIALLY
FOR THE DEPENDENCY. COUNSELING
ACCESS TO LEGAL AID THANK YOU.
MY TWO TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CHURCH COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JOSELYN SALTO WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M A LIFE
COACH WITH THE HOPE OF
REDEMPTION FEES AND I CURRENTLY
WORK AT PELICAN BAY STATE
PRISON I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN.
REHABILITATION REDEMPTION
REENTRY AND REUNIFICATION
PACKAGE. SPECIFICALLY PINE
GROVE CORPORATION CAP REPORTED
FIVE TWO TWO FIVE AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING
BURKHART THIRTY PEOPLE. FIVE
TWO TWO FIVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE. NINE TWO FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD EVENING KAREN MEMBERS OF
THE SPECIAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR COMMUNITY
INVESTMENT I JUST WANTED TO
YOU- THANK YOU FOR SUB FOR ITEM
HAND I PULLED THAT THEY DIDN'T
GET THE CALL IN EARLIER AFTER
THE SEVENTY MILLION INVESTMENT
TO CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
INVESTMENT AND INNOVATION
PROGRAM TO SUPPORT. COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
KATIE WATTERS SMITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WORK AND FAMILY
COALITION I'M CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF THE GENOCIDE IN
THIRTY TWO YEARS TO EXPAND THE
CURRENT WAGE REPLACEMENT RATE
BIRTHDATE INSTABILITY INSURANCE
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE WE REALLY
ACQUIRED THAT- THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FOR INCLUDING THIS
EXTENSION. I'M IN THEIR
PROPOSED BUDGET AND WE ALSO
CALL ON THE LEGISLATURE TO IN
BATH AND THAT DISABILITY
INSURANCE FUND TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS TAXES DO NOT
INCREASE. TO FIND THIS
IMPORTANT EXPANSION THANK YOU.
NINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
ROBERT MITCHUM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE CALLING
OPPOSITION ISSUE THIRTY ONE
UNDER BUDGET SOME FIVE GUARDING
REJECTION GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL
FOR PAYMENT TO STATE YOU I
PHONED- AND HIS DATE A
CROSSOVER ISSUE WITH. ME AFTER
NEWMAN MENTIONED IT'S ALSO IN
SUB FLOORS- BACKED. YOU AMOUNT
OF THE IN- THE BOARD ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR I BELIEVE I HAD TWO
SMALL. TWO BILLION OUT OF A
TWENTY ONE BILLION PRESENT
FRAUD COOL THINGS TOO SMALL TO
BE GIVEN THE JUST UNDER ONE
BILLION- TWENTY ONE BILLION.
ONE PARTICULAR GIVEN THAT JUST
UNDER ONE BILLION MAY BE
COMPRISED OF FRAUD THAT
EMPLOYERS BE PAYING BACK- WE
ALSO SEE THE DELAY IN THE TAX
PROPOSAL AS PROBLEMATIC GIVEN
THAT IT COULD DISAPPEAR IN
FUTURE YEARS LEAVING EMPLOYERS
ACTUALLY BLACK THE GOVERNORS
PRESENT PROPOSAL IN RELIEF- TO
HELP WITH. IT SHOULD BE RE
EXAMINED FORWARD AND THEN THE
RECONCILIATION PROCESS THANK
YOU. THANK YOUR MODERATOR WE
NOW WE NOW HAVE JUST TWO
MINUTES REMAINING. THANK YOU
AND NINE TO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO
TEN YOU MAY BE ON MUTE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY TWENTY THREE YOU MAY
BE ON MUTE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE TWO SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
REGARDING THE JUDICIAL PRE
TRIAL ISSUE FOLLOWING THE
HUNDRED COURT DIVISION WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BEING APPLIED COURTS
WILL BE IMPLEMENTING PRE TRIAL
DECISIONS WITHOUT THE BENEFIT
OF HAVING A FUNDED SYSTEM TO
ENCOURAGE THE FROM THE START-
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE.
EXTENSIVE WORK TO ADVANCE
EQUITY IN ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE. AND WE SEE A STATEWIDE
PRE TRIAL FREE WORK AT
SUPPORTING THAT GOAL. WITHOUT A
STATEWIDE FRAMEWORK THAT
CREATES STANDARDS OF
IMPLEMENTATION IT'S LIKELY TO
BE DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS AND
REDUCE THE PR TRIAL ACROSS THE
STREET. WE SEE THAT WITH A VERY
TIMELY AND IMPORTANT ISSUE
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
HUMPHREY DEPRESSION- AND WE
CERTAINLY HOPE. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE AND
HOW BEST TO ADVANCE THE GOALS
OF EQUITY AND. AND FIFTY AND-
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FIFTY YOU MAY BE ON ME PLEASE
GO AHEAD. OF MINE TO SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MATT WAS IT WOULD
HAVE SAVED CALIFORNIA JUST
QUICKLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
THAT EVERYONE HAS BEEN DOING ON
THE BUDGET- IF YOU COPY SHOULD
LEADERSHIP BUT WE JUST URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR TO DO
MORE TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WORKERS AND CRIED OUT TO PAY
OUT OF THE YEAR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ONE TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MICHAEL CAN TELL EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF MY EIGHTY FIVE TREND
RELIGIONS THE NUMBER THAT YOU
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR PROFOUND
THANKS AND APPRECIATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION. PROPOSING TO
CONTINUE SPECIAL RELIEF FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES. AS YOU MOVE
FROM PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE THE
FINAL LANGUAGE WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO MOVE THE
ADMINISTRATION TRAILER BELOW
LANGUAGE FORWARD WITH SPECIFIC
MODIFICATIONS REQUESTED BY MY
ASSOCIATION IN OUR MARCH TWENTY
SIXTH LETTER TO LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP. WE URGE YOU TO
EXPAND THAT RELIEF UNTIL FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
AS THE INDUSTRY AND CAPITAL
TAKE UNTIL THEN TO RECOVER WITH
REGARD. TO RIDERSHIP AND
REVENUES. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
IN Q. EXCELLENT OKAY SO THAT
WAS OUR AND CONCLUDING OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT WE'VE HEARD IT
NOW FOR THEFIRST TWO ITEMS AND
ALSO OUR SUBS ONE TWO THREE AND
FOUR AND FIVE. AND- WE I WANT
TO. APPRECIATE ALL OF THE
PUBLIC WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY AND IF
THERE WERE ANY OF YOU WHO
WANTED TO THAT WE- RAN OUT OF
TIME. PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE WHICH YOU CAN DO
EASILY ON OUR WEBSITE. AND
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T LIKE TO HAVE
TO TURN TO CUT OFF PUBLIC
COMMENT SO IF THERE IS ANYONE
WHO WASN'T ABLE TO- WE REALLY
DO ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUBMIT TO
US- ALL RIGHT NOW- WE- ARE
WAITING FOR. A VOTING LIST-
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DIVIDE SOME
OF THE BOATS UP A BIT WE MAY
HAVE TO TAKE JUST ABOUT A THREE
TO FIVE MINUTE PAUSE. FOR THAT
LIST. SO WE'RE GONNA PAUSE FOR
JUST FINE. I SUPPOSE I
SHOULDN'T SAY THREE TO FIVE I
SHOULD JUST SAY FIVE. WE'LL
PAUSE FOR FIVE MINUTES OKAY.
FIVE MINUTES FIVE MINUTES. MMHM.
OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE WILL
RECONVENE SO IF I GET
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO START VOTING NOW
ANDY I'M GONNA ENTERTAIN
MOTIONS I'M GOING TO READ THE
ITEMS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON- SO LET'S
START WITH SUB ONE. SENATOR
GROVE YOU HAVE A COMMENT BEFORE
WE START I DO I HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS ON A COUPLE OF THE
ITEMS IF THAT'S OKAY MADAM
CHAIR- WE TOOK THAT BEFORE I'M
SURE PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS TO VOTE.
I KNOW THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
CONSOLIDATE THE VOTE SO WE ARE
YOU GO HEAD THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE INDIVIDUAL VOTES WE
CAN JUST CONSOLIDATED. THAT'S
WHY WE MISSED IT JUST IF
ANYBODY COULD ANSWER ON-
BUDGETS OF FIVE. ITEM SEVEN AND
TWENTY FOUR THEY'RE
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED IS
THERE A REASON SINCE WE DON'T
HAVE THE LANGUAGE. SEVEN AND.
TWENTY FOUR. DO WE NOT HAVE LA
OR FINANCE ON THE LINE MA'AM.
ONE MOMENT LET'S SEE IF OUR
BUDGET SAID CHAIR WANTS TO MAKE
A COMMENT OKAY. LIKE THEY SEEM
LIKE GOOD ITEMS THAT IT'S JUST
A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE SO I'M
JUST CURIOUS WHAT THE INCREASES
FOR ONE MOMENT.
SENATOR DRAWS
OR DID YOU WANT TO COME IN HERE
ON ANY OF THOSE. I'M TRYING TO
REMEMBER THE PARTICULARS OF IT
BUT. THIS COMES UNDER- YES- I'M
NOT SURE WHAT WHAT IT'S IT IS
AN EMERGENCY IT'S SEVEN FIVE
MA'AM IF I COULD JUST CLARIFY
ITS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUNDS FOR HOMELESS
YOUTH EMERGENCY SERVICES COUNTY
HOUSING WHICH SOUNDS AMAZING
BUT IT IS ALSO- I BELIEVE EIGHT
TIMES THE AMOUNT THAT IT WAS
LAST YEAR SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
ARE WE SERVING MORE REVIEWS
WHICH IS GOOD WELL IT'S SAD
THAT THEY'RE HELPING YOU KNOW
HOMELESS BUT- I JUST WONDER WHY
INCREASE SO DRESS ON AND I CAN
ADDRESS THAT OKAY ON THE
HOMELESS OBVIOUSLY. THE- WE
HAVE INCREASED THE INVESTMENT
FOR HOMELESSNESS IN GENERAL.
BUT BECAUSE MANY OF OUR HOMES
PROGRAMS DON'T NECESSARILY
SERVE HOMELESS YOUTH IN BECAUSE
HOMELESS YOUTH HAVE. VERY
PARTICULAR NEEDS. ON AN OFTEN
SHOULD BE A SEGREGATED SAFE
FROM ADULTS TURNING ON THE H.
SO IT WAS FELT THAT WE NEEDED
TO SEPARATE SOME FUNDS. IN OUR
INVESTMENT OVERALL HOMELESSNESS
IS A GREAT DEAL LARGER
OBVIOUSLY THAN LAST YEAR'S AND
SO THIS IS I WOULD SAY PROBABLY
NOT PROPORTIONATELY LARGER BUT
LARGER FOR THAT REASON. THAT'S
PERFECT MA'AM I JUST LIKE IT
WAS A GOOD PROPOSAL BUT I JUST
DIDN'T. UNDERSTAND WHY THE
INCREASE CAN I JUST ACCEPT THAT
AS- THE SAME THING WITH THE
STATE- ITEM NUMBER- TWENTY FOUR
AT ITS TWO HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIMES GENERAL FUND FOR THE NEXT
THREE FISCAL YEARS. FOR THE CAL
THE A. P. PROGRAM FOR YES YES
SO THAT'S SEVEN TIMES HIGHER
THAN LAST YEAR AND THE REST OF
THAT IS THE SAME. CORRECT I'M
SURE THE SET PAD THAT YOUR MATE
THE STRUCTURE MAY WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT BUT I CAN SAY.
THAT- WE- OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
WANTED TO INCREASE THE
INVESTMENT IN THE CALIPHATE
THEIR MIND GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION LAST YEAR BECAUSE OF
THE PROJECTIONS THAT WE MAY NOT
HAVE. FUNDING TO DO SO WE WERE
UNABLE TO- HOWEVER I THINK ALL
OF US KNOW. TRAGICALLY GUN
VIOLENCE IS UP. AND SO TOO IT
IS OBVIOUSLY THE TIME THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO GREATLY INCREASE
OUR INVESTMENT IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT CAN HELP REDUCE
GUN VIOLENCE AND I'M SURE THAT
WENT INTO THE SUB COMMITTEES
DELIBERATIONS AND I READ MANY
STAKEHOLDER LETTERS. ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM- BUT I CAN
CERTAINLY ALLOW THE SCEPTRE
COMMON IF SHE WOULD LIKE TO
SENATOR DRUGS OR- THIS IS ON
ACCOUNT THAT I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD. OKAY
THANK YOU MA'AM AND THEN MY
LAST QUESTION AGAIN WE WERE
ABLE TO CONSOLIDATE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF VOTES
TOGETHER SO- IT'S A SEVEN FOUR
AND IT'S ON THE U. I TRUST
FUND- SO THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
ARE. THE RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY ONE FROM THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WHICH IS US
AT THE RECOMMENDATION WAS TO
REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT
ONE BILLION DOLLAR DIRECT
PAYMENT TO THE WIFE AND- AND
THE PROPOSED ALTERNATIVE TAX
BREAKS. IF WE ACCEPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DIRECT REDUCTION THAT
SAVES THE STATE ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IN
INSURANCE INTEREST PAYMENTS
WILL THESE TAX CREDITS APPLIED
TO THE REDUCTION OF THE U. I
TRUST FUND AS WELL OR NOT. WE
HAD A ROBUST DISCUSSION WERE
YOU WERE OUT ABOUT THAT HONEY
LET ME SEE IF- BELIAU CAN YOU-
YEAH. MR PATRICK DO YOU WANNA
GO AHEAD GO AHEAD GET YOUR
REGULAR WITH ELIO- AS I
MENTIONED WE WORK WE WORK
CLOSELY INVOLVED WITH THE
CRAFTING THAT PROPOSAL BUT OUR
UNDERSTANDING. IS THAT IT WOULD
NOT APPLY TO. JANE DOWN THE
BALANCE OF THE SEASON THE DEBT.
DOES IT GO TOWARDS INTEREST HI
I WILL BE ABLE TO ANSWER THAT
APOLOGIES I- IT AS I MENTIONED
WE HAD THAT ROBUST DISCUSSION
BUT I WAS DISTRACTED NOW
BECAUSE I WAS LOOKING OUT OR
BREAK DOWN AND MAKING SURE THAT
I HAD. WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
NEXT PROPERLY FORMULATED IN MY
HEAD BUT I WILLRETURN NOW TO
BUY BUT ABILITY TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION WHICH I CAN'T NUMBER
ONE. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
WAIVED INTEREST THERE'S NO
INTEREST UNTIL SEPTEMBER
WHETHER THEY ACT FURTHER WE
DON'T KNOW YET NUMBER TWO THE
WAY THAT THE- PAY DOWN WAS
STRUCTURED UNDER THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WHILE IT WAS PAYING
DOWN LARGE AMOUNTS OF THE DECK.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE BENEFITED
THE- BUSINESSES UNTIL. GOOD
POINT THE FUTURE PERHAPS TWENTY
TWENTY NINE EVEN TWENTY THIRD
ADDITIONALLY IT WAS. FOR ALL
AND- OUR STRUCTURE NOW WITH A
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
CREDIT ON GOING. WHAT IS
TARGETED TOWARDS OUR SMALLER
BUSINESSES WHO OBVIOUSLY ARE
THE ONES WHO SUFFERED THE MOST
DURING THIS PANDEMIC THEY HAD
THE MOST ECONOMIC IMPACT. AND
DUST THE- THE ABILITY TO PAY
THAT DEBT IS WHAT IS- HAS A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THEM MORE
THAN MOST OF OUR LARGE
BUSINESSES NOW NOT ALL OF OUR
LARGE BUSINESSES THRIVE. DURING
THE PANDEMIC BUT MANY DID THUS
YOU SEE THE- EVERY AND ECONOMIC
INDICATOR SHOWS THAT THE ROPE
THE STOCK MARKET OUR OWN
REVENUES VARIOUS OTHER THINGS
SO THE FEELING WAS IN OUR
RESTRUCTURING. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSIBILITY AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WAS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ASSISTING
THOSE SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE
MOST ECONOMICALLY IMPACTED. AND
THEN MY FINAL QUESTION THEN WE
CAN VOTE MA'AM I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS AND TWO BILLION
DOLLARS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TAX CREDIT SINCE THAT
WAS REDONE REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT COMING
UP WITH THE SENATE'S. PROPOSAL
AND IT SAYS IT GOES FROM TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY THIRTY THREE CAN WE
DURING THIS BUDGET BIND FUTURE
LEGISLATURES. AND ABILITY TO
CRAFT THEIR OWN BUDGET WILL
THIS CONTINUE TO GO WHERE CAN
IT BE CIRCUMVENTED NEXT CYCLE
FOR OR THE CYCLE AFTER. SO ANY
STATUTE WE PASS CAN BE UNDONE
BY A FUTURE LEGISLATURE HOWEVER
IN THIS CASE IT WOULD REQUIRE A
TWO THIRDS VOTE BECAUSE IT IS A
TAX CREDIT. BUT WE CAN AFFECT
CAN NEER FULLY BIND ANY FUTURE
LEGISLATURE THOUGH BY TWO
THIRDS VOTES IT WOULD OBVIOUSLY
BE A LITTLE MORE DIFFICULT TO
UNDO. THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
FOR BEING PATIENT NO WORDS.
AND- ANY OTHER COMMENTS BEFORE
WE START THE VOTING PROCESS.
AND APOLOGIES FOR A. I WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE IS ABLE
TO. ALL RIGHT SO NOW THIS IS
GOING TO BE A LITTLE
COMPLICATED. BUT IT'LL BE WE'LL
BOTH BE STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
COMPLICATED SO ON. OUR SUB ONE
EDUCATION SUBCOMMITTEE I WOULD
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION AND
I'M GOING TO READ THE ITEMS ON
THE FOLLOWING ITEMS. ITEMS
THREE THROUGH SEVEN. VITAMINS
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE ONE
MOTION ITEMS THREE THROUGH
SEVEN NINE THROUGH NINETEEN.
ITEM TWENTY TWO ITEMS TWENTY
FIVE THROUGH TWENTY EIGHT ITEM
THIRTY ONE ITEM THIRTY TWO
ITEMS. FORTY THREE TO FORTY
SIX. I AM FORTY NINE ITEM FIFTY
TWO AND ITEMS FIFTY FIVE TO
SEVENTY TWO I WOULD SO MOVE
EXCELLENT SENATOR LAYERED
MOVES. AND. FIVE FIVE MISTERS
AS STEPPING CHART CONSULTANT WE
NEED A ROLL CALL ON THAT
CORRECT YEAH OKAY. MR SEVEN
CHARTER WE NEED TO ROLL CALL ON
THAT YES WE NEED A ROLL CALL
AND THEN THOSE ITEMS OKAY. WE
HAVE A MOTION. OKAY COM.
POTIONS ON THAT THE ITEMS CITED
BY THE CHAIR- SENATORS SKINNER.
SKINNER HI WE'LL SEND CARRIER
HI CAROL HI COURTESY ALL RIGHT
HI DOLLY HI NATALIE HI THE
ROSIN HI TORONTO HI A COMMON.
AILMENT HIGH GROWTH HI WROTE HI
COM LOGGER HI COME UNDER HI
LAYERED ALL RIGHT THERE HI
MCGUIRE. GRIER HI MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S HI MAN. MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI- CHEWABLE HI
HELLO HI PM HI PAM HI STERN.
STERN HI BY CAL SKI HI KELSEY
HI. SEVENTY NINE. EXCELLENT SO
THAT- MOTION IS OUT WITH MAKE
SURE I SAID THAT CORRECTLY WAS
SEVENTEEN ICE IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT OKAY. AND NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FINE. BY WOULDN'T LET NAME TWO
ITEMS SO THIS ISN'T ONE SINGLE
MOTION ON ITEMS EIGHT AND FORTY
EIGHT SENATOR LAYERS SO MORE
OKAY LET'S DO A ROLL CALL WHEN
ITEMS EIGHT AND FORTY. KIND OF
EIGHTEEN FORTY EIGHT SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
COPYRIGHT HI COPYRIGHT HI
COURTESY OF. THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS NO. NO THE ROSIN.
RATHER I THINK MEN. WOMEN ARE
HIGH GROWTH. GROW NO COM LOGGER
HI MARGARET HI LAYER BY LAYER
HI MCGUIRE HI CHOIR HI
MELINDA'S. LINDA IS NO MAN HI
HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE.
TURBO NO PEN HI CAN I TURN FIVE
TURN HIGH BY COUNTY HI MAKOWSKI
HI. SO THAT'S THIRTEEN ARISE
FOR NOS CORRECT RIGHT SO THAT
EIGHT AND FORTY EIGHT ARE OUT
WITH THIRTEEN VICE AND FOUR
THOSE. NOW I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
A SINGLE MOTION ON ITEMS ONE
AND TWO. OKAY SENATOR LAYERED
MOVES. ROLL CALL. MADAM CHAIR
YES WE WANT TO DO A SINGLE
MOTION ON ITEM ONE HOUR
SEPARATELY FROM TWO YES OKAY
THEY WERE BUNCHED ALL RIGHT SIR
WITH THIS MOTION OF SENATOR
LATCHES ON ONE ITEM ONE ROLL
CALL. YEAH SENATORS ARE ONE
SENATOR SKINNER. HI NIELSEN
SCARBOROUGH HI CABRIO HI
CORTESE ALL RIGHT WHO DOES HE
FIGHT DOLLY. DOWNLOADING IT TO
PROBABLY NOT VOTING TORONTO I'D
RATHER HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN HIGH
GROWTH. GROVE NONVOTING COMMON
EITHER HI THE CAR MARKER HI
LAYERED LAYER HI MY CHOIR HI
WIRE I'M LINDA THIS. MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S NO. MAN HI MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI HELLO. THE
TROUBLE NO PEN HI BEN HI STERN
HI DURING HI KATHY BY. MAKOWSKI
HI HIGHS THIRTEEN KNOWS TO.
FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS TO ONE ITEM
ONE NOW AND ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON ITEM TWO SO MOVE. RIGHT ROLL
CALL AN ITEM TO. FOR ITEM TO
SYNERGISE SKINNER BY SKINNER HI
NELSON CARGO CARRIER HI
COURTESY OF TWITTER THE HIGH
DOLLAR NOT ONLY ARE WE NOT
VOTING RAZA HI TORONTO I MEAN
HI ADNAN HI GROW. GROVE NOT
VOTING COM OTHER OUR MURDER I
LAYERED OUR- HI MIKE WEIR HI
WHERE YOU MELINDA'S NOW LINDA'S
NO MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN
HI CONTROLLABLE DURABLE NO FAN
HI TAM THAI STERN. DURING HI
WHAT COUNTS HI CAN I SPEAK HI
HIGHS THIRTEEN KNOWS TO. ALL
RIGHTS ARE ITEM TWO IS OUT
PRICE THIRTEEN KNOWS TOO. NOW
LET ME ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM TWENTY. SENATOR MAN MOVES
ITEM TWENTY ROLL CALL. I'M
TWENTY SENATORS SCANNER HI
SKINNER HI NO SIN COPYRIGHT HI
COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY CALL TO
THE HI DARLING NO NOT REALLY NO
TORONTO. TORONTO HI HEY MAN HI
HI GROVE HELLO NO FROM OTHER HI
CONGER HI LAYERED LAYERED A
HIGH WIRE ACT WIRE ISLANDERS.
WINDOWS NO MAN. MAN HI
INTERMENT ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I
TROUBLE. THE TROUBLE HI IN. HI
STERN STERN I WORK AT A SKI HI
KAFI HAI HAI'S FOURTEEN KNOWS
THREE BERRY ICE FORTINOS THREE
ON ITEM TWENTY NOW LET'S TAKE A
ROLL CALL AN ITEM- LET US HAVE
A MOTION ON ITEM TWENTY ONE.
SIMILAR BY A SENATOR MEN SO
ITEM TWENTY ONE GO AHEAD. I AM
TWENTY ONE SENATORS SCANNER HI.
SKINNER HI NELSON. COPYRIGHT I
COVER HI COURTESY OF THIRTY
FIVE DOLLARS YOU KNOW NOW WE
KNOW THE RAZA. RUSSELL HI
AIKMAN HI HIGH GROWTH. GROSS HI
FROM OTHER COMMA- I LAYERED HI
THERE TIME CHOIR HI BLAIR I
MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI JOE BLOW I FILLED OUT
HI PM HI THEN I STERN. STERN HI
MARK OWSKI HI I CAN'T SPEAK
HIGHLY. SIXTEEN NICE ITEM
TWENTY ONE HAS SIXTEEN HOURS OF.
THIRTY NINE FIFTY NINE YES I AM
TWENTY ONE FIFTEEN EYES ONE NO.
OKAY FIFTEEN HOURS ONE KNOW
THAT- MY NAME IS OUT. THEN NOW
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM TWENTY THREE. SO MOVED BY
SENATOR MEN. GO AHEAD ROLL CALL.
FEB ONE ITEM TWENTY THREE
SENATORS SENATORS SKINNER BY
SKINNER HI. NIELSEN COVER YOUR
OWN CAREER HI CORTESE HI WHICH
IS THE HI DOLLY NO DOLLY NO
TORONTO. HELLO I MEAN HI ADNAN
HI GROWTH CITY GROVE NOT
LOADING CAMARGO KAMARG LAYER
LAYER HI MIKE WEIR. WEIR HI
MELINDA IS. MAN HI MAN I.
NEWMAN NEWMAN HIGH- CHILL.
TROUBLE HI IN. DAN HI STERN
FIVE EASTERN IOWA CASKEY HI
CASKEY HI. THAT'S FOURTEEN ALL
RISE ONE NO. CORRECT ALRIGHT
SO- ITEM TWENTY THREE IS OUT
FOURTEEN NIGHTS WHEN NO WILL%
NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON ITEM
TWENTY FOUR. SERVER BY SENATOR
MAN GO AHEAD ROLL CALL. THE ONE
I AM TWENTY FOUR SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI. GILSON
CARRERO TRY CAREER HI COURTESY
OF THE CON DOLLY NO DALI NO
RAZA HI BROTHER HI ADNAN. IN
HIGH GROWTH. CAMARGO CAMARGO
FIVE LAYERED OUR MARITIME
ACQUIRE HI I'M MELINDA'S. MAN
MAN HEINEMANN ALL RIGHT WHEN I
GO TO ABOUT. THE TROUBLE FIVE
PM HI CAN I STERN HI DURING HI
MY COUNTY HI THE CASKET HI.
FOURTEEN HOURS ONE NO. FORTY
ONE NO RIGHT I AM TWENTY FOUR
HE'S OUT WITH FOURTEEN EYES AND
ONE NO. NOW I WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION THIS IS A COMPLICATED
ONE ITEM TWENTY NINE INSTEAD OF
ONE. WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS
EPARATED AND HAVE A VOTE ON
THE UC SAN DIEGO MEDICAL CENTER
AND UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. SOMEONE GIVE ME A
MOTION ON THAT SENATOR LARRY
THANK YOU FOR MOVING IT THIS IS
UC SAN DIEGO MEDICAL CENTER IN
UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE. A ROLL CALL PLEASE. I
AM TWENTY NINE. UC SAN DIEGO
MEDICAL CENTER FROM UC
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
SENATORS SKINNER BY SCANNER HI
NIELSEN. IBERO HI CORREO HI
CORTESE CORTESE HI DOLLY NO
DOLLY NO THE RAZA. BRAVO HI
ADNAN A WOMAN I WROTE I WROTE
HI FROM OTHER FROM OTHER SIDE
LAYER BY LAYER I'M A FIRE HI
WIRE HI MELINDA HI LINDA HI
MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN
ARTICLE TROUBLE. GLOBAL HI PM
ALL RIGHT. IN HI STERN RIGHT.
STERN OF STERN HI THERE
MICHALSKI HI KATHY HI DOLLY I
DIDN'T NOTIFY I'M SORRY DOLLY
NO DOUBT HI. SO SEVENTEEN HI
ALL RIGHT ON THAT SPLIT OF ITEM
TWENTY NINE WE HAVE SEVENTEEN
EYES AND IT IS OUT. AND NOW I
WILL ENTERTAIN THE SECOND PART
OF THAT- ITEM WHICH IS THE UC
RIVERSIDE CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL RESEARCH THE
TECHNOLOGY FACILITY PLANNING
SITE ACQUISITION ENVIRONMENTAL
SURVEYS. LET'S HAVE A ROLL
CALL. YES SIR SORRY A MOTION
WHICH IS SENATOR LURCH. PAULA
JEEZ. SEVEN HI AM TWENTY NINE
IF YOU SEE OUR CENTER FOR WORK
ENVIRONMENTAL RESEARCH. SENATOR
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI HILTON
COPYRIGHT. HI COURTESY OF THE
DISEASE HI DOLLY. TORONTO HELLO
HI ADNAN HI ADNAN I GROW. COM
LOGGER FOR MURDER HI LAYER ARE
CLEARED HI WIRE HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI. HI NEWMAN
RIGHT CAN I- TOLD BOTH. TO
ABOUT NINE PM. CAN I STERN HI
DURING MY WORKOUTS SKI HI THE
CASKET HI FOURTEEN ICE ZERO
NOBLE. OKAY FOR THE SECOND PART
OF ITEM TWENTY NINE THE BILLS
OUT IN ITS FOURTEEN ICE. ALL
RIGHT NOW. WE WILL HAVE A
MOTION ON ITEM. THIRTY SENATOR
EARLIER MOVES ROLL CALL ON ITEM
THIRTY. SOMEONE ITEM THIRTY
SENATORS SCANNER HI THERE HI
NIELSEN COPYRIGHT HI CARRERO HI
CORTESE HI COURTESY HI DARLING
NO DARLING NO RATHER. THE
RATHER HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH
GROWTH GROSS NO KAMAGRA KAMAGRA
COD LAYERED LAYERED I INQUIRE
HI BLAIR I'M LINDA'S. MAN I
MEAN I NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
I OWE TO ABOUT. PEN PEN HYSTER
STURT HIGHWAY CASKEY HI KATHY
HI. THIRTEEN ICE TO NOTES YES
SO I AM THIRTY SELF THIRTEEN
EYES TO NOSE. THE NOW AND. I
HAVE TO SEPARATE THIRTY THREE
AND THIRTY FOUR HOURS THAT ONE
OF DID JUST SEPARATE VOTES OKAY
SO I ENTERTAIN A MOTION CENTER
LAYERED ON ITEM THIRTY THREE.
BROKAW FEB WARM ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATORS SKINNER BY
SKINNER HI NELSON. CARRERO HI
CAROL HI CORTESE HI COURTESY HI
CHARLIE NO NOT REALLY NO DIRAJA.
HELLO I AM A MAN HI A WHEN I
GROW. HI GROVE HI COMMA- COME
ON OVER HI LAYERED HI THERE HI
MY CHOIR HI WIRE I MELINDA'S.
MAN MAN I NEWMAN NEWMAN I-
TROUBLE. PAN PAN I STERN HI
STERN I WORK OWSKI HI CASKEY HI.
FOURTEEN EYES WINDOW RIGHT ITEM
THIRTY THREE IS OUT FORTINOS
ONE NO THAT'S ITEM THIRTY THREE
INSTEAD OF ONE NOW ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON ITEM THIRTY FOUR
SENATOR LAYERED SO MOVES ROLL
CALL PLEASE SINNERS SKINNER HI
THERE HI NELSON. CABRERA HI
HOWEVER I WHICH AS A HOTEL HI
DARLING. NO NOT REALLY NO
TORONTO. THE RUSSELL TORONTO.
HI EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH
GROVE I CAMARGO COME LATER I'D
LAYERED HI THERE I'M A BUYER
RIGHT WHERE I. MELINDA'S. MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN HI I. O. JOGO JOE
ABOUT FIVE PM. PM EASTERN HI
THERE HI WHERE KATHY HI KATHY
HI. FIFTEEN EYES ONE OF FIFTEEN
HOURS ONE KNOW ON ITEM THIRTY
FOUR AND NOW FOR ITEMS THIRTY
FIVE WE'RE GOING TO SPLIT IT
WILL TAKE EIGHT FIRST EMOTION
ON THE SAN FRANCISCO DYSLEXIA
CENTER SO MOVED BY SENATOR.
RELATED MOTION ON THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO DISTLER LEXUS IN A
ROLL CALL. SUB ONE ITEMTHIRTY
FIVE UC SANTA CRUZ DYSLEXIA
CENTER SENATOR SKINNER BY
SKINNER HI HOUSTON COPYRIGHT HI
HI CORTESE I WOULD SAY THE HI
DARLING BY. THE EARLY HI DRAWS
A- RATHER HI ADNAN A HIGH
GROWTH. GROVE HI COM AUGER IN
ORDER ALL RIGHT PLAYER PLAYER
HI WIRE. WHERE I. MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S ALL RIGHT MAN MAN HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HIGH
UNTIL ABOUT. AND ARI STERN.
STERN ALL RIGHT WHAT COUNTY HI
CASKEY HI. SEVENTEEN ICE ZERO
EYES THE- THE ITEM FOR YOU SHE
SEARCHES GO DYSLEXIA CENTERS
OUT AND NOW WE WILL- TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE ONLINE- SCIENCE AND
EDUCATION THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED THAT'S MOVED ROLL CALL
PLEASE. FOR MORE THAN THIRTY
FIVE INSTITUTIONAL LAW NURSE
SCIENCE EDUCATION SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HIGH HEELS
IN CAIRO HI. HI WHAT DOES HE
SAY TO THE HI DOLLY. THE RISE
OF. RODGERS BROTHERS HI ADNAN.
SEGMENT GIVEN THE GROWTH. AND.
THIRTY EIGHT MIN SEGMENT HI BRO.
COME OVER SOMEWHERE HI LAYERED.
LEHRER HI MIKE WEIR. CHOIR HI
MELINDA IS. YEAH I'M IN
MELINDA'S NO. I THE MAN. MAN
FEBRUARY SEVENTH TWO NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE. CAN
PANASONIC STERN STURT HIGHWAY
CASKEY MAKOWSKI HI. THE NORFOLK
SENATOR MAN WANTS TO ADD ON OR
NOT OTHERWISE I THINK IT'S A
TWELVE. OKAY CENTERMAN DO YOU
WANT TO ADD ON TO THE
CALIFORNIA STREET ON LAUNDER OR
SCIENCE AND EDUCATION. SERMON
MAN I. I THINK IT'S THIRTEEN
ONE THIRTY ONE SO THAT MOTION
PASSES THIRTEEN ONE. AND THAT
CONCLUDES THAT ITEM THE CLOSING
ROLE OKAY WE ARE NOW GOING TO.
BY SO- CONSULTANT I NEED TO
SPEAK. TO EACH ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALLY. OKAY SO BY IN
THIRTY SIX IF I COULD GET A
MOTION ON ITEM THIRTY SIX YES
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED ITEM
THIRTY SIX ROLL CALL POLICE AT
ONE I'M THIRTY SIX SENATOR
SKINNER SKINNER HI. NIELSEN CUP
CARRERA CABRIO HI CORTESE.
CORTESE GOOD HE SAID I
ACCORDING THINK I DALI NO EARLY
NO TORONTO. TORONTO HI ADNAN. A
MAN I GROW. NO GROWTH NO
COMMAGER COMMENTATOR HI GLARED.
LAYERED I AM CHOIR. ENQUIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MELINDA'S NAM MAN.
MAN HI NEWMAN. NO MAN HI JOE
BLOW JOE BLOW NO PAM HI PAM I
STERN. EASTERN HI MY CASKEY.
WHY CASKEY MICHALSKI HI.
THIRTEEN ICE FOR NOTES HI WE
HAVE THIRTEEN EYES FOR NOSE ON
ITEMS SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ITEM
THIRTY SIX LET'S GO TO
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ITEM. THIRTY
SEVEN SO MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED ROLL CALL. SENATORS
SCANNER HI IN HER HIGH. HEELS
IN CARRBORO COPYRIGHT HI OR
DOES HE OR DOES HE HI DOLLY NO
NO TORONTO. I MEAN. EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. CAMARGO
COME HUNGRY HIGH LAYER MAYOR
HIGH MCGUIRE. HI MELINDA. MAN
N. I. NEWMAN WOMEN ARE ELIGIBLE.
PAN CAN I STERN STERN ALL RIGHT
WHAT COUNTY. KATHY HI. THE BILL
IS THIRTEEN THIRTEEN EYES ONE
NO- ITEM THIRTY SEVEN IS OUT.
OKAY NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT SO MOVED BY
SENATOR LAYERED ROLL CALL.
SOMEONE I AM THIRTY EIGHT
SENATORS SKINNER SKINNER HI
NELSON CAREER. COVER ALL RIGHT
WHAT IS THE- KELLY HI DOLLY.
THE RISE OF THE RATHER HI ADNAN.
HI GROWTH. GROSS HI BRO I AMONG
HER. COMMA I LAYERED LAYER HI
BRIAR WHERE SITE MELINDA'S. MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN. HI UNTIL ABOUT.
PAN HI STERN HI KAREN HI WE'RE
CASKEY BECAUSE HE HI. FOURTEEN
HI ZERO NINE FOURTEEN HOURS
ZERO NOTICE ON ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT ITEM THIRTY NINE SO MOVED
BY SENATOR LAYERED ROLL CALL.
I'M SOMEONE I'M THIRTY NINE SO
SENATOR SKINNER BY SKINNER HI
HOUSTON. COPYRIGHT. CAIRO
CENTER CARNEIRO. ACCORDING TO
ROLL CALL. CORTESE. I WHATEVER
HI DARLING. RATHER. SENATOR
DRAWS SO BROTHER I EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. COMMA-
MARGARET HI LAYERED. I BLAIR.
WHERE I. MELINDA'S MAN MAN I
NEWMAN IN OUR OPINION ALL
RIGHTS TURN TURN ALL RIGHT
WORKOUTS SKI. KATHY HI. CARRIER
REWROTE. HI NICE THIRTEEN KNOWS
I'M ICE THIRTEEN NO ZERO I
BELIEVE SENATOR JOE BOOK WANTS
TO WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO
JUST THIS IS NUMBER THIRTY NINE
HI YOU'RE HERE WOULD YOU PUT
YOUR MIKE UP SO WE CAN HEAR YOU
I APOLOGIZE AND DID NOT HEAR MY
NAME. BUT IT'S AND I FOR THIRTY
NINE. THE TROUBLE HI GUYS
FOURTEEN NO ZERO. I AM THIRTY
NINE IS OUT WITH FOURTEEN EYES
NOSE ZERO ZERO KNOWS. HARI ITEM
FORTY MOVED BY SENATOR LAYERED
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL TO SERVE
ONE ITEM FORTY. SEVEN IRON FOR
A FORTY SENATORS SKINNER HI
SKINNER HI NELSON. CABRERA
TONIGHT MY CAREER HI CORTESE HI
COURTESY HI DARLING HI NATALIE
I'D RATHER GO. TORONTO TORONTO
BROTHER HI ADNAN. I GROW I. I
GROW I COMMA- CAMARGO LAYER
THERE HI BUYER R. I. MELINDA'S.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN I
OTOBO. PAM PAM HI STERN STERN I
RECKON SKI BECAUSE HE I. I
BELIEVE THAT'S FIFTEEN ICE ZERO
KNOWS FIFTEEN RIGHT HERE I AM
FORTY FIFTEEN EYES ZERO KNOWS
LET'S GO ON A FORTY ONE SENATOR
LAYERED MOVES ITEM FORTY ONE
ROLL CALL PLEASE. SIR ONE ITEM
FORTY ONE SENATORS SCANNER HI
SKATER HI NELSON CABRERA
CABRERA HI CORTESE. COURTESY HI
DARLING NO DARLING NO RATHER.
THE RATHER HI TAKING EGGMAN
HIGH GROWTH. CAMARGO CALENDAR
HI LAYERED WHERE I'M GLARE
CHOIR HI MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HI
NEWMAN NEWMAN HIGH PATROL BOAT.
SHOW WELL HI PM PANTAI STERN-
HI RICK OWSKI MAKOWSKI HI.
HIGHS FORTINOS ONE SIZE
FORTINOS ONE ON ITEM FORTY ONE
THAT'S OUT NOW WE DO FOR ITEM
FORTY TWO. SO MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED ROLL CALL ON SEPT ONE
ITEM FORTY TWO. SEVEN NINE
FORTY TWO SENATORS SCANNER HI
THERE HI NELSON CABRERA. QUICK
CARE HI QUIT AS HE QUARTERLY HI
DOLLY. TORONTO RATHER HI EGGMAN
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. GROVE NOT
VOTING COMMA- FROM MARGARET HI-
LAYERED LEHRER HI MCGUIRE WHERE
HI MELINDA'S MELINDA'S KNOW MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI JOE
BLOW. IN PM HI STERN. STERN
FIGHT WHAT COUNTY BY COUNTY
HIGH PRICED THIRTEEN KNOWS ONE
FIVE THIRTEEN KNOWS ONE ON ITEM
FORTY TWO THAT IS OUT NOW I'D
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
LAYERED MOVES ROLL CALL ON ITEM
FORTY SEVEN SEVEN ONE FOUR ONE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN SENATORS
SCANNER HI. THERE HI NELSON
COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY
COURTESY HI DOLLY NO KNOWLEDGE
NO DRAWS A RATHER HIGH EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH. GROW HI
COMMA- THE MURDER HI THERE.
PLAYER HIGH CHOIR. CHOIR HI
MELINDA'S WINDOWS NO MAN. MEN
HEIGHT NEWMAN NEWMAN I- TROUBLE.
PEN PEN FIVE STERN STERN
ALRIGHT WHAT COUNTY. BECAUSE HE
HI. PRICE FOURTEEN DOLLARS TO
ON ITEM FORTY SEVEN SIZE
FOURTEEN THOSE TWO ITEMS OUT
NOW WE WONDER CHAIN A MOTION ON
ITEM FIFTY SO MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED ROLL CALL ON ITEM
FIFTY. SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY
SENATORS SCANNER HI THERE HI
NIELSEN. THE COVER GIRL. I
COURTESY WHATEVER HI DARLING.
TORONTO RATHER I EGGMAN EGGMAN
HIGH GROWTH. CONGER CONGER I
LAYERED LAYERED HYBRID WIRE R.
I. MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN.
MMHM HI THE TROUBLE. PENN I
STERN MR ALL RIGHT WHAT COUNTY
CASKET I. PRICE THIRTEEN NO
ZERO ITEM FIFTY IS OUT THIRTEEN
ZERO ZERO NOW WE WILL GO TO
ITEM FIFTY ONE MOTION BY
SENATOR LAYERED ROLL CALL
PLEASE. SOMEONE ITEM FIFTY ONE
SENATORS SKINNER BY HI NIELSEN.
COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY AFTER THE
I. DALI. DOURADO. TORONTO HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH.
COMMA THE MURDER I'D LAYERED.
LAYERED I'M ACQUIRE. CHOIR HI
MELINDA. MAN MAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN. THE MAN I AM TROUBLED.
TROUBLE I PEN. PEN I STERN SURE
I WORK OUT HE KELSEY I ICE
FOURTEEN NO ZERO. I AM FIFTY
ONE ALL EYES FOURTEEN- NO ZERO
THAT IS OUT. NO MOTION ON ITEM
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED SO MOVED LET'S HAVE
ROLL CALL ON ITEM FIFTY THREE.
OF ONE ITEM FIFTY THREE
SENATORS SCANNER BY SKINNER HI
NIELSEN COPYRIGHT. WHERE I LIVE
COURTESY THE I. DALI. THE RAZA
RATHER ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
EGGMAN WE'RE DOING BOTH MR
MCGUIRE STOPPED TALKING TO
MICHIGAN ADMIN ADMIN I GROW.
KAMAGRA KAMAGRA HIGH LAYER
THERE I'M A CHOIR I'M LINDA
THIS. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN HI JOE
BLOW GLOBAL IPM. HI STERN
EASTERN IOWA CASKEY HOW HEALTHY
I. FIVE FOURTEEN HOURS.
FOURTEEN NO NOS NO NOS SO FIFTY
CORRECT HI ABOUT THE ROTORS
EIGHT FIFTY THREE IS OUT. HELLO
WITH FOURTEEN HIGHS AND OWNERS.
FIFTY FOUR MOVED BY SENATOR
LAYERED SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR ROLL CALL PLEASE FOR
BORN IN FIFTY FOUR SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER ALRIGHT
NIELSEN COPYRIGHT. COVER ALL
RIGHT COURTESY. DONALD J. C.
CORTESE. HI DOLLY TORONTO. I AM
EGGMAN ALRIGHT BRO. GROSS HI
COME OTHER. COME ON HI LAYERED
LAYER- INQUIRE R. I. MELINDA'S
MAN MAN I'D NEWMAN WOMEN ARE
ELIGIBLE. PEN PEN I STERN.
WHITE HOUSE MICHAEL C. I. STERN
AFTER A HIGH. FIVE FOURTEEN NO
ZERO ICE FORTINO ZEROS ITEM
FORTY FIFTY FOURS OUT BY NOW
ITEM SEVENTY THREE MOTION BY
SENATOR LAYERED SUBCOMMITTEE
ONE ITEM SEVENTY THREE ROLL
CALL. THE ONE I AM SEVENTY
THREE SENATORS SKINNER SKINNER
HI MY NOTION COPYRIGHT. CAIRO
HI CAROL HI CORTESE COURTESY HI
DARLING NO DARLING NO THE
RATHER. THE RISE OF BROTHER HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH.
GROVE NO. COM AUGER CAMARGO
HEIGHT LAYERED LAYER I REQUIRE.
HI MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
AND THEN I'LL GO ABOVE. TEN TEN
HI STERN TURN ALL RIGHT WORK
OWSKI R. KANSKE HI PRICE
THIRTEEN KNOWS TO ITEM SEVENTY
THREES OUT PRICE THIRTEEN NOES
CAN YOU. BIDEN SEVENTY FOUR
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ONE ITEM SEVENTY
FOUR ROLL CALL PLEASE. FEB ONE
ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SENATORS
SCANNER HI HI NELSON COPYRIGHT.
HI COURTESY. WHAT DOES THE I.
DALI NO VALLEY NO TORONTO.
PRESENT HI ADNAN EGGMAN HIGH
GROWTH. GROVE NO CALM WATER. I
LAYERED WHERE HI WIRE WHERE I.
MELINDA'S BELINDA'S NO MAN MAN
I NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE.
THE TROUBLE NO PAN. N. I. STERN.
STERN I Y. CASKEY BY CRAFT BY
KELSEY I THIRTEEN KNOWS FOR
ITEMS SEVENTY FOUR ICE THIRTEEN
KNOWS FOR THAT ITEM IS OUT NOW
WE GO TO ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SO
MOVED BY SENATOR LAYERED ROLL
CALL PLEASE SOMEONE I AM TWENTY
FIVE SENATORS SKINNER HI CAN I
NO SIN COPYRIGHT. COVER I.
CORTESE PROTECT THE I. DALI. NO
NO TORONTO. TO ROGER. RATHER HI
ADNAN A MAN HI GROVE. KAMAGRA
KAMAGRA I LAYERED. HI MCGUIRE
FIRE EYE MELINDA'S. MAN MAN I
NEWMAN WHEN I- TROUBLE. PAM BEN
I STERN. STERN DURING ALL RIGHT
WHAT KIND OF KEY ACCOUNTS I. HI
THIRTEEN KNOWS ONE. I AM
SEVENTY FIVE SIZE THIRTEEN
KNOWS ONE THAT CONCLUDES THE
VOTES ON EDUCATION. SEVEN ONE.
WE HAVE A GOOD NUMBER MORE TO
DO AND- WILL GO FASTER IF
PEOPLE WERE SOON AS THEY HEAR
THEIR NAME. GIVE US THEIR
RESPONSE. WE ARE NOW GOING TO
THE VOTES ON ITEMS. SKEWS ME
FINE BUDGET SO TO I'M GOING TO
ENTERTAIN A SINGLE MOTION. YES
YES YES. HOLD ON. TO GET MY
FOOD.
HERE. THE.
YEAH.
WE WILL
BE.
OKAY. OUR.
OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE STARTING OUR
VOTES AGAIN I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S. RIGHT
NOW THANK THE ONES THAT TENSION.
PRECIADO BECAUSE WE ARE GOING
TO DO A LITTLE DIFFERENT
PROCEDURE. CAN I PLEASE HAVE
YOUR ORDER. THANK YOU. NASH
RATHER THAN HAVING OR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT REPEAT EVERY NAME. I
AM GOING TO. READ A LIST OF
ITEMS FOR SUB COMMITTEE TO. AND
I'M GOING TO ASK FIRST. FOR
EXAMPLE. CAN WE RECORD ALL DAMS
WITHOUT OBJECTION CAN WE RECORD
ALL SORRY. AND UNLESS I GET AN
OBJECTION THAT'S WHAT WE'LL DO.
AND THEN. DEPENDING ON WHAT
INFORMATION I HAVE BEFORE ME I
WILL ASK EITHER. MAY FIGHT WE
RECORD. ALL REPUBLICANS BYE
WITHOUT OBJECTION YOU KNOW IF
THERE'S UNLESS THERE'S AN
OBJECTION AND THEN I WILL DO
THAT FOR DEPENDING ON WHAT THE
ITEM IS. AND THEN WHERE THERE
ARE. DIFFERING VOTES I WILL
ALLOW THERE TO BE A ROLL CALL.
OKAY SO YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FOLLOW ME. AND I WILL
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION IN
ORDER TO DO THAT BUT IT WILL GO
FASTER AND I THINK IT'LL WORK.
BUT I DO NEED SOME HELP SO NOW
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE. TO FOR THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ITEMS FOUR
THROUGH SIX ITEMS EIGHT THROUGH
NINE ITEM ELEVEN ITEM EIGHTEEN
ITEM NINETEEN AN ITEM TWENTY
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
WITHOUT A DOUBT IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION TO RECORD ALL
DEMOCRATS INSIDE NOW. I'M SORRY
MAN I'M SURE YOU'RE GONNA TO
SLOW IT DOWN RIGHT AND JUST I
WILL EASE I WILL HE REPEAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY. ALL
RIGHT THIS IS. THE ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA FOR SUBCOMMITTEE TO.
THAT'S THREE SOURCES
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
ENERGY SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I'M
GOING TO ASK FIRST DEMOCRATS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MAYOR RECORD
BY FOUR ITEMS. FOUR THREE SIX.
EIGHT NINE NINE BY ADAM LEVIN.
ITEM EIGHTEEN ITEM NINETEEN AN
ITEM TWENTY THREE SEEING NO
OBJECTION ALL TIMES ARE
RECORDED HI. NOW MAY I ALSO
WITHOUT OBJECTION RECORD ALL
REPUBLICAN VOTES AS I. SEEING
NO OBJECTION ALL REPUBLICAN
VOTES ON THOSE ITEMS R. I. AND
WE'RE CLOSING THEN THOSE ITEMS
WITH THE SEVENTEEN YEP ICE.
ZERO KNOWS. NOW I WILL READ
ANOTHER FEW ITEMS AND WHAT I
WOULD LIKE HIS.FOR ITEM
SIXTEEN. I AM TWENTY EIGHT BY
ADAM THIRTY AN ITEM THIRTY TWO.
MAY I WITHOUT OBJECTION HAVE
THE DEMOCRATS ALL DEMOCRATS
RECORDED DESIGN. SEEING NO
OBJECTION THEN ALL DEMOCRATS
ALL BY HAND MAY I IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION RECORD ALL OF OUR
REPUBLICAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
VOTES HAS NO. SEEING NO
OBJECTION THEN ON THOSE ITEMS
WHICH ARE SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY AND THIRTY TWO. THE
FINAL VOTE IS THIRTEEN OUR EYES.
YOU GUYS GIVE ME THE NUMBER ON
KNOWS. THANK YOU FOR KNOWS ALL
OF SUDDEN I COULDN'T DO MATH
GOODNESS- THIRTEEN OURS FOR
NOSE AND THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT.
NOW. I THINK THESE ITEMS I WILL
READ. I CAN ASK WITHOUT
OBJECTION IF WE MAY RECORD.
DEMOCRATS AS HIGH ON ITEMS ONE.
TWENTY TWO. TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN AND. THIRTY THREE. RIGHT
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE HAVE ALL
DEMS HI ON THOSE AND I WITHOUT
OBJECTION TO FIND ME RECORD ARE
REPUBLICANS AS NOT VOTING. SH
SH IS THAT CORRECT. ALL RIGHT
SO FOR ITEMS. ONE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN AND
THIRTY THREE THE VOTE IS
THIRTEEN. FIVE ZERO KNOWS AND
THOSE ITEMS ARE OUT. NOW I WILL
TAKE AN INDIVIDUAL ROLL CALL
BUT NOT FOR THE DAMS WHICH I'LL
EXPLAIN IN A SECOND. SO FOR
ITEMS TO WITHOUT OBJECTION MAY
I RECORD ALL SIS II ON ITEM
TWO. RIGHT AND MAY I HAVE A
ROLL CALL ON THE REPUBLICANS.
SENATOR SKINNER WE MAY NEED TO
SPLIT THE VOTE ON THIS ONE I%
DON'T KNOW IT'S ONLY TWO AND
THIS ITEM TO- DOLLY. R. KELLY I
GROW HI GROOM HI MELINDA'S.
LINDA IS NOT LOADING THE
TROUBLE HI. THE TROUBLE BY.
FOUR EIGHT ZERO ITEM TWO IS OUT
WITH SIXTEEN. ZERO NO VOTES.
NOW FOR ITEM THREE WITHOUT
OBJECTION I WOULD LIKE TO
RECORD ALL DEMOCRATS IS OFF BY
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ROLL CALL
ON THE REPUBLICANS. THE
PROTOCOL FOR ITEM THREE CENTER
NIELSEN DOLLY PARTON DOLLY I
GROW. GREW BY MELINDA'S.
WINDOWS NOT LOADING A TROUBLED.
WE HAVE FIFTEEN ICE SILVER ITEM
THREE WE HAVE FIFTEEN ICE. ZERO
NO VOTES. OKAY FOR ITEM. SEVEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION I WOULD LIKE
TO RECORD ALL DOWNS AS VOTING
BY ONE ITEM SEVEN IN MAY I HAVE
A ROLL CALL FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
NIELSEN DOLLY. HI DARLING AYN
GROWTH HI GROUP EINEM OLYMPUS
RIGHT. MELINDA'S NOT VOTING
BOATING PHOTOBOOK HI
PREVENTABLE BY. SIXTEEN- FIVE
SEVEN IS OUT SIXTEEN OZ ZERO NO
VOTES AND NOW FOR ITEM CAN I'D
LIKE TO HAVE A- STARTED
DIRECTION CALL DEMOCRATS.
RECORDED AS I BEEN ROLL CALL ON
THE REPUBLICANS. NIELSEN DOLLY.
DOLLY NOW GROW. NO GROUP NOW
MELINDA'S. LET US KNOW THROUGH
A BOOK. BUT THAT SAID. THIRTEEN
THREE TRY TO ATTEND SO THIRTEEN
HOURS THREE KNOWS. AND NOW FOR
ITEM TWELVE WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE RECORD THE DOWNS AS- VICE
THEY WILL ROLL CALL WHEN
REPUBLICANS. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY NO TELLING NO GROWTH.
YEAH GROVE NOW MELINDA'S NOT
VOTING LINDA'S NOT VOTING
ULTRABOOK HI THE JOB OF. RIGHTS
ARE ITEM TWELVE SO FORTINO EYES
TO NOSE. NOW ON ITEM THIRTEEN
DOT OBJECTION I'D LIKE TO
RECORD ALL DANCES I DID NOT
HAVE A ROLL CALL ON THE
REPUBLICANS. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY NO TELLING NOW GROW.
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S NOW OCTOBER.
I HAVE A THIRTY NINTH TWO
NIGHTS. BRIGHT EYED AND
THIRTEENTH OUT THIRTEEN KNOWS-
SKEWS ME THIRTEEN OHIO'S TWO
KNOWS. AND NOW WE'LL GO TO ITEM
FOURTEEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION
RECORD THE DAMS AS BY IN A ROLL
CALL PLEASE ON REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NELSON DOLLY NO.
TELLING NO GROWTH THIRTY.
MELINDA SO MELINDA IS NOW
OCTOBER OUR JOB NOW. THIRTY
NINE THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN START
WITH THIRTEEN HOURS THREE KNOWS.
NOW ITEM FIFTEEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION CAN WE HAVE THREE
DEMOCRATS RECORDED DECIDE AND
ROLL CALL ON REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NELSON DOLLY NO
TELLING NO GROWTH NO GROWTH NOW
MELINDA NO LINDA IS NOW- CHOKE.
BY ADAM FIFTEEN IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS. NOW
ONE ITEM SEVENTEEN. DOT
OBJECTION DEMOCRATS ARE EYEING
AND ROLL CALL ON REPUBLICANS.
SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY NO
TELLING NO GROWTH. MELINDA SO
MELINDA NOW PATROL BOAT HI THE
TROUBLE GUY. THIRD ITEM
SEVENTEEN START WITH FOURTEEN
EYES TO NOSE. ITEM TWENTY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION DEMOCRAT SIDE
BROKEN REPUBLICANS SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROWTH MELINDA'S
THE TROUBLE. BAYERN TWENTIES
OUT WITH THIRTEEN ICE N. ZERO
KNOWS. NOW ITEM TWENTY ONE
THOUGHT OBJECTION DEMOCRATS
WILL BE RECORDED AS I BROKE ON
THE REPUBLICANS SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY NO KELLY NOW GROW
NO GROWTHNOW MELINDA NO
MELINDA'S NOTRE BOGUE. VERY
TWENTY ONES OUT WITH THIRTEEN
ICE THREE NEWS. I AM TWENTY
FOUR WITHOUT OBJECTION
DEMOCRATS RECORDED DECIDE
REPUBLICAN RECALL SENATORS
NIELSEN CALLING I AM THIRTY
FOUR. TWENTY THIS IS TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROVE MELINDA'S
A TROUBLED. THE RIGHTITEM
TWENTY FOUR SO THIRTEEN FIVE
ZERO NEWS IT'S GOOD ITEM TWENTY
FIVE DEMOCRATS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL BE RECORDED AS I
WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL ON
REPUBLICANS. EDITOR'S NIELSEN
DOLLY. DALI I GROVE GROUP II
MELINDA'S. OTOBO. HI I'M TWENTY
FIVE SO FIFTEEN EYES ZERO KNOWS
FIFTEEN BILLS GO TO ITEM TWENTY
NINE THOUGHT OBJECTION
DEMOCRATS RECORDED DESIRABLE
CALLED REPUBLICANS SENATORS
NELSON DOLLY NO TELLING NO
GROWTH NO GROWTH NOW MELINDA'S
NO ONE DOES KNOW A JOKE BOOK. I
AM TWENTY NINE IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS. NO
ITEM THIRTY ONE WE WILL SPLIT.
WE WILL. FIRST ACT ON P. EIGHT
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
OPERATIONAL OBSERVERS ON ITEM
THIRTY ONE AND WE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL RECORD THE
DANCES I WILL HAVE A ROLL CALL
FOR THE REPUBLICANS AND THAT'S
ON THE EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION FOR OPERATIONAL
OBSERVERS CONTRACT. CENTERS
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROSS MELINDA'S
OCTOBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THIS
IS THE SPLIT FOR THIRTY ONE
WERE VOTING ON THE EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR OPERATIONAL
OBSERVERS. DALLY I KELLY I. YOU
WANNA DO THE ROLL CALL FOR THE
REPUBLICANS AGAIN SHARE CLICK-
SINNERS NIELSEN DOLLY HI KELLY
I GROW ALL RIGHT GROUP III
MELINDA'S. THE TROUBLE. WE CAN
TAKE YOUR ROAD TO WHERE YOU
STAND OFFER YOU WANT THIS IS
ITEM THIRTY ONE ON THE EIGHT
POINT SEVEN MILLION FOR
OPERATIONAL SERVICE CONTRACT.
CONTROLLABLE BY. RIGHT ITEM
THIRTY ONE THE EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR OPERATIONAL
OBSERVERS CONTRACT HAS SIXTEEN.
ALL EYES IN ZERO KNOWS FOR NOW
WE WILL GO TO THE PORTION OF
ITEM THIRTY ONE THAT IS THE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION FOR VARIOUS CLEAN
ENERGY INVESTMENTS. AND WITH
THE A RECORD THE- IS AND I AND
WHATEVER CALL ON OF. SENATOR
NIELSEN DOLLY NO TELLING NO
GROWTH. MELINDA'S NO LENDERS
NOW A TRUE ABOVE. SEVEN RICHARD
WAGNER. THIS IS THE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MILLION
FOR VARIOUS CLEAN ENERGY
INVESTMENTS. SHE WE GO TO I AM
SORRY. BUT YOU'LL NOTICE HI
OKAY SO THAT VOTE FOR THAT IT-
THIRTY ONE SPLIT IS FOURTEEN
ICE INTO KNOWS. THIRTY ODD THAT
ITEM THE EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE MILLION FOR VARIOUS CLEAN
ENERGY INVESTMENTS IS OUT. PART
NOW. WE WILL DO A SIMILAR. FOR
SEVEN THREE THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. AND I WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SENATOR
AGNES SO MOVED YEP. AND I WILL
READ THE ITEMS. THIS IS A MODE
ONE MOTION ON ALL THE ITEMS I'M
ABOUT TO READ OKAY. THEY ARE.
ITEMS ONE AND WO ITEM FIVE.
ITEMS EIGHT THREE THIRTEEN.
ITEM FIFTEEN. BY ADAM.
SEVENTEEN TO TWENTY TWO
FIREARMS. TWENTY FOUR TO TWENTY
SEVEN. IDMS TWENTY NINE. ITEM.
THIRTY ONE. FIGHTERS. THIRTY
FOUR TO THIRTY NINE. ITEM FORTY
THREE. THE ITEMS FORTY SEVEN
AND FORTY EIGHT ITEM FORTY NINE.
ITEM FIFTY AND FIFTY ONE THE
ITEM FIFTY TWO ITEM FIFTY THREE
ITEM FIFTY FIVE ITEMS. FIFTY
SEVEN THREE SIXTY THREE. I AM.
SIXTY SIX TO SIXTY EIGHT. ITEM
EIGHTY ONE ITEMS EIGHTY SEVEN
AND EIGHTY EIGHT AN ID HI TOM
NINETY. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
WILL RECORD ALL DEMOCRATS SAYS
BY. AND WITHOUT OBJECTION I AM
YES GO AHEAD GO AHEAD SENATOR
GROVE DID YOU CALL ITEM EIGHTY
EIGHT I DID OKAY SORRY I MISSED
IT EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
AND NINE. SO MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY'S GOOD WITH WHAT I
READ AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
HELLO WE WOULD RECORD ALL
REPUBLICANS AS I ON THAT MOTION
ALSO. RIGHT LOOKS GOOD. OKAY SO
ALL OF THOSE ITEMS I READ. ARE
NOW APPROVED ON A SEVENTEEN I
VOTE LET'S SEE ARKANSANS COMING
TOWARD ME JUST TAKE A QUICK.
HELLO NEXT SORRY SO THERE ARE A
FEW MORE ITEMS. EXCUSE ME IN
SUB THREE DAX I'M GOING TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION FOR AND FOR
WHICH I'M GOING TO STATE AFTER
I SEE THE ITEMS I'M GOING TO
STATE THAT I WOULD LIKE WITHOUT
OBJECTION IN ARE YOU FROM
EVERYBODY BUT LET ME SAY WHAT
THEY ARE. OKAY AND IT'S MS
AIKMAN WE'VE GOT AROUND UP SO
SHE'S MAKING THE MOTIONS O'MARA
THE ITEMS. NINETY THREE. NINETY
FIVE A- ONE OH ONE ONE OH
THREE. ONE SIXTEEN. ONE TWENTY
THREE ONE TWENTY FOUR. ONE
TWENTY SIX. ONE TWENTY SEVEN
ONE THIRTY. ONE THIRTY THREE
THROUGH ONE THIRTY FOUR. AND.
ONE THIRTY SIX TO ONE FORTY
TWO. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL RECORD. ALL DAMS AND REAPS
AS HIGH. GREAT SO THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE ITEMS I READ ARE NOW
OUT TWENTY SEVENTEEN ZERO VOTE.
OKAY NOW I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A
MOTION. SEND DIRECTEMENT SO
MOVE ON THE ITEMS I AM ABOUT TO
READ OKAY THESE ARE ITEMS. SIX
THREE SEVEN SIX EIGHT ONE SEVEN
FOURTEEN. FORTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE AND SEVENTY SIX. ONE OH
EIGHT ONE OH NINE ONE FOURTEEN
ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE ONE
TWENTY NINE AND ONE THIRTY FIVE.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION LIKE TO
RECORD THE DEMOCRATS AS I. AND
RECORD THE REPUBLICANS HAS NO.
SEEING NO OBJECTION THEN THOSE
ITEMS WILL PASS OUT WITH A.
THIRTEEN FOUR VOTE. KEEP US
THINKING OF SENATOR NELSON BUT
HE'S NOT ABLE TO BE WITH US
TONIGHT SO THOSE ITEMS ARE
PASSED WITH THIRTEEN NICE
FOREIGNERS. OKAY NOW. SINNER
AGREEMENT IF YOU DON'T MIND YOU
CAN DO ANOTHER MOTION ARE YOU
WILLING. SO RIGHT NOW I'M GOING
TO READ. A NUMBER OF OTHER
ITEMS AND THEN I WILL INDICATE
WHAT WE WOULD TAKE AS THE VOTE
RECORD AS THE VOTE. RIGHT THESE
ITEMS ARE. THREE FOUR SIXTEEN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY THIRTY TO FORTY FORTY
ONE. FORTY FOUR THROUGH FORTY
SIX. FIFTY FOUR FIFTY SIX SIXTY
NINE THROUGH SEVENTY FOUR.
SEVENTY EIGHT THROUGH EIGHTY.
EIGHTY TWO TO EIGHTY SIX
THROUGH EIGHTY SIX. EIGHTY
NINE. NINETY ONE NINETY TWO.
NINETY FOUR. NINETY FIVE B.
NINETY SIX THROUGH. NINETY
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED ONE OH TWO.
ONE OH FIVE TWO ONE OH SEVEN.
ONE TEN TO ONE ELEVEN. HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN FEDERAL OVERREACH
IN THERE. ONE SEVENTEEN THREE
ONE NINETEEN. ONE TWENTY TWO
AND ONE THIRTY TWO. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION I WOULD LIKE TO
RECORD. PAUL DEMOCRATS IS BY
AND ALL REPUBLICANS AS NOT
VOTING. AND WITH THAT THOSE
ITEMS SEEINGNO OBJECTION THOSE
ITEMS ARE OUT. TWENTY THIRTEEN
ZERO VOTE. NOW WHAT DO SEVERAL
CALLS. POLICE FOR SERVICE. PART
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ITEM THIRTY
THREE. BUT WE WILL- SPOOKED OUT
ITEMS. CITIES ARE ON THE ITEM
THIRTY THREE FOR SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTMENTS. AND ON THE. THE I
WILL READ THESE INVESTMENTS.
BILL MOVED THANK YOU SENATOR
AIKMAN THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
TO LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THE THIRTY FIVE
MILLION TO WORK FORCE
DEVELOPMENT THE FORTY MILLION
FOR COORDINATION PLANNING AND
I. T. AND THE THREE MILLION FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE STUDY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION I WOULD LIKE TO
RECORD STATUS HI FOR DEMOCRATS
AND AS I REPUBLICANS. SEEING NO
OBJECTION THEN ITEM THIRTY
THREE WITH THE- FOUR INVESTMENT
SO I MENTIONED IT SAID THE SUB
ITEMS ONE THREE FOUR AND FIVE
IS NOW OUT ON A SEVENTEEN. ZERO
VOTE. NOW ON ITEMS Q. SIX AND
SEVEN THOSE ARE SUBJECT TO
THIRTY THREE K. CENTER
RECOMMENDS MOST SO MOVED. SO
THESE ARE THE ON. WELL ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY I WANT TO JUST DO TWO
AND SIX OKAY THIS IS ITEM
THIRTY THREE SUBS TWO AND SIX
YES SENATOR MELINDA. IS THIS I
APOLOGIZE MADAM CHAIR AND I'M
ACTUALLY ON AN EYE ON PART
SEVEN OF THIS I THINK WE RECORD
YEAH SO I AM GOING TO READ BY I
DIDN'T DO PART SEVEN YET OKAY
I'M ABOUT TO DO PARTS TO SIX
AND SEVEN OKAY OKAY. BUT I'M
GONNA DO TO WIN SIX IN ONE
ACTION. THE NOMINEE TO SEVEN IN
A SEPARATE IS THAT OKAY. RIGHT
SO. I AM THIRTY THREE SUB TWO
ONE SIX THAT'S A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR HEALTH
EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
GRANTS AND SIXTY THREE POINT
ONE MILLION FOR CALIFORNIA
REDUCING DISPARITIES PROJECT
WITHOUT OBJECTION I'D LIKE TO
RECORD ALL DEMOCRATS ISN'T BY.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION I'D LIKE
TO RECORD ALL REPUBLICANS AS-
ABSTAIN NOT VOTING. SO WITH
THAT. THE THIRTY THREE SUB TWO
AND SIX WOULD PASS WITH THE
THIRTEEN ZERO VOTE. AND NOW FOR
THE SEVENTH PART OF ITEM THIRTY
THREE WHICH IS THIRTEEN MILLION
TO END EPIDEMICS. THEY MOVED BY
MUSIC MEANT. I WOULD LIKE
WITHOUT OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTE
IT OCCURRED THERE WERE SAME
ROLL CALL FOR DEMOCRATS WHICH
IS A LIE BUT NOW HAVE A ROLL
CALL FOR REPUBLICANS GO AHEAD
LOCAL SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY.
GROSS I GROUP II MELINDA'S FIVE
LENDERS I SHOW BOTH FIVE THE
TROUBLE GUY. DOLLY I HAVE. AIDS
SO IF I HEARD THAT RIGHT THEN
WE HAVE A SEVENTEEN ZERO VOTE
ON THAT THIRTY THREE POINT
SEVEN. CORRECT OKAY EXCELLENT
NOW ITEM SIXTY FOUR THIS IS
ITEM SIXTY FOUR FOR
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE. SO MOVED BY
MUSIC MEANT. WITHOUT OBJECTION
ALL DAMS RECORDED AS I BROKE
OFF REPUBLICANS SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROVE MELINDA'S
A TURBO. OCTOBER GUY SO I AM
SIXTY FOURS OUT FOURTEEN YESS
ZERO KNOWS. OKAY SEPT ME THREE
ITEM SIXTY FIVE MOVED BY MUSIC
MEANT. WITH A ROLL CALLS AS
SUBSTITUTES IN ROLL CALL FOR
DEMS AND THEN- REAPS WROTE A
SKEWS ME ARE BROKEN SO LET'S
HAVE A ROLL CALL. SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY. THANK YOU GROWTH
GROVE ICE MELINDA'S. SO
TROUBLED. THIS WAS ITEM SIXTY
FIVE OF SUBCOMMITTEE. THREE
WE'VE CONCLUDED OKAY SO THAT
THE VOTE ON THAT IS FOURTEEN
OUR ICE ZERO KNOWS. CORRECT
CENTERING IN MOTION ON ITEM
SEVENTY SEVEN THE ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN OUT OF JUNCTION ALL JAMS
REPORTED AS AN ALLY PLEASE
LET'S ROLL CALL FOR A
REPUBLICAN SENATORS NIELSEN
DOLLY. GROVE RIGHT GROW BY
MELINDA'S. PICTURE BOOK HI THE
TROUBLE THAT DOLLY I THOROUGHLY
I RATE ITEM SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN EXCUSE ME ITEM SEVENTY
SEVEN IS OUT WITH SIXTEEN I
BOATS NO NO VOTES. FOUR EIGHT-
WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM NINETY
NINE. A MOTION BY MUSIC MAN BY
THE SAME ROLL CALL FOR THE
DEMOCRATS WE'RE SEEING NO
OBJECTION THEN PLEASE SUBMIT
FIVE ROLL CALL FOR THE
REPUBLICANS SENATORS NIELSEN
DOLLY NO DOLLY NO GROWTH NO
GROWTH NOW MELINDA'S NO
MELINDA'S NOW A TRUE BOOK.
RIGHT ITEM NINETY NINE IS ABOUT
THIRTEEN AND THREE NOS THIRTEEN
EYES THREE NOTES. RIGHT WILL
NOW BECAUSE SEEING A MOTION ON
ITEM ONE OH FOUR BY SENATOR
RICHMOND. AND THE- SAME ROLL
CALL FOR DEMOCRATS SEEING NO
OBJECTION LET US DO A
REPUBLICAN ROLL CALL SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROSS MELINDA'S
OCTOBER HI THE JOBOKAY FORTY
ONE OH FOUR IS OUT WITH
FOURTEEN HOURS ZERO KNOWS
FIGHTING ONE TWELFTH SENATOR
EDMUND MOVES. AND WE WITHOUT
OBJECTIONS. REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY NO KELLY
NO GROWTH NO GROWTH NOW
MELINDA'S NO LINDA IS NOW A
TROUBLED. WE'RE READY. VITAMIN.
TWELVE RIGHT NOT VOTING. SO
ITEM ONE TWELVE IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS. I AM
ONE THIRTEEN SO MOVED BY
SENATOR. WE WILL USE THE SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS
SEEING THE OBJECTION NOW WE'LL
HAVE A ROLL CALL ON OUR
PUBLICANS SENATORS NIELSEN
DOLLY. GROVE MELINDA'S THE
TROUBLE. WELL THIS IS ITEM. ONE
THIRTEEN. VERY GOOD. OKAY ITEM
ONE THIRTEEN IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ALL EYES. ZERO KNOWS.
NOW WE GO TO ITEM ONE TWENTY
FIVE THE MOTION BY MISTAKE
MEANT. WE WILL USE THE SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS THE
SINGLE OBJECTION PLEASE GIVE
ROLL CALL FOR THE REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY NO DOLLY
NOW GROW. NO GROUP NO MELINDA
SO MELINDA SNOW OCHO BUG. VERY
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE IS OUT
WITH THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS.
FOR NOW S- MOTION FOR MAGNET
ON ONE TWENTY EIGHT. WE WILL
USE THE SAME ROLL CALL FOR THE
DEMOCRATS SEEING NO OBJECTION
AND NOW WE ILL DO A ROLL CALL
FOR THE REPUBLICANS ITEMS ONE
TWENTY. EDITOR'S NIELSEN DOLLY.
GROWTH MELINDA'S NO MELINDA'S
NOW FOR TROUBLE I THE TROUBLE
GUYS GREAT ITEM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT IST OUT WITH FOURTEEN ICE
ONE NOTE. LET'S GO TO THE LAST
ITEM FOR OUR- SUBCOMMITTEE
THREE FIVE AND ONE THIRTY ONE
MOTION BY SENATOR EKMAN. SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS
SEEING NO OBJECTION AND NOW WE
WILL DO A ROLL CALL WITH THE
REPUBLICANS THIS IS ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY. GROSS MELINDA'S A
TROUBLED HI THE JOB OF AN GREAT
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE IST OUT
WITH FOURTEEN ICE ZERO KNOWS.
OKAY NOW WE ARE GOING TO R. AND
SUB FOR. I WILL FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCEDURE. IT SENILE SENATOR
KIRBY OR YOU WANT TO MAKE MY
FIRST MOTION. OKAY THE MOVE ON
WE WILL. WITH THE MOTION BY
SENATOR CAFIERO I WILL READ THE
ITEMS. ONE THREE TEN THIRTEEN
THROUGH FIFTEEN. FRIDAY MAY
EIGHTEENTH I AM TWENTY ITEM
TWENTY ONE ITEM TWENTY FOUR
ITEM TWENTY FIVE. IDMS TWENTY
NINE THROUGH THIRTY FIVE ITEM
THIRTY EIGHT ITEM FORTY.
BYNUM'S FORTY TWO THROUGH.
FORTY SEVEN. BYNUM'S FIFTY ONE
THROUGH FIFTY TWO. BY ADAM
FIFTY FOR AN ITEM FIFTY EIGHT.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WOULD
RECORD IN ALL RIGHT FOR
DEMOCRATS AND WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WOULD RECORD A KNIFE
REPUBLICANS SEEING ANY
OBJECTION NO OBJECTIONS SO ON
THOSE ITEMS THAT ARE RED THE
VOTE THESE ARE OUT ON A
SEVENTEEN ZERO VOTE. AND NOW
SENATOR CAFIERO WILL YOU GIVE
ME A MOTION FOR THE NEXT SET OF
ITEMS. GREAT REMOTE THESE ITEMS
ARE ITEM NINETEEN ITEM TWENTY
THREE. I AM THIRTY SIX ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN. ITEM FORTY ONE
ITEM FIFTY THREE ITEM FIFTY
SEVEN. WITHOUT OBJECTION ROLL
CALL FOR DEMS WILL BE I'D BEEN
FOR REPUBLICANS IT WILL BE NO.
SENATOR GROUP. I'M SORRY MADAM
CHAIR DID YOU CLICK INCLUDE
ITEM ELEVEN IN THAT. NO I DID
NOT. I WAS TOLD TO GIVE A ROLL
CALL FOR ITEM ELEVEN OKAY THANK
YOU I APOLOGIZE YOU'RE NO
PROBLEM. GOOD TO MAKE SURE WE
DID IT RIGHT. OKAY SO FOR ITEMS.
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE THIRTY
SIXTY THIRTY SEVEN FORTY ONE
FIFTY THREE ANDFIFTY SEVEN.
THE VOTE IS THIRTEEN YES IS FOR
KNOWS. IN THAT ITEMS OUT. NOW
SYNDERGAARD BUREAU YOU'LL AND
YOU'LL DO ME THE FAVOR OF
ANOTHER MOTION ON THESE ITEMS.
THE ITEM. SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
THIRTY NINE. FORTY EIGHT FIFTY
AND FIFTY SIX AND WE'LL USE THE
SAME ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMS.
AND WITH IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION FOR OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES THIS WILL BE NOT
VOTING. ALL RIGHT SO THOSE
ITEMS THEN ARE OUT. WITH EIGHT
THIRTEEN ZERO VOTE. THE NOW
WILL DO SEVERAL CALLS. THE
MOTION ON ITEM ELEVEN BY
SENATOR CAFIERO. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE DEMOCRATIC VOTE
WILL BE I. AND WE'LL NOW ASK TO
DO A ROLL CALL FOR REPUBLICANS
THIS IS ITEM ELEVEN FOR SUB
COMMITTEE FOR SENATORS NIELSEN
DOLLY NO CALLING NOW FOR OKAY
NO GROUP NOW MELINDA'S NO
WINDOWS NO A TROUBLED. ALL
RIGHT THAT IS OUT. WITH A
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS BY THE
MILITANTS. RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION ON ITEM TWELVE SEEING-
SYNDERGAARD REMOVED IT- WITHOUT
OBJECTION VOTES ARE I WILL CALL
ON REPUBLICANS SENATORS NIELSEN
DOLLY. GROVE TWELVE THIS IS
ITEM TWELVE YES. THE NEW GROW
HI GROVE BANK MELINDA'S NOTHING
A TO A BUG HI THE TROUBLE GUY.
ZERO BY GOT THAT RIGHT THAT
RULE- THAT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
IS OUT WITH FIFTEEN ICE. AND
ONE NO NO SORRY FIFTEEN EYES
AND- ZERO KNOWS. HI I'M TWENTY
TWO SO MOVED BY SENATOR CAFIERO
DEMOCRAT ROLL CALL WHY WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THEN A ROLL CALL
FURTHER REPUBLICANS SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY FOR. GROSS ITEM.
TWENTY TWO. FOR THE RECORD I'M
NOT VOTING. MELINDA'S OCHO BUG
HI A CHEWABLE GUY BURIED ITEM
TWENTY TWO IS OUT WITH FOURTEEN
ICE ZERO KNOWS. RIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION ON TWENTY SIX. AND THE
SAME DEMOCRATIC RULE COSTING NO
OBJECTION BROKE ON THE
REPUBLICANS. WE CAN HEAR THAT.
YOUR MIKE WAS IN ON. SENATOR
NELSON DOLLY. GROSS MELINDA'S.
HI MELINDA ZAYN PHOTOBOOK.
RIGHT ITEM TWENTY SIX IS OUT
WITH THE FOURTEEN YES AND ZERO
NINE ZERO NOTES OKAY I AM
TWENTY SEVEN GOT THE MOTION.
AND THE DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL
THE SCENE NO DIRECTION WILL BE
THE SAME. AND WE WILL HAVE A
ROLL CALL ON REPUBLICANS.
SENATORS NELSON DOLLY. GROWTH
MELINDA'S THE TROUBLE. A
TERRIBLE GUY THIRD ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN IS OUT WITH FOURTEEN EYES
ZERO KNOWS. HELLO GO TO ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION AGAIN
FROM COVER EURO I'M NOT GOING
TO REPEAT AND IT DIDN'T IS.
SENATOR COPIERS JUST NODDED
SHE'S MADE A MOTION ON ALL THE
REST OF THE ITEMS WE'RE JUST
GOING TO DO THE FULL BREAK. SO
TWENTY EIGHT NO OBJECTION FOR
THE SAME ROLL CALL FOR THE
DEMOCRATS IN OUR LOCAL AND
REPUBLICAN. SENATORS NELSON
DOLLY. DOLLY NOW GROWTH NO
GROWTH NOW MELINDA. LINDA IS
NOW A TRUE BOTH. RIGHT ON
TWENTY EIGHT'S OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS. I AM
FORTY NINE THIRD OBJECTION THE
REAL COLD BE BIASED FOR THE
RICH DEMOCRATS SEEING NO
OBJECTION WILL THEN HAVE A ROLL
CALL FOR THE REPUBLICANS THIS
IS ON SEPT FOR ITEM FORTY NINE.
SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY. DOLLY
NO GROWTH NEW GROWTH NOW
MELINDA'S KNOW MELINDA SNOW
PATROL BOAT. RIGHT ITEM THIRTY
NINE IS OUT WITH THIRTEEN ICE
THREE KNOWS. NOW ITEM FIFTY
FIVE THIRD OBJECTION SAY ROLL
CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS ROLL
CALL PLEASE FOR THE REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY. THE
GROWTH. MELINDA A TURBO. A
TERRIBLE GUY- RIGHT ITEM FIFTY
FIVE IS OUT WITH FOURTEEN NO-
PRO GROWTH OKAY GROWTH NOW. ANY
OTHER- GIVE YOU. I'M SORRY NO
WORRIES WE CAN JUST LET IT ROLL
OFF FOR IFTY FIVE AGAIN HEY
BRO CALL AN ITEM FIFTY FIVE
SENATORS NIELSEN. DOLLY GROWTH
NO GROWTH NOW MELINDA'S A TRUE
BOTH. RIGHT ITEM FIFTY FIVE IS
OUT WITH THIRTEEN EYES ONE NO.
CORRECT WE'RE NOW ON OUR LAST
SUBCOMMITTEE. THIS. SENATOR ROZ
SHOW ROOM GONNA TAKE YOUR
MOTION AND I'M GONNA TAKE IT AS
FOR ALL OF THE ITEMS. AND WE'RE
BACK I'M GOING TO SPLIT THE
ROLL CALL OKAY. SO FIRST THIS
IS ON SENATOR GROCERS MOTION
FOR ME TO READ THE ITEMS THIS
IS FOR SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE. BY
ADAM. ONE THREE THREE. EIGHT
NINE CAN. ELEVEN TWELVE
THIRTEEN. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIRTY. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR AND FORTY
FIVE. WITHOUT OBJECTION ON
THOSE ITEMS WILL RECORD DAMS
WITHIN I'D- IN A IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE RECORD OR
REPUBLICANS ALSO A I. SEE NO
OBJECTION THAN THOSE ITEMS ARE
OUT ON A SEVENTEEN ZERO VOTE.
AND NOW WE WILL GO TO ITEMS.
THIS IS SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ITEM
NUMBER. FIVE SIXTEEN NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE. THIRTY ONE THIRTY
TWO THIRTY EIGHT FORTY ONE
FORTY TWO FORTY THREE. TEN
FORTY SIX. FORTY SEVEN. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL USE THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL. AND FOR
THE REPUBLICANS IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WILL RECORD YOU
ALWAYS KNOW. GREAT SEEING NO
OBJECTION THOSE ITEMS. WE'LL GO
OUT ON A THIRTEEN I FOR NO VOTE.
OKAY NOW. PHYLUM SEVEN ITEM
TWENTY FOUR ITEM TWENTY SIX
ITEM THIRTY SEVEN ITEM THIRTY
NINE AN ITEM FORTY FOUR WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'LL USE THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL OF I. AND
WE WILL IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION
RECORD OR REPUBLICANS AS NOT
VOTING. CORRECT SO THAT THOSE
ITEMS WILL NOW GO OUT THIRTEEN
EYES ZERO KNOWS. NOW WE'LL HAVE
A SET OF ITEMS THAT ARE WE'RE
GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL SO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE'LL USE THE DEMOCRATIC. ROLL
CALL WE HAVE BEEN USING WHICH
IS WHY SEEING NO OBJECTION.
WE'LL CALL THE ROLE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS THIS IS ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. SENATORS NIELSEN DOLLY NO
TELLING NO GROWTH. GROWTH NO
MELINDA'S NO MELINDA SNOW- TRUE
BOTH. EIGHT ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS
OUT ON A THIRTEEN ALL RIGHT
THREE NO. OKAY ITEM NUMBER.
SIX- WE'RE GOING TO. I COULD
SEE I THINK. HI TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- EACH ONE ITEM
NUMBER SIX I'M IN A SEPARATE
THE VOTE. WHEN ITEMS THIS IS
SIX HAS SOME SUB ITEMS OKAY
THIS IS ITEM. SIX FOUR SEVEN
FIVE IT HAS THE SUB ITEMS OF.
THREE FOUR SEVEN. AND EIGHT.
SEARCH I WANNA MAKE SURE I GOT
THAT CORRECT NO I DON'T OKAY.
LET'S DO A ROLL CALL LET'S DO
ITEM ONE THIS IS. THIS IS SO I
KNOW IT'S VERY CONFUSING THIS.
THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE'RE
ALMOST DONE. OKAY WE ARE ON
SEPT TWENTY FIVE AND IT IS
ISSUE SIX AND ISSUE SIX HAS A
NUMBER OF SUB ITEMS. SO I AM
GOING TO FIRST. WITHOUT
OBJECTION FOR I KNOW THE SUB
ITEMS OF ISSUE SIX THERE IS ONE
AND SEVEN THAT'S THE DEPENDENCY
COUNSELING THE COUNTY LAW
LIBRARIES. WITHOUT ANY
OBJECTION FROM THE DEMOCRATS
WERE GOING TO USE OUR SAME ROLL
CALL. IRAN'S UNLESS THERE IS AN
OBJECTION FROM OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES WILL ALSO RECORD THE
MASAI. NO OBJECTION OKAY SO
ISSUE SIX OF SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
ITEMS SUB ITEMS ONE IN SEVEN TO
DEPEND SHE COUNTS ON THE COUNTY
LAW LIBRARIES WILL NOW BE
RECORDED I'LL BE OUT WITH A
SEVENTEEN ZERO VOTE. OKAY NOW I
KNOW ITEM NUMBER THIS IS SUCH A
FIVE ISSUE SIX THE LEGAL AID.
THE COURT REPORTERS THE
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT RATE
THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
FIND. THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS
AND THE COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE'LL USE OUR SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
WE'LL RECORDOUR REPUBLICAN
COMMENTS CAUGHT SKEWS ME OUR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES AS NOT
VOTING IS THERE NO OBJECTION TO
THAT. OKAY THEN THOSE ITEMS
LEGAL AID COURT REPORTER'S
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT RATE
TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT FUND
COLLABORATIVE COURTS IN
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE WILL BE RECORDED AS
A THIRTEEN ALL VOTE. NOTE ZERO
KNOWS. OKAY NOW ON ITEM ON THE
SUB VITAMIN ISSUE SIX THAT'S
NUMBER EIGHT. WITHOUT OBJECTION
I WILL HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
RECORDED AS I WILL HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON REPUBLICANS. RIGHT
SENATORS NIELSEN SOLID NO
FELLING NOW GROW GROWTH NOW
MELINDA'S SNOW FALL AND IS NOW
A TRUE BOOK. VERY BAD CHEESE
SUB PART OF SSUE SIX WILL BE
RECORDED AS THIRTEEN HOURS
THREE KNOWS THE NOTICE OUT.
OKAY AND NOW ROLL CALL ON NINE
USING THE SAME DEMOCRATIC ROLL
CALL. BUT PLEASE READ THE ROLL
CALL FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
SENATOR NELSON DOLLY. DOLLY NO
GROWTH. MELINDA'S KNOW MELINDA
SNOW PATROL BOAT. ALL RIGHT ON
THAT ISSUE SIX SUBPART NINE
WILL RECORDED AS THIRTEEN EYES
TO NOSE. AND THAT IS THAT. AND
NOW WE'LL GO TO THE LAST ONE OF
THAT ISSUE SIX THE SUB CAN.
SAME ROLL CALL FOR DEMOCRATS
SENIOR OBJECTIONS PLEASE READ
THE ROLL CALL FOR THE
REPUBLICANS. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY. DOLLY NOW GROW NO PROOF
NO MELINDA NO LINDA IS NOW A
TURBO. WHAT NUMBER SIR THIS IS
THE SUB ITEM. WELL YOU KNOW
WHAT I DON'T NEED TO DO TEN WE
ALREADY DID THAT. NOW I'M
CONFUSED AS WE REPORTED THAT
FORTY SEVEN GIVE ME A PAPER
THAT HAD TEN TWICE. I'M YES ON
THAT WE ALREADY VOTED ON YES WE
ARE READY TO ANSWER SOMEONE
GAVE ME A SHEET THAT HAD THAT
CHOICE GEEZ LET IT STRIKE. THAT
WE ALREADY HAVE A VOTE ON TEN.
OR VOTE WE TOOK A VOTE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE SIX AND TEN SO
MY APOLOGIES. WE DID ALL THE
ITEMS ALL THE SUB THINGS IN
THAT ISSUE SIX. OKAY WITH GOOD.
RIGHT NOW MAKE SURE I'M GETTING
THIS GOT A LOT OF PIECE OF
PAPER HERE. HEY WE ARE. AGAIN
WITH SENATOR DRAWS MOTION WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ITEM TEN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE DEMOCRAT ROLL CALL THE SAME
AND WILL PLEASE HAVE A ROLL
CALL ON TEN FOUR ARE
REPUBLICANS. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY. GROSS RIGHT GROUP HI
MELINDA MELINDA'S I O. JOGO.
PICTUE BOOK I'D DELHI ARE
DOLLY I. K. IF YOU COULD READ
THAT VOTE OUT I DIDN'T- TALIA I
HAVE SEVENTEEN NICE NO NO BUT
THAT'S GREAT NUMBER TEN IS OUT
WITH SEVENTEEN EYES ZERO KNOWS
IT'S GO TO NUMBER THIRTEEN.
THIS IS SEPT FIVE NUMBER
THIRTEEN WILL USE THE SAME ROLL
CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
WE'LL DO A ROLL CALL FOR
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS. SENATORS
NIELSEN. DOLLY GROSS RIGHT
GROUP ONLINE LENDERS HI LINDA I
THE JOB HI I'M JOE BOGAN NINE.
SO THAT IS OUR NUMBER THIRTEEN
ZERO OR SIXTEEN ICE ZERO KNOWS.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO ITEM
TWENTY TWO. AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL USE THE SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS
WILL ISSUE A ROLL CALL
REPUBLICAN SIDE AND TWENTY
THREE- SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
SENATOR NELSON DOLLY. GROWTH
BELINDA SNELL GLENDA'S NOW A
JOB OF. RIGHT THAT ITEM IS OUT
WITH THIRTEEN HIGHEST ONE KNOWS.
BEDSIDE I'M TWENTY TWO. NOW
ITEM TWENTY THREE SAME ROLL
CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS BUT WE
WOULD DO AND ROLL CALL FOR
PUBLICANS. WOULDN'T THE
SENATORS NELSON. DOLLY GROSS
MELINDA'S- TROUBLED. THE
WINDOWS NO NO MELINDA'S NO
GROWTH NO GROWTH NOW. SO ALL
RIGHT ON ITEM THIRTEEN SORRY AN
ITEM TWENTY THREE IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN EYES TO NOSE. THANKS
FOR SUB COMMITTEE FIVE NOW.
SEPT ME FIVE ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN.
IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE OR HAVE BEEN HI
BOTH RECORDED FOR BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS. YOU
CAN CHECK THAT FOR YOU REENTRY
AND WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION FOR ANYONE
THIS IS ALL AND I BOTH THE
ENTIRE ROLL CALL RIGHT OKAY
GREAT SEEING NO OBJECTION. SEPT
ME FIVE ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
REENTRY AND WRAPAROUND SUPPORT
SERVICES SEVENTEEN ICE THAT'S
OUT. NOW BIOS- ON ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN. ON THE- SUB PARTS OF IT.
TO THREE FOR. FIVE EIGHT.
THERE'S A REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING RELIEF COUNTY
RESENTENCING PILOT PROGRAM ON
THOSE ITEMS WITHOUT OBJECTION I
WOULD HAVE THE- SHAKING YOUR
HEAD OKAY WHAT WE GOT WRONG
MADAM SEARCHES YES NOT
INSURANCE REVIEW- HE JUST
LISTED ARE YOU LISTED FIVE THIS
IS A GREAT REVIVAL WE DID OURS
REALLY SEVEN YES SOMEONE
SCRATCHED OUT MY SERVICE. IT'S
LATE I'M MOWING. OKAY THE GLAD
WE WENT TO THOSE NUMBERS JUST
ONE MARK I IT OKAY SO. THESE
ARE. SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN SUB ITEMS. TO
THREE TWO ZERO FOUR SEVEN AND
EIGHT. AND IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT
WE WILL LET'S HOLD ON TO. FOR
SEVEN EIGHT- I DIDN'T DO SIX
YET. WERE WERE OKAY YOUR. TO
NOT A CHAIR IF YOU COULD-
SEPARATE OUT ITEMS TO CARE FOR
PLEASE THE REST ARE FINE YES I
WILL. OKAY LET ME TRY THAT
AGAIN SEPT FIVE ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN. THE SUB ITEMS OF TWENTY
SEVEN THREE FOUR. SEVEN AND
EIGHT. THE NEXT REBUILD DATE OF
PROGRAMMING RELIEF AND COUNTY
RESENTENCING. THIRD OBJECTION
WE WILL HAVE THE SAME
DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL. AND THE
NOT VOTING FOR ALL REPUBLICANS
CORRECT. CORRECT SO THOSE
SPIDERS ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN SUBS
THREE FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. WE'LL
GO OUT ON A THIRTEEN ZERO VOTE.
THIRTY NINE ZERO KNOWS. AND
THEN FOR ITEM NUMBER SIX THIS
IS ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN SEP SIX.
FIFTY SAME ROLL CALL FOR
REPUBLIC BY SKEWS ME SAME ROLL
CALL FOR DEMOCRATS SEE NO
OBJECTION. AND FOR THE
REPUBLICANS UNLESS YOU OBJECT
WE'LL RECORD U. S. NO. RIGHT SO
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN SEP SIX WILL
GO OUT ON A THIRTEEN FOUR VOTE
THIRTEEN ICE FOREIGNERS. RIGHT
NOW ITEMS ONE AND TWO WE'RE
GOING TO DO A ROLL CALL THE
FIRST FOR ITEM ONE WILL US THE
SAME DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL
SEEING NO OBJECTION BUT WE'LL
READ THE ROLL CALL FOR THE
REPUBLICANS THIS IS SEPT FIVE
ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN. SEP ONE.
SENATOR NIELSEN. DOLLY NO KELLY
NOW GROWTH NO GROWTH NO MELINDA
NO MELINDA SNOW PATROL BOAT.
OKAY THAT NUMBER THREE NUMBER
ONE IS OUT THIRTEEN YES THREE
KNOWS. OKAY NOW NUMBER TWO WE
WILL NUMBER TWO MEANING ANDREA
SHE TWENTY SEVEN WE WILL HAVE
THE SAME ROLL CALL FOR
DEMOCRATS BUT PLEASE DO A ROLL
CALL FOR APPLICANTS. SENATORS
NIELSEN- SUBSECTION TWO. YES
THIS IS ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN SUB
ITEM TO. SENATOR NELSON DOLLY
DOLLY NO GROWTH NO GROWTH NO
MELINDA'S NEW ZEALANDERS KNOW
OCHO BOTH. ALL RIGHT THAT'S
GOING TO GO OUT WITH A THIRTEEN
ICE THREE NOS AND THAT IS THE
SUB TWO UNDER ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN OF OUR SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE.
OKAY NOW THIS ISSUE WILL BE
JOINING. TWENTY EIGHT. FIVE
SEVEN THREE FIVE. YOUR
ENTERTAINER MOTION BY SENATOR
ZERO ZERO. WE ALL USE THE SAME
ROLL CALL FOR THE DEMOCRATS IN
PLEASE GIVE A ROLL CALL FOR THE
REPUBLICANS SENATORS NELSON
DOLLY. GROVE MELINDA'S PATROL
BOAT HI RICHARD OKAY GREAT SO
ITEM- RATHER ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO OUT WITH
FOURTEEN ICE ZERO KNOWS. OKAY
TWENTY NINE. SAME MOTION.
SEVERAL CALL FOR DOWNS BROKE
OFF REPUBLICANS PLEASE SENATORS
NIELSEN DOLLY. GROWTH
MELINDA'S- OTRO BUG HI A
TERRIBLE GUY ALRIGHT SO. ISSUE
NUMBER FOR SECURE SORRY IS IT
IT'S ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE.
IT'S GOING UT WITH FOURTEEN
HOURS ZERO KNOWS. RIGHT NOW
THIRTY FIVE. THIRTY FIVE WE'LL
USE THE ROLL CALL WE'VE BEEN
USING FOR THE DEMOCRATS SEEING
NO OBJECTION ROLL CALL FOR
REPUBLICANS SENATORS NELSON
DOLLY NO GROWTH. KELLY NO DOLLY
NOW GROSS MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
NOW A JOB OF. GROSS HEALTH
GROUP KNOWN. CORRECT THAT ITEM
IS OUT WITH THIRTEEN ICE THREE
KNOWS. THAT'S- ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY FIVE. OKAY ITEM NUMBER
FORTY. BUT SEVERAL CALLS FOR
THE DEMOCRATS I SEE NO
OBJECTION PLEASE READ THE ROLL
CALL FOR THE REPUBLICANS
SENATORS NELSON DOLLY NO
SELLING NO GROWTH NO GROWTH NO
MELINDA MELINDA IS NOW A TRUE
BOTH. THE RIGHT ITEM FORTY IS
OUT WITH THIRTEEN ICE THREE
KNOWS. BEEN LOOKING OVER THE
VARIOUS THINGS TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE. TAKING A VOTE ON ALL OF
THE ITEMS SHARE DID WE DO ITEM
THIRTY SIX. LET ME SEE. WHAT
THE TO ME SHE. I'M GLAD YOU
CAUGHT THAT. THERE WAS NO
THIRTY SIX LISTED ON THIS LIST.
I THOUGHT I WAS BACK YOU'RE
SLEEPING ON. NOW YOU'RE NOT
SLEEPING YOU'RE GOOD. YOU'RE
GOOD CORRECT WE WILL NOW ACT ON
ITEM THIRTY SIX FOR
SUBCOMMITTEE. FIVE AND WE WILL
USE THE- DEMOCRATIC ROLL CALL I
SEE NO OBJECTION WE'LL TAKE A
REPUBLICAN ROLL CALL ON ITEM.
THIRTY SIX. SENATOR NELSON
DOLLY NO TELLING NO GROWTH NO
GROWTH NO MELINDA'S NO
MELINDA'S NOW A TROOP OF. RIGHT
ITEM THIRTY SIX IS OUT WITH
THIRTEEN ICE THREE KNOWS.
SENATOR DOLE YOU'RE SO GOOD TO
CATCH ANYTHING ELSE. IF I MAY
MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK YOU.
FOR AN EXTREMELY HARD JOB THAT
YOU HAVE THIS YEAR WITHIN THE
BUDGET LIKE I'VE NEVER SEEN
SOMEONE JUST PUBLICLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
AND I CAN'T IMAGINE JUST BEING
ON SET TO MYSELF. YOU'RE
DEALING WITH ALL THE
SUBCOMMITTEES AND THE AND THE
BUDGET I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE WITH US AND YOUR-
HARD AND DILIGENT WORK.
PRECIADO THAT. UNITED BY I WILL
EXTEND THAT RECORD I WILL TAKE
IT WITH WITH GREAT- AFFECTION
AND- THE WORD TO BE STORED WITH
BUT I ALSO EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION TO ALL OF YOU
BECAUSE THIS AS WE KNOW WAS AN
INTENSE AND VERY- WELL THIS IS
THE BIGGEST PARTY WE'VE EVER
HAD. IT ALSO THANK YOU MISTER
DALI FOR CATCHING THAT ITEM IN
A COUPLE OF OTHER SENATO
MELINDA IS A FEW OTHER FOR
CATCHING A FEW ITEMS AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY BEFORE WE WRAP UP.
THAT DURING THIS HEARING MANY
TIMES AS A COMMENTS WERE MADE-
THERE WERE PUBLIC THROUGH
PUBLIC SCHOOL A CALL THEN. I
THOUGHT MUCH ABOUT OUR FORMER
CHEER. NOW SUPERVISOR MITCHELL
IN LA SENATOR MITCHELL. AND I
THOUGHT THAT IN SO MANY AREAS.
WITH THE ATTENTION AND
INVESTMENTS WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE IN THIS BUDGET FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY CHILDREN. IN OUR
INVESTMENTS TO ADDRESS RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN HEALTH CARE
JUSTICE IN OTHER AREAS. HE
REALLY- I REALLY THOUGHT OF HER
A GREAT DEAL. AND ONE SECOND-
OKAY SO I THINK WITH THAT I
WANT TO JUST TURNED TO MY-
CONSULTANT COMMITTEE CONCERN
WE'VE CUT WE'VE DONE OUR
BUSINESS IS THAT CORRECT. PHOTO
OF COURSE SKEWS ME SENATOR
GROVE PLEASE YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BIEBER'S
COMMENTS ABOUT YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
ALLOWING US TO GO IN THE BACK
ROOM AND- AND CONSOLIDATE VOTES
TO SHORTEN THE EVENING AND
APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH US.
YOU KNOW IT YOU DID HELP US A
GREAT DEAL BY THAT. TIME AND I
WAS REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF. OUR
SECRETARY OF THE SENATE. HAVING
THE WISDOM TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO IT FASTER THAN READING A
WHOLE OR DAVE'S. WHICH I WAS
WRITING. GO BERNIE. SO LOOKING
TO MY CONSOLE AGAIN TO MAKE
SURE I DID NOT. FORGET ANYTHING
I DON'T WANT TO SELECT ANYTHING
TIXT CUP AND LIP ALL RIGHT.
MEMBERS YOU'VE BEEN PHENOMENAL.
ELECT THE NEGOTIATIONS BEGIN.
WITH THAT OUR BUDGET SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE- OUR SENATE
BUDGET AND FINANCE REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL CONCLUDE.